hello everyone and welcome to simply
learns youtube channel today we will be
taking you through the javascript and
html tutorial it is said that one must
have a basic understanding of html and
javascript in order to be
become a front-end web developer
the end of this tutorial you guys will
be able to implement both html and
javascript in different ways
so before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
technology videos so if you are a tech
geek in a continuous hunt for the latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribe to our youtube channel
and press that bell icon to never miss
any updates from simply learn so without
any further delay let's get started
let's go through the agenda for this
full course tutorial we'll start this
video with an introduction to html in 10
minutes
we'll then go through classes ids and
drop down in html after that we'll
discuss content boxes and html image
slider then we'll see how we can create
a navigation bar registration form and
quizzes in html
after all the learning we'll design a
fully functional website using all the
concepts we have learned
we'll end the html part with the roadmap
and how you can become a front-end web
developer
upon completing html we'll move on and
cover javascript as well
we'll cover everything you need to know
and understand about javascript we'll
see what javascript is and why one
should learn javascript
following that we'll cover basic
javascript topics like arrays loops and
functions in javascript along with
advanced level topics like promises in
javascript
we have some specific projects waiting
for you guys
we'll create some games at the end of
this tutorial to understand javascript
in a better way let's start this video
with an introduction to html
now what exactly is the basic web
architecture now web architecture is
made up of three essential elements
that's the website that is the front end
of a web application that is visible to
the user
then there is the server which
constitutes the back end of a web
application and holds and manages all
the data and finally there's the ip
address that is the address assigned to
a website in order to be accessible on
the internet
first up let's have a look at what
website is
so your browser starts by loading the
main html file and then the css and
javascript
the user interacts with the website and
is not concerned with the backend of an
application now secondly we have
the server once you've developed your
website you'll have to host it on your
server to make it accessible on the
internet
server along with the database contains
all the data of a website and
facilitates user interaction
lastly there's iop address which is the
third element of the web architecture
now website is hosted on an ip address
we put a domain name over that ip
address the same way we put names over
people's phone numbers
when you type a domain name in the
browser it will give you the server call
the server will then send over the
website to you
next what is html
html is the most widely used markup
language for developing and structuring
web pages on the internet
it defines the structure of websites and
formats these web pages
so what exactly is css then
now css is a simple design language used
for making web pages look more beautiful
and presentable
it can be attached to any html element
to style it or even position it
according to the developer's choice
then you must be wondering what exactly
is javascript
now javascript is a powerful interpreted
language targeted for web development
it is used for making web pages
interactive and bringing the web pages
to life
so now let's create your first website
now html short for hypertext markup
language is the coding standard for
documents designed for web browsers
consisting of a series of elements or
tags and which can be used to structure
a web page right so these elements can
include headings paragraphs
div containers tables and more htmls are
nested meaning there are opening and
closing tags with the content in between
those tags
so now let's write a simple html code
that will help you understand the basics
of the language
so for this i'm using the text editor
that is visual studio code you can go
ahead and download this text editor from
their official website so here i've
created a simple.html file in my vs code
and i've added the initial html files
now let me explain to you
one by one
now doc is not so much of a tag but it
is more of an instruction now this
indicates the browser that the document
type to be served to the user is in fact
an html document
now this doctype instruction should
always be included at the very top of
your html page
next up you have the html tag that is
used to contain all the web pages html
code
right so it contains an opening and
closing tag with contents in between
them
the html tag can also have attributes
now for example there's the lang
attribute allowing you to specify the
spoken language of the contents of the
page
followed by the http tag there's the
head tag
now this is the first section of the
that contains all the information about
the web pages properties links and more
it could have pages title description
additional meta tags and css code so
here i've used the title tag and let's
give a title say
html
in 10 minutes
all right
you can also add css to the head tag by
using the style tag and change the
display styles of html elements that are
based the next section is the body tag
now the body tag contains all the
displayable contents of your web page
including headings paragraphs div
containers tables and more
now the html header tags are used to add
headings to a web page
there are several types of headings
available for developers to add to a web
page right so first up let's have a look
at them i'm going to create a simple h1
heading tag
and the message i'm displaying is
this is
the first heading
all right
after this i'm going to
add a paragraph tag which creates
padding in the top and bottom of the
element to help separate the text
between each paragraph
right so i'm gonna add a p tag
and save
this is paragraph tag
[Music]
this let me add a simple h2 tag which is
another heading tag and say this is the
second heading
now you can also add line breaks which
are helpful from time to time if you
want to provide a single line break in
your content you can do so by adding the
br tag
so here let me just add one for
better understanding
now the html div tag defines a division
or a section in an html document that is
used as a container for other html
elements
now these elements can include content
areas sidebars page bars page headers
footers etc
this tag is used to apply styles to html
elements that cannot be added otherwise
you can also make use of the html image
tag to add images to a web page now
these images in a web page are a very
common site and they can make the
website look more attractive so for that
we can use the image tag so say img
within which i mentioned the source
[Music]
i'm adding the html logo so let me just
mention that here
and then i'm going to provide width for
it and then a specific height
all right so when you save the file
and when you look at the browser
you can see that
the first heading is displayed then your
paragraph tag is displayed followed by
the second heading and then the image
now let me show you how you can add
styles for some of these uh headings and
paragraph tags so here in back in my
first heading tag let me just say styles
and let me change the font
of the content that is being displayed
and i'm going to change it to career new
and for my paragraph tag let me display
the content in italics so i'll say font
style and make it italics
so let me save this and when i look at
the browser
you can see that the font has changed
and so has the font style here
so now we've covered a few important
html tags used to develop a web page now
there are many other tags available for
almost everything you'd want to add to a
web page now all of these are available
on the internet for you and you can use
them in your website in this tutorial
we are going to learn about the classes
and id in the html and how to use them
so
without further ado let's get started so
what is an html class
an html class attribute is used to
specify a single or multiple class names
for an html element
the class name can be used by css and
javascript to do some tasks for html
elements
you can also use this class in the css
with a specific class with a period
character followed by the name of the
class first selecting elements
so let's jump on to the demo to
understand the classes and id better so
we are on our sublime text editor
let's add the standard boilerplate of
html
we'll give the title as
classes
and id in html
let's start with the basic example
we will see how to define an html class
so inside the body tag
we'll add one h1
and we'll give this
the class name of
head one
we'll add some text here this is
the heading one
now you can copy this part because we'll
need it
enough for the lines
so for the h2
this will be the heading 2
for h3
this will be heading 3
and let's add one more h4
this is the heading 4.
so as you can see we have used the same
class name in all our h1 h2 s3 and h4
so if you save the file and
go to the page and refresh
you'll see the headings are there on the
page this is the heading 1 heading 2
heading 3 and heading 4.
now let's learn how we can use this
class name for our styling purpose
so we'll open the style tag here
and you will mention the
class name by
period followed by the class name so
head 1
open the parenthesis
and let's set the color to
lightsan
and we'll set the font family to
set quit cursive
keep the background color to black
okay so you can see we have mentioned
the class name dot head head one for our
styling purposes and we have given the
color point family and background color
for it so just save the file and go back
refresh
now you can see we have designed this h1
h2 h3 and h4 using our class tag
now let's use another example with a
different class name
so
here only will make the changes let's
name this class as h2 this h3 and let it
be h4
now you can style them separately for
the head to
we can set the color
to say light
pink and we can set the font background
color to
red
okay
now
similarly for the h3
dot
head 3
set the color to
i don't know what color this is let's
say fujisa
and set the background color
to
let's say blue
okay save the file and go back to the
page
now you can see we have design our h1 s2
h3 and h4 using the different class name
this is the example of using the
multiple classes on the same code
one thing you should note that these
class name must be separated by the
space
there are a few points you should know
while working with the class
so the first one will be the class
attribute can be used on any html
element
like any html element can have a class
name
the second point will be the class name
is the case sensitive
head one
and
if we change here to say
we'll keep this h as kept capital so
this will be wrong the style won't be
implemented on the page now if you
refresh
you can see the style is not implemented
so the class names are case sensitive
let's change this back
refresh and now you can see our design
is back
so this was all about html classes
now let's move on to the id attribute
so the html id attribute is used to
specify the unique id for an element of
the html document
it allocates the unique identifier which
is used by the css and the javascript
for performing certain tasks
in cascading stylesheet that is css we
mention an element with a specific id by
using the hash symbol followed by the id
so let's work on an example to
understand this better
so we'll use the same previous example
we'll mention the h1 and this time we'll
use the id
so id and we'll name it as head one
this is the first heading
for h2 also
will mention the id name as head one
only
head one
this is the
second heading
now to style the heading we'll go back
here
we'll open the style tag
and we'll use the hash symbol to mention
the id so hash
head one open the parenthesis
we'll set the color to
light green
we'll set the font family to cursive
and we'll set the background color
to black
okay
now save the file and go back and
refresh
so you can see this works a similar
manner to the class apart from it that
we use the hash symbol to mention the id
name
so
now let's change the example and use the
different id names for different
exponents
so this can be h1
this can be h2
let's add one more
we'll name it as id
head 3
okay
so
we'll style the
head too
we'll set the color to red
for head tree
we set the color to yellow
let's use green yellow okay
save the file
go back
and refresh
now you can see we have the different
style for different ids
so in this way you can use the different
ids
to design your html page
in this tutorial we are going to learn
how you can create
a drop down in your navbars using just
html and css so we are on a sublime text
later i have the dot html and dot css
file ready so let's start by adding the
standard boilerplate
let's give it a title
link your css file to the html file
now inside the body i'll add the ul's
we have added this hash so that when you
click on this home button it won't
redirect you to anywhere
so just save the file
and we'll go back to our page
so you can see we have this home here
okay so let's add some more
so just copy paste this
and we'll name this section about
now inside this about i'll require some
submenus
so inside this i'll open another ul tag
we'll add sections such as team
clients
career and legacy
and we'll close the ali tag here
okay now save the file and go back here
and refresh
now we'll add some more
so
here
we'll add the ally for contact
okay so inside this contact i'll add the
sub menus
so
you will
and i'll
copy this code and i'll edit it here
okay so inside the contacts i'll need
email
phone
let's click
twitter
and this will be my linkedin
okay
now we'll add some more sections
we'll name the services
and this one will be my news
okay so this looks fine
a little bit of alignment
yeah
so you can see
we have this home about contact services
and news and inside this we have the sub
menus
okay we forget to
add here
hash inside the specifics
just mention hash
everywhere
okay save the file
go back and refresh okay
so you can see we have this html ready
now let's go back to the css and design
these
drop downs
so first inside our html
select the body tag
we'll add one background image so just
the background looks
more
attractive
so i have an image file saved so i'll
jpg so save
go back
and refresh
yeah you can see we have this black
thing
we'll shrink this image
so
we'll keep the background size to cover
and we keep the font family to arial
okay
so for the ul tag
we'll keep the margin to zero
we'll keep the padding to zero as well
and we'll set the list style to none
okay now
we'll design the uli part
so we'll keep the float to left
width will set to 200 pixels
we'll set the height to say 40 pixels
um we keep the background color
to something darker say
keep the opacity to 0.9
line height 40 pixels
uh keep the text aligned
to center
and font size two
20 pixels
save the file go back and refresh
okay you see we have the background
image in the place we have this snap bar
in the place
and all the drop downs are here
okay
now it's time to design ul
li and a
so for this we'll keep the text
decoration to none
color let's keep white
and we'll set the display to block
save the file and go back
now we'll add the hover effects for this
drop downs
okay
so ul
li
a.4
we'll keep the background color
for the hover
to say
anything you can circulate select light
caliber
save
let's see how it looks on the page
refresh
yeah it's look good
now the final part of this requires this
to shrink inside just when you hover
over this so the drop downs will appear
okay
so we'll set this ulli
li 2
display none
and will add the hover effect over like
so that when we hover the drop down
appears
save
go back and refresh
now you can see all the drop downs are
inside this
and hover over it and the drop downs
appear
okay
so this is all about the drop downs menu
in html i saw that we can create the
beautiful dropdowns just by using the
html and css nothing fancy
in this video we are going to create the
content boxes which are used in web
pages for various purposes
so let's see an example of what we are
going to create so in this video we are
going to create something
like this this is the content box with
the icon and the description of the
content box
icons here used is from the font
awesome cdn
so let's start creating
so i have my two files open which is
html and css
let's add the standard boilerplate
we'll add the content
boxes in html
as the title
let's link our css file
now inside the body
let's add a div class container
inside the disk class container i'll
create another div box
i will require three such boxes so we'll
copy paste this three times
on the style sheet
let's set the margin
to zero
and padding also to zero
we'll set the font family
to sans serif
now
for the container
class
we'll set the position to relative
and we'll set the width to 1200 pixels
which is the whole width of the content
box
we'll set the height
to 300 pixels
and we'll set the margin
to
240 pixels and auto
for the boxes inside the container
we'll add the position
relative
and will set the width to
let me explain what this is
this css type function is used to
perform a calculation to be used as a
property value
this is specifically used for the width
of the div classes
it requires a mathematical expression
the result will be used as a value
so we'll be using lot of this type
function here in this code
we'll set the height to
300 pixels minus 30 pixels
one property of calc function is that it
takes single expression as its parameter
the expression can be any simple
expression combining the following
operators
plus so that is addition minus that is
subtraction multiplication and division
we will set the background to hash 0 0 0
we'll set it to float left
and we'll specify the margin to 15
pixels
um we'll set the box sizing to border
box
overflow will be hidden
and border radius
let's set it to 10 pixels say
just save the file and let's go back to
the page to see how it currently looks
so you can see our boxes are in the
proper places
we have the background black with the
proper margin between them
okay so we have the structure
let's code more
now we need the icon
for that
we will require a icon from the font
awesome
cdn so we'll add the font awesome cdn to
our page
so we will search
quantosim
cdn 4.7.0
we are using the older version because
it is more stable
so go to this font awesome
libraries
here select the version and copy the
link tag
go back to the page and add it here
delete this integrity part
now
here inside this class box
add one div which will be named class
icon
and inside here we'll add the link of
the icon so search here
font or some icon 4.7
go to the first one
here you can search the any icon you
want uh let me search for
say
information
so i'll go to the information
and i'll copy this
go back to the code and add it here
now inside this i'll create another div
which will be for use for content
so we'll name it class content
and inside this i'll add one h3
info
and inside it
i'll add some
text
uh
copy this much from here
to here
now delete this whole part
and put it inside
p tag
so inside the p tag
and then
yeah
so
let's go back to the file and see how it
looks right now
okay so you cannot see the icon here
because it is black let's try to change
the color here
so that you can see the icon
so let's set it to ff0
okay so you can see i have the icon in
place this is and this is the text that
we have added to this content box
now let's style this content box first
set it back to 000.
now
general dot box
dot icon
set the position to absolute
set the top
to zero
left to zero
and we'll set the width to 100
we'll set the height also to 100 percent
background will be hash f00
i will set the transition
to 0.5 seconds
and we'll keep the z index as one so
that the icon will be visible
okay
refresh
yeah you can see the icon here
okay
now let's add the whole effect on that
so container dot
box dot
over
icon
we'll set the
top to 20 pixels
calculate the left to
[Music]
50
minus 40 pixels
with
80 pixels
i keep it 280 pixels as well
and let's set the border radius
to 50
okay
so now that we have
repeat
so now that we have added the hover
effect let's save and go back to the
page
now let's
design the icon so container dot
box dot icon
dot fa
also set the position to absolute
top will be 50 percent
left 50 percent
transform let's translate it to
minus 50
minus 50
and keep the font size to
80 pixels
transition 0.5 seconds
and we'll set the color to
save the file and let's go back to the
page
yeah so you can see our icon has now
bigger size and with the hover effect it
shrinks for text to visible
now we need to add the hover effect to
the icon so that the font size increases
for that we'll add container
box dot over
we'll keep the font size to
shows
okay
now it's time to design the content
inside the container box so we'll set
container
dot box
dot content
all the positions are absolute
we'll set the top two hundred percent
so that when the icon shrinks the whole
text will be visible to the text box
we'll set the height
to will calculate it
100
minus 100 pixels
text align center
keep the padding to 20 pixels
for proper spacing
box sizing as border box
transition to 0.5 seconds
and we'll keep the opacity
to zero
okay save the file and let's go back
yeah and you can see the icons are in
the center of the shrinking circle
now let's add the hover effect
now when you set the opacity to one
another text
okay we are not designed yet s3 and p so
let's start designing it
so container
dot box
dot content h3
10 pixels
keep the padding to zero
color
and let's keep the font size to 24
pixels
now you will see the text will be
visible inside the box
so refresh
yeah
you can see this is the heading of our
like this content box
now similarly let's style the paragraph
tag
so container
dot box
dot content
e
margin will be zero
padding will be also zero
and color will be
fff as usual
if
yup we are almost there
now we will design these two boxes with
some spacing and effects over here
now
inside this
delete them we'll copy paste the above
code here
so copy from here dip class container
we'll change the icon classes here
so for this let's keep search as
a rch
instead of copying the class by going
back to the font cd we can directly add
the class search here if we know the
name of the class
and here we can add
location
so the class name for location is map
marker
save the file and let's go back
yeah
now you can see
these things are here
with the good content box when you hover
over this box the
this whole thing shrinks and you can see
the text visible
now add we'll add some styles we'll
change the color and we'll add one
background here so that when this
shrinks the background color of the
black changes
okay
so we'll go back to our code
so to change the color of the box
we'll have a dot
container
dot
box
and we'll use the nth child property and
child
one because the first box
dot icon
so we will keep its background to
think
okay
and dot container
box and child
one
its color will be when it shrinks
let's keep it to orange
yeah
so save the file
go back
and refresh
okay so you can see we have the icons in
places and when you go
click on here so the hover effect
shrinks this and this is the pink in
color we have the background orange with
some text here
you can see
smooth transitions
so
this is all for the content boxes in
html you can use different icons here
using this font at awesome icon and
there are several icons here you can use
any of them
and just make sure that the padding and
the text are aligned in the proper
places in this video we'll learn how you
can create a beautiful html slider by
using just html and css and a little bit
of javascript
our image slider looks something like
this
we have the background image and this
images that i have taken
for example purpose we have these radio
buttons and we click on the radio
buttons
we can go through our images one by one
also the images will change
automatically after sometimes as you can
see
so let's see how we can create this
image slider
so here in the desktop i have created
one file where i have the required
images
and html and css file
so first in the experiment style let's
add our radio buttons
so we'll create one theme
which will be named as this class slice
inside this bib cache slides will add
the radio buttons
so input
the input type will be radio
and let's give this name
radio button
and we'll tag them with id radio 1.
so as you can see
we'll need four buttons here so we'll
add four radio buttons here
so just copy paste this four times
here choose the id to radio 2 radio 3
and video 4 so we can distinguish
between our four radio buttons
so after the creating the video buttons
we'll add our required images so we'll
create android div and limit class
slide first
inside
i'll create an image tag
and specify the path of the image
in a similar way we create a
four div tags for four images
so just
will do simply
another with class name
slide
inside this image
2.jpg
uh
so just save the file and let's recheck
our code
we have the review buttons we have the
images so let's just go back to our file
and see how it looks
so if we refresh
we see we have the four radio buttons
here and
some distorted images
so
let's just fix this images in the css
so inside our css file
we'll add the body
and we'll set the margin to 0 pixels
padding to zero
we'll set the height to say under
vertical height
we'll set the display to flip
uh we'll justify the content to center
we'll set the align items to center
and we'll set the background to black
so just
refresh this file
so we still need to fix these images
so just
set the slider width to
800 pixels
this there's an error we'll set this
width
we'll set the height
to 500 pixels
we'll set the border radius
to 10 pixels
and overflow will keep as hidden
for the slice
part i'll set the width to 500 percent
high to 500 pixels
and display to flat
let's save the file and see how it looks
on the page
so yeah you can see the image is now in
a proper size you have to click the
studio button we have the background
black
so let's fix this things
so for the slide input
okay before starting this let's add some
more html content here
so after adding the image we have to
create the automatic navigation button
and the manual navigation button
so after this
add another div
the class name
navigation
auto let's see
and inside this navigation auto will add
dev
class
auto button one
we need the full button so we'll copy it
four times
and this will be
my button two
this is the button three and this will
be button
navigation button so we'll name this
navigation
make sure it's spelled right navi
navigation
manual
and inside this
bow we'll add our radio buttons usually
manual
we'll name it class
manual button
we need the core button so we will copy
it four times
we change the label to radio 2
radio 3 and radio 4
so i think this will work enough so here
we have the navigation
okay we have a spell mistake here
class and navigation kind of invested
classes
so let's recheck our code
it's a good pattern to recheck your code
so that you don't encounter any error so
okay we have a different slider here
and inside the zip clock slider we have
the four radio button d one two c pro
we have our added all images
inside the div tags with the name slide
okay
we have created a navigation auto
the four buttons and navigation manual
buttons okay
so let's save the file and go back and
refresh it to see how it looks
okay
we have to add some css here
so inside the slides
input
before the display was done
all the dots slides in vector
now we'll add the style for image
we'll set the width to 800 pixels
and we'll set the height to say 500
pixels
okay
so let's save the file and just go back
to see how it looks right now
okay so you can see the images are
properly aligned here
we have to style our radio buttons for
here so let's go back to our css
now the code we are going to write here
for the manual slide navigation so just
add here comment manual slide navigation
so yeah
repeat for that we will remember the
code
so we'll add the first
class navigation manual
we'll set the position to absolute
then set the width to 800 pixels
will not have the height here will set
the margin
so the margin top will be
minus 40 pixels
this will keep it as black
and the justified content
will be center
so let's go here and
go back to the page to see how it looks
right now
okay the images are in the center you
can see
now we cannot see the regular buttons
just as now we have to add some color to
it so that the radio buttons will be
visible
so go back to our css
solid and red
you can take any color you want
we'll set the padding to 5 pixels
we'll set the border radius to
say 9 pixels
we set the cursor to point pointers so
that when whatever buttons the cursor
will look as a pointer
and we'll set the transition to one
second
save
go back and refresh
so now you can see the buttons are here
not properly spaced but yeah they're
here
so let's add the spacing and everything
else
so we will set the manual button
we'll set the margin
right to 40 pixels
and it's time to add the over effect so
for the manual
button
will be on save
background
the color
so just save the file and go back and
refresh
yeah so you can see our manual buttons
are in place
when you go over it you can see the blue
effect and when you click
nothing happens right now because we
don't have any javascript response to
this data button
we'll add them in the end
first let's design these buttons so this
is for the manual button
now we'll add one code which will be
used when you want to save the radio
button by default
so let's understand how those video
buttons work in this file so the radio
button is used where two or more options
are identified which are mutually
exclusive and the user has to do exactly
one trust
in other words taken on a non-selected
reader button will erase any of the
button letters selected on the list
previously
derivatives into lower cognitive layers
as they permanently keep all the options
visible such that users can easily
analyze them
radio buttons are also simple to use for
users who have difficulty making
effective mass movements
so we'll add hash radio
dot check
so the sign that we have added here is
more signaling combinator
it combines two sequence of simple
selectors having the same parent and the
second must come immediately after the
first
so
we add dot first
and for this we set the margin left
to zero
okay so this will be radio one
the label that we added in our manual
buttons
we'll need four such
buttons so we'll copy this four times
one two three and four
this will be my for radio button 2
and we'll set the margin left here to
minus 20 pixels
for radio button 3
set it to say
minus 40 pixels
i'm going to forget to add
pixelation
and for the last button
we'll set it to minus 60 pixels
so all this code is for the manual
navigation button
now let's design for automatic
navigation button
so
we open dot navigation
we'll set the position to absolute
then set the display to flag
set the width
to 800 pixels
and let's justify the content of the
center
and insert the margin top
to save for 60 pixels
let's set 460 pixels
now
so i'll add this guy to navigation auto
so
navigation control
div
then set the border
solid red
make sure you keep this separator solid
and same in both the navigation auto and
navigation manual because if you change
the
so we'll just keep it here red
we'll set the padding to five pixels
we'll set the border radius to nine
pixels
and we'll set the transition to 1
seconds
now same code as here which i have added
for
checking out the radio buttons
so we'll just copy this whole code
and paste it here
i'll have to tweak some things here
so the class was navigation dot auto
so we'll add here
navigation auto
dot
auto button one
we will filter some background
so we'll delete this code
um
background let's say
any color
pink
so
copy this code control c
delete this whole thing
and just change the radio button here
this will be really button
this will be three
and this will be phone
now we have all the designing in place
now we have all the designing in place
let's go back to the code and refresh
so now you'll see everything is in place
the background is that that the images
is perfectly aligned we have this button
so let's click
so when you click you see the images
slides this is the photo image
third
second
and first so
your beautiful image slider is ready
all right now is left is to add the
javascript code to this image to
function in automatic manner
so now we will go back to this html file
and below this div tag
we'll open one script tab
and inside the script tag
will create one
variable game counter
set it to 1.
open weekly function set interval
so
so what this part specifically does is
we have created one
variable named counter and it will check
against the id that we have created in
radio
when the radio button is
checked and it encounters
the counter will be plus plus that
control increase by one
so
after the counter has reached the floor
so it will get back to the starting
point that is one
so
the whole point of this code is to
make the images slide in in a loop
so just save
and go back
now when you refresh
you'll see the images will move after
sometimes
specifically two seconds
now when the images reach the last stage
it goes back to the first
you can also change it by clicking here
manually
when we talk about html based
development so in html page development
navigation is very important where you
have multiple pages attached to so that
when you click on this page or click on
any hyperlink it will take you to the
new page now so that you can move back
and forth so this navigation is very
essential part of any web development so
that you can offer the navigation so
this
simple application of html they would
like to start from scratch so let's go
and create a new folder now and give the
name called navigation
and inside this navigation we want to
create some new pages
so
here i'm going to create index
dot html
the css name would be
app.css and along with this we would
like to also create some new folder
inside this i'll keep all the navigation
files inside this so i can select pages
inside this pages let me have total
number of three pages with me one is
called about
dot html
then we create
contact
dot html
then we create one more that is called
services.html
dot html
so these three links we will create it
one by one but first let's start with
the index.html
so what's there in my index.html file
so
first thing i would like to start with
my same html syntax
here
well
this is my basic construct so i will
start with my
link real from here so that i can have
my stylesheet with me link are you equal
to stylesheet href equal to
app.css though i have not written
anything but i just left it as a blank
in my body tag i would start with the
navigation so html5
brought you some new tags knowns call
a nav tag which is once
again won't change anything drastically
in your browser however they are called
cementex which will help you for the
seo that stand for search engine
optimization so i'll start with my nav
inside my nav i will start with my div
div
i'll say
navigation bar so but before that i say
class equal to
heading
there is my div tag
and inside my tip tag i want to bring my
heading so i say h4
and i said
navigation bar
and after the div tag i will start with
my ui tag which is the unordered list
inside my
unordered list i can set li that stand
for list items
and i can offer lot many links inside
this so you will i just offer the class
equal to
nav hyphen
links
and inside this my array tag i say
a which is a anchor tag
so
a link href equal to
now here i offer
the name i say index
dot html
and
that's it and this will be by default
active so we say
class equal to
active
a
class equal to it
active and hdf equal to
file and here we offer home
for home page
i'll copy this line
and paste it for other three urls
so
here
the
active won't be there
instead we say hrf equal to
the location called pages
under this pages
we say about about.html and here we say
about
okay copy this
paste it
and a part of this about we always say
services.html
and here we say
services
inside this we offer
contact
contact
okay
and once the nav tag is over
i will offer the div
div plus
equal to just give the name body hyphen
text
i just say
h1 tag inside this
and this is the home page
that's it so that's my home page which
is ready with me
and along with this whichever the other
pages are also available
those pages i also want to use
so first of all let me check how this
page looks like it
well it looks like a pretty basic page
so once this page is ready what i will
do is
here
i copy the content
and paste it here
and above and let's see what's there in
my above see few things will change
number one here
this app.uses
now here we have to just use
dot dot
there's an app.css for me
so
you have to offer some title too so
after this link area
beautiful title this title i can say
about
okay
so rest everything is fine
so h4 navigation bar nav links here i
have to offer the links for my base html
page
so
when i talk about index.html file
okay it won't come so
index.html5
so i won't say it is an active anymore
let's just remove this line
class equal to let's
normal h
but about would be active in this case
so
a
class equal to
active h of this services
contact
is as usual saying but i would not be
having any
pages anymore
because we are in the same location
that's why
and here i say this is a
about this is about page
about page
so
that's it
i'll go back and check
if it all fine home is active right now
about you can see it as an about page
right now
the word page is just appear as it is
saying
contents are more or less looks like and
same that is why you are able to see
now just like that
just go back and copy the others
now here
up css navigation bar
active
it is in contact so make contact as an
actor
so textual html file remains same this
is
contact page
so
that's how it is
and
it will say about my
other properties which is my
services
copy sorry
copy this contact
and here
i'll be activating my
service in this case
so
class equal to active i remove it from
here
make it available here this is
service page navigation index page is
about active yeah all looks good heading
about over here i change
service
there's a change to
contact so looks fine
let's see
okay
service contact
about
so far about we need to check where we
need to go
so we have got pages about.html pages
also there
so
all there so we would like to see
how the about page will be activated
here
index.html file also contains an about
so here
when i
refresh
well
[Music]
we will call index.html page
talk about about
where is an about page now
services
so like this
it is happening for you
okay
so
that's how exactly my thing is
so we're all good
and
services contact
home all good
well my page is now ready and going
forward we would like to beautify my
pages by offering the css well let's get
started with our css file
so in my css file i will start with my
common properties
which is margin
i'm saying 0 pixel
followed by padding
i'm making a zero pixel again
again we want box sizing
this is a border
iphone box
okay
well going forward this is my standard
settings for all different type of
properties now i want the other
properties to be get introduced that is
called box body text
dot
body
hyphen
text
inside this body text i said display
flex
now when i see where the body text is
available going to my text.html file
body text is available here div class
so here in my css file i can say body
text display reflex
i say font family
font family i can give anything
i'm just giving call mod
share it
these two
we are offering it
later on align items
enable item center
followed by justify content
and making the center
then margin top
[Music]
250 pixels
these are the properties are there
followed by
okay first let's check what is an effect
here
see
it looks better now
now we would like to go ahead with the
nav
i already have this nerf with me
now
display
flex
then justify content
space around
followed by
align item
align items i want to make center
and then we want to say min height
so
we say min
hyphen
okay so min height we are giving 8vh
followed by background color
just set d
same color
and uh
same font family i just copy this form
timely and make it available here
well let's check
there we go so navbar looks awesome but
i still feel the links needs to be
justified we want to make it even more
better but before that i offer the
nav links so here
i say
nav links so dot nav
hyphen links
this nav links will have display
flex
display
flex and then justify content
that i want to make it space around
again
followed by width
so
[Music]
width
so width would be 20
perfect
and now
nav link
li dot
nav links
li
this
list style
none
let's see how it is changing
there we go that it looks really nice
so now links are ready and
i want to make it a heading
heading
i want to make it more organized so
let's see about a heading
so here i say
dot
heading
and inside this heading i say color
which is white
followed by text
transform
text text transform upper case
followed by letter spacing
this letter spacing will be 5 pixels
and followed by large font size
and this font size is just 20 pixel
that's it and let's see what is
differentiate
here awesome so this navigation bar is
now looking great
and it is giving me all the basic
operation whichever we have expected now
this nav links whichever we have created
okay they are working fine but i just
want to make it even more beautiful
and how i can make it more beautiful to
make it i would like to go ahead with
the nav links again
dot
nav links of type anchor tag
now i would like to activate my anchor
tag by making it color
white
okay followed by text decoration
text decoration
and followed by letter spacing
let us pressing 3 pixels
and then
font weight
font weight bolt
and font size
14 pixels
and padding
14 pixels
and 16 pixels
both options
that's it
and
followed by we want to use the nav links
when i will over it so the color should
change so we are saying dot
nav links
and here with li
followed by a dot
active when the anchor tag is active
then in that case i want to change the
background color
to
lights light see green i can say
lights
so
[Music]
we have this option called light see
green
this one light that looks beautiful
and followed by say
i copy this
and this active
so nav links like dot active
background color we are using but if it
is not active then in that case what you
will use so
i can just change the small thing
here
i've changed this color
uh
now let me try to copy this first
i tell you about what i want
to copy this and paste it as usual here
what i see is when it is an active
okay when it is an active i will change
the color to
i think the spelling is wrong
active it should be
active background color i want to change
it to green so for that we are just
using the color
hash
this is a green color where it is
inactive and when this is not active
so we can just say a colon
active
which is used now now like colon active
or we can say equal over
equal
over
a colon
over and here we say colon
not
dot
active
that's it
let's see how it works
awesome this looks beautiful home homes
are active right now you say it is on a
home page
i can see it is an above page it is
service page it is a contact now you can
see it looks even more
awesome in this html piece hands-on we
are expecting that all of you are aware
about the basic concept of html as well
as the css so this kind of learning is
going to help you to understand like how
html and css can connect together while
offering you a mini application the
first application on this track we're
going to offer you that is related to
your html registration page okay so
as you know for this particular
registration development application i
would like to use the visual studio code
which is one of the very very popular
tool provided by microsoft so this tool
we will be using it for our mini
application development so let's get
started with this so step number one let
me go back and create a new folder now
i'm going to create a new folder name
for registration
and inside this i would require two
files number one it's called index dot
html
another one that is called
css we can say
app.css
so in index.html file
we want
some standard development so i want to
start with my html tag
so
i already have this
html base autofill code provided by your
visual studio code so there are plugins
are available inside this so that you
can automatically create the basic
structure for this html which you can
have the html tag head tag
as well as the body tag and from this
point onwards we will start developing
our code now
so
i want to develop a registration page so
in this registration page i will start
from my
form tag now so inside this form it is
saying like form action to something i
really do not have any backend so i just
leave it as a blank and here i will
start with my h1 tag where i want to say
register
after this register i want to offer the
paragraph tag
where i can say please
fill
in this
form
to
register with us
register
with s
okay
now after that i would like to start
with horizontal row so hr
so
starting with my horizontal row
and pause this because see we would like
to organize our application and now
level
in this level for
i just want to give the name called fn
it's just the name
and after this fn stands for the first
name
and within this level i would like to
use the b tag which is a i would say
that hold here i will pass first name
bold tag is closed it's a label
inside this label i would like to use
input tag
here i will call input tab equal to text
and offer a few other details also like
i say a placeholder
placeholder will offer you what to be
filled i'll say first name
that is
the placeholder value after this name
equal to
fn that is a stand for first name
after that id
id is option
but if you want to pass we will use this
id fn
id equal to fn
and
required
because i want this field cannot be
black
so this is my
first text box where i have this
first name with me
like that i will go ahead and talk about
my
next property or password and for
password also i would like to have the
similar details with me
so this label i'll copy
and paste it below
and this is for
your password so we're giving the name
called psw
here we are saying password
and uh input type of view text
so here i will change input application
to password
because password field
details would not be visible to you
please
here we say
placeholder i can say enter
password
name equal to
you can give psw
id equal to we can give same psw
so
we have a call password it is similar
like we would like to offer the confirm
password fields too
i will copy this line
and paste it again
and here we can say confirm password
you can say
cpsw
again password
enter
confirm password cpsw
and cpsw
now it's over
after this we want to make it as a
horizontal rule
closed
and once it is run then we like to have
the button with this
so here is the button we can say
register
here in my button
i would like to offer the type equal to
submit
are we going to
submit
so that's it so this is
the simplest form i have it
now i would like to see how it really
looks like it
so from here i would like to open it
revealing finder
let's open this
well it looks like that
fine so this is what my formless form is
ready and now we would like to go back
and start developing my css in which i
would beautify my form to offer some
more details of this
well friends as we know the html page is
ready it's time to go back and start
developing a css to beautify my html so
inside the css i would like to start
with the tag which is a call body
and
inside this body tag i can offer some
basic setups but
i just want to give the basic background
color now which is called
background iphone color
i can just give the name called t here
that's a background color let's the rest
of the things i can just leave it as it
is now for all the other properties i
can say box sizing
border iphone box
that
dot container
container
and in this container we have to offer
certain benefits
now first thing you need to understand
which other places
i will be using the container so you see
here in my index.html file
uh
when we talk about form actions and all
okay we say h1 register we haven't used
any container right now so let's get
added the container
div
class equal to
container
okay and this particular div tag will
get closed only at the last
so
this tip tag
will close at the last
here so i want to make
the look and feel for this complete
container
in much more better way so here in my
container we want to say
margin auto
let's press enter here
margin
auto
now width
50
then adding
16 pixel
followed by background color
which you want white
then box shadow
this box shadow we want to give some all
four origins 20 pixels
to same 20 pixel
and zero pixel
and which color we want so i just say
rgba
in this rgba we just give the value call
0
again
0.
again 0
and
the value which you want to give to this
alpha because it is always between
0 to 1 we are saying 0.7 that is an
opacity
four properties is given
now let's see how it looks
yeah why because we haven't added a css
in my html so let's add the css so
inside my
browser html
now inside my head let me add link
link rl equal to style sheet href equal
to
app.css
that's it
now let's see
there we go looks better now
so this is your container okay which you
can see it is having some shadow i would
like to organize this all set up text
boxes in much more better way
so
after this
we want to offer the other
properties to liken for my input
go back to my css
so after this container we want input
input again
time equal to
text
now
also to
input
type
equal to
here we offer few things number one
width
which is 100
after
sorry
then padding
once again 15 pixels
then margin
you're offering 5 pixels
0
22 pixel
0
followed by display
display i will say inline block
inline block
followed by border do you want any
border
so i say null
border none and background
we can offer the color
so we can say
white smoke
that's it let's see in my html
awesome so this looks more beautiful
more organized so this is
your form but i want to make it even
more better now because i want to
perform the validation and in validation
we want to check how the focus will come
in so the beautification needs to be
added more
here
we want to offer the same input type
text input type password i copy this
here
now here we want to offer background
color
we want to open the background color on
focus
this has to be on focus
focus and here also
on focus
now background color
we want to change to anything but for a
typing we can just give
same
and
outline
now
okay so this is my for focus and for the
registration button
so
here we see dot
i do not have that class for register
button so i have to create this class
inside my
button
registered btl
i would like to offer the properties for
those like background
color t
followed by color
which is
white
then padding
we offer 16 pixel
then border
no
then cursor
i think it is better to have pointer
only
then with
100
solve by margin
this auto
then opacity
then i say 0.8
fine so this is for my registration
button
let's see
wow this looks better now so this is a
full size button
so this is for my button
and i want the moment i take my cursor
on button
the color should change or it should
look like it hover
copy this
over
and here we say opacity
which is with the value for 1
that's it
now you see now the color is changing
great so like this you see how the
conditions are working when i press on
register you see the messages
please fill the field blank and it is
changing
the
when we talk about the situation
called focus so in this it works like
that when i give the name
you see now how the background color is
changing now so it is little bit more
grayish color so this time we gonna
develop another very interesting example
using this html
javascript
and css together and that is called
working with a quiz application so one
of the very very interesting
projects will be developing it from the
scratch and i'm sure that you will enjoy
a lot
so what we will do will start creating a
new folder now first of all i'm gonna
give the name called
html
quiz
now i'm gonna create a three files
inside this number one i'm gonna say
index.html index.html
then i need another file that is called
app.css
and the third file i'm going to create
inside this that will hold the script
related part so we are saying script
torches
so we have total number of three files
ready with us
now from html page we would like to
develop this html tags first
so we'll go to the html and see
so we have got this basic html syntax
ready and from here we will start
working with the div tag first
here onwards depth
so within my tab tag
we would like to create
another div tag
okay
so the first top level class
to this particular tip
see we haven't created a css but we
would like to offer some of the css
classes available here so we see
the class equal to container
now we have got another tab tag inside
this we will set div
id equal to question hyphen container
question hyphen
container so that is the name or id of
this div
and we say class
equal to hide
now within this step tag
we would like to offer some details but
before that we would like to create some
embedded div tags inside this so we're
going to create another tab tag here
and this tab id
equal to
answer
answer hyphen buttons
so that's the id name and we would like
to offer the class also
class equal to
btn hyphen grid see again i'm telling
you these classes we are just creating
it
but we would like to use this
in our css
okay so they are just the normal
classrooms we are giving it right now
now inside this dev tag
we want to offer
some more details
now what exactly the details are number
one i would like to offer a few buttons
now
button
so we see a button class
equal to btn
and after that we would like to give the
name called answer1
answer one
so that i can have this button class
copy it three more times
and now we can change
the names two
two
here three
here four so we have total number of
four answers ready with us
dev tag is getting closed here another
two tag is getting closed here
and now here
before the last tip tag is getting close
we would like to create another div tag
now inside this div we say
class equal to controls
that's another tip tag so under this div
we want to offer few more buttons
button here we say button id equal to
start button
start iphone
btn okay and then we say class
class equal to start
hyphen
btn
space
btn
and we say start here
now just copy this
complete line
and put it again
so
rather than giving the start button
we say
next button and class equal to
next hyphen button
next hyphen button
btn and we will give additional property
called height
and here we give the value called next
let me make this s capital
and
next
two buttons we have created
after this
div tag is getting closed
after that i would like to start another
tab tag
and if this tip tag we will offer
class equal to score
okay
and here
we would like to start working with a
span
and here we will say span
id equal to
right hyphen
answer
or answers i can say
so
after that the div tag is getting closed
and
that's it and it last
the last step tag is getting closed
which you can see right now we would
like to use the script tag
but one more thing
this drive tag i would like to close
even before
so two tip tags are getting close and
this is another tip type which is closed
at the end
and here we want to include the script
tag
script
src equal to
script.js
that's it our html page is almost ready
let's review
and
yes i can see
some standard buttons has been created
now we would like to look make gives a
better look and feel to this kind of
button cell
complete ui by offering some awesome css
okay everybody so we'd like to start
working with css part now
so to work with the css we have to offer
few things
here
we're providing a route and with this
route some basic settings we are
offering it number one
hyper hyphen hue hyphen neutral
hue
hyphen
hyphen hyphen q
hyphen neutral the value is giving a
score 200
after that we're giving call hyphen
hyphen hue
again
hyphen rom
this value we are giving is
zero
then we are saying hyphen hyphen here
hyphen
correct
145
so these three values we have given
followed by body
in this body we would like to offer few
details number one
hyphen hyphen hue
this we are making with the variable
hyphen hyphen u
neutral
the one which we have already declared
okay now we will try to provide padding
so this padding we are giving zero
next property is margin
module will also remain zero
after that display
and then
after that not display i would say
instead it is better we can have
flex
after that width
we're providing width almost 100
followed by height
so height we are providing is called
once again hundred
okay now we have called justify contents
this justify contents i can say center
perfect going forward
align items
here we can say
center again
now background color
which color you would like to give it so
we can just use this option called
hsl and this will we would like to use
this var
again this in this world we are using
iphone hyphen view
and followed by
100 percent
comma
20
these things and this is style we
wouldn't we would like to use in my
index.html page
so within my head tag
well
in index.html5 how you would like to
refine the styles we always use
link
link
css
so the value is automatically style.css
but we would like to change to app
dot css that's it
now let's see the final outcome
now it looks better
okay so it is only for the background
nothing else it is impacting
now we want to offer
few more things into my css it is only
for the body
now we would like to go ahead with the
body dot
correct
body dot correct
we're providing
queue
and here we would like to offer
iphone iphone draw
and also sorry not wrong just for
correct
and
we can use
body
dot wrong
body dot round so same thing i'd like to
copy
so rather than saying correct
using
wrong
well these two properties we have
defined
going forward we would like to start
working with a container
container inside my container i would
like to offer width
basic thing
that we are providing 800 pixels
followed by
max weight
this max would be 80
now going forward background color
background color we are offering white
that always looks better
followed by border radius
border radius that we are providing 5
pixels
after this padding
this padding will be 10 pixels
followed by box shadow
this box shadow we can say 0
0
10 pixels
2 pixels
so this is we have applied for the
container and container is used
right over here let's see
okay that looks better
so this is where it comes under my
container
now
we would like to offer the buttons
here
in our css
we want to now offer the button colors
so
dot
btn
hyphen
grid
well
in index.html file so we have a call
button grid
this button grid we would like to start
from here
btn grid beating grid display
great
followed by grid
hyphen
template columns
so here we are saying repeat
in this repeat we are saying 2
comma
auto
then we would like to offer the gap
this gap will be the 10 pixels
followed by margin
that will be the 20 pixels
and then 0.
this is for my button grid let's see
awesome so that looks pretty nice
now
going forward we would like to apply the
styles of my button
so how my button will looks like
well button grids we have created it now
we would like to go ahead with the
buttons
so dot ptn
followed by the details so
iphone happen
here var
we'll be using neutral
okay
going forward we would like to use
border
so this border we want to use
12 pixels
or i would say one pixel
and then solid
and hsl
values you would like to give it once
again
qr
hyphen iphone u
followed by
100
30
okay so these are the values for
border
followed by
background color
so we would like to use the same
details
now we would like to use background
color
so in background color we will just use
hsl rather than this
so hyphen hue
100
and 50
okay
followed by
border radius
border radius 5 pixels
now padding
padding just 5 pixels
and
10 pixels
then color
this color will be white
for sure
and
the outline
outline we are using is none
last option cursor
so cursor we will be using pointer as
you should see
so
these are the details are available
which we want to use it
for my button
now the last option
you want to use it for the button over
dot btn
dot
or
four
and for this performer
you want to say border color
this watercolor you would like to use
black
that's it let's see
awesome
so this looks pretty nice
as you can see right now here
well
so
this is how my
initial
looks like
okay now i also want to change
this
start button and next button both
so here
we want to use
dot
start
hyphen btn
and also for
dot
next hyphen pt
common look and feel for both
one size
one
dot five
next font weight
now this font weight i want to give bold
followed by padding
this padding is by 10 pixels
and 20 pixels followed by 10 pixels 20
pixels
next cursor
will be as usual pointers
now we want to go ahead with the
controls
with controls we say display
flex
followed by justify contents
just justify content services center
followed by align
items
and here we say center
and last option which is left is called
height
this height is a
display
none
that's it let's check this
out well
so
this will be
visible to me
so the moment i said start then with
other buttons will be visible so this is
how my program is
well my css is all set
well let's get start working with the
script part now
this is a major part of your
main
code development so here we will start
working with this const
and here we will say
start
button
equal to
document dot
get element by id and here it will give
the name call
start
hyphen btn
that's the name
like this
i just copy this line
make it available here like people call
start button
we have a call next button
and here
next button
like
here another one
here we change the name
and give the name called
question
container element
container
element
question container element documentation
by id
here we give the name called question
hyphen container
question hyphen
container
because this is already there
you see question hyphen container is
already there
we're using
question hyphen container
like this we would like to use one more
and that is called
question element
question
element document good element by id here
we'll be passing
question
followed by
we want to use
answer button element
answer
buttons
element
answers
or i can say
answer buttons element
answer hyphen patterns
answer hyphen
buttons
so naming convention must be chosen very
carefully
now we will provide
option called shovel question because we
want every time the questions to be get
shuffled
shuffled questions
shuffled questions
current question
index
shuffle questions and current question
index
and we would like to provide one
variable call let
quiz score
equal to
zero
so we created those variables
now
once it is done we want to basically go
ahead and start creating a set of
questions for my application
so here we want to provide the questions
so we say const
questions
const
questions
equal to
eric
first question which i would like to
create it here is called question
now here we will say
javascript framework
so which of these
is a
which one of these i would say which one
of these is a
javascript framework
this is my question now
okay so i would like to have answers for
sure
so here we are providing answers
so what answers we would like to provide
so in this answers the first answer i
can say
like this
here i see text
first will be python
python
okay
python
answer is true or false
correct
false so it will be the false
copy
now let's change the value here i say
django
correct false
third is react
so
i can say true
last i'm keeping it score
false as usual same so like this we have
created
a question
and four answers
okay so we're all set now
so
here after that
we want to create a few more
okay
so once again i would like to bring some
questions now
and related answers
so i just copy this
first
so second question
i can say
who's the prime minister of india
so we can have two
answers available
okay
talk about kundalini remodel value is
called work true
second we're gonna give the name call
this value is called false
so taken the values like this and we can
take one more
just for the demo purpose
so
like here
next is called what is 4 multiplied by 3
i can have many answers
so i'm just making the first is called 6
which is false seconds 12
like that total we have created
3
okay so we all are set with this
multiple questions
okay
now once it is done we would like to
offer
one function here
okay and what that function would be
the function would be known score clear
status class
function
player
status
class
it takes some parameter call element
and here we will say element dot
class list
dot
remove
element.classlist.remove
correct
and once again i copy the same line
[Music]
so we have two options available
call what
right
and what wrong
now
going forward we want to have
few more functions to be attached
there's only one function attached
that's called clear status class
now we would like to add one more
function here
call
function set
status class
okay and here we pass two parameters now
one is called element
and second is called correct
two parameters we are passing it down
element and correct first we are calling
this function called clear status class
is a function which we have created pass
element
followed by we are saying if
correct
then
element
dot
class list dot
add
correct
okay
else
use the same option
but we'll try to add
wrong here
so this is how we would like to apply
right or wrong
so this is a set status class which we
have it now
followed by the most important function
which you're going to use it right now
here
is called
your select answer so you have to
basically select the answer so this is a
little bigger function
so let's try to understand function
select
answer here we pass e as in parameter
and from here we will use
const
select selected button
selected button equal to e dot
target
number one
second const
correct
equal to
selected button
dot
data set
select button dot dataset dot
correct
now going forward
we'll be calling this
set status class
function in this set status class we'll
be passing
document
dot body
as a first parameter
and
correct
is the second parameter
okay now we're using
array
dot from
and here in this editor from we're using
answers
button element
dot
children
okay followed by
dot
for each here
we're using
this button
is in parameter
now here
what i will do we are using this option
called
set status class
first parameter will be what
a button then
button
dot
data set
dot
we can give the value call what correct
okay so this is how we are using this
array
now we'll be
utilizing the
main evaluated value called if
shuffle quotient
dot
length
if
shuffle quotients dot length is greater
than
current question index
plus one
then what
then we are saying
next button
dot
classlist
dot
remove
and here we will say height so this will
be
hidden
okay
else
else condition says what start button
dot inner text
okay start button dot inner text equal
to
restart
okay
and
next is called start button
dot
class list
dot
remove what we need to remove height
part
that's it
okay and here we're using this option
called if
selected button
dot
data set
equal to
correct
then
quiz score
plus plus
and
document dot
get element by id
here we are providing
write hyphen
answers
followed by
dot
inner html equal to
quiz
score
so whatever the score will be after
selecting the correct answer
this will be available to the user
okay
now the next thing which we're going to
develop it is basically your reset state
function
reset state
function reset state
so what we're going to offer here we are
saying
clear status class
document
dot
body
okay here we are saying
next button
dot
class list
dot
add
height
okay
now
we are using this while option now
answers button element
dot first child
so here i will be using answers button
element
dot remove child
here we have a call dot remove chart and
here we'll be giving
answers button elements
dot
first child
so these are the functions are used
right now
we haven't called those functions but
we'll be calling those functions one by
one
but this is
something which you wanted to start with
okay
well
reset state is already set now going
forward we would like to start working
with the show questions so that the user
can start seeing the question
we are saying function show question
show question the first parameter will
be question
and
from here onwards we would like to use
the question element
so we have a call question element dot
inner text
equal to
question
dot
question
now followed by questions dot answer
question dot
answers
dot
for each and here i would like to use
your passing what
answer is and parameter
now
here we like to create a button called
const
button equal to
document dot
get sorry document dot create element
i'd like to create a button now
okay after that we are saying
button
dot inner text
you to set the value
equal to
answer
dot
text
then
followed by button dot
class list dot
add here we are
offering
btn
okay now we are saying
if
the condition is
answer dot
correct
if answer is correct
then what
then button
dot dataset
dot
correct
equal to
answer dot
correct
okay
now
the next thing is we are using button
dot
add event listener
attaching the listener to this event
which event
on click event
second parameter will be
select answer
then
answer button element
dot
append child
of
what button
so this is your show questions
followed by what is the next question it
will appear so here we say function
set
next question
next question
here
function set next question
here in this next question we are just
saying
reset state the function we are calling
it and saying
show question
and here we are passing this
shuffle questions
and we are passing this current
question index
that is what the sect
next question is offering it to me
now the last function which is left that
is called start game how the game will
start
function
start
game
and here
the main magic begin here we say start
button
dot class list
dot add
and here
height
after that
shuffle questions
equal to
we have called questions
dot
sort
okay here we say
math dot
random
and
five
we're passing this value
okay after that we are saying
current question
index initially we are given 0 right now
after that
question
container element which we have already
defined
dot
class list
dot
remove
height
okay
and then
we're calling
set next question
which is a function we are calling it
and initializing our quiz score
with the value called zero
well start game is
ready
next thing which you to start the cover
button
so here we are saying
start button
dot
add event listener
here
in this
on my click
event i will try to call this function
start game
first thing
now next will be calling
next button
dot
ad event listener
on click
on click
we are using
okay so here we're calling current
question index
current question index
plus plus
and
set next question
that's it
so we are mostly done with our code
script.js we have basically already
initialized there
okay
the values will be
kept automatically
so most of the things are now ready with
us
okay so
our javascript is almost
ready index.html file is there and
app.css is also ready with this
now let's finally see how my overall
look and feel really looks like it
let's just go here and try to refresh
and check on a button called start
awesome i could see
the first
question appears automatically which of
these a javascript framework
if i select as usual my correct answers
for react
now you can see
is automatically making the rest of them
as a
red and not giving me the next button
now
the prime minister of india i'm saying
that modi
great next
and i say
4 multiplied by 3 i said 12 i said next
and which of those used in mobile up
development flutter
and flask is a flask it says twitter
and now you can see the application
looks perfectly fine
and it gives me the restart now
and that's it so this is how dear
friends your project is now completely
working
and expected as the way it was designed
for when i
once again restart and you can say start
button that's giving me four multiply by
three that means it is one second have
taken
random question
this mini project will help you to
understand how we can align our content
to display to my end user so not many
things are there we have got css in
place we have a html in place and using
some css3 based effects using some html5
based effects we will be getting our
mini website having some single html
page and a css and lot of images will
help you to understand in case if i want
to develop a website how to kickstart
them
okay so let's get started so this is my
folder i've created call web pro and in
a similar folder i'll be creating some
of the files so my first file will be
called styles
dot css
so in this style start series first of
all i need to import some of the fonts
which i will be using it throughout my
development so i'm saying to add rate
import url
and here i'll be offering the location
by saying
https
songs
dot
google
apis
dot com
okay google please dot com slash
css
okay question mark we have to use family
equal to here we can use alure
alera and with using this pipe symbol is
using joe's friend
joe's film
plus
sense
so that is the url for me in case if you
want to verify whether this url does
exist or not so what you can do you can
just copy this and go to your browser
and uh
try to paste this and check if it does
exist yes it does exist that means these
urls are available to us so this is the
url which i'll be using it
for my development after that i'll be
using this asterisk
and providing some of the core features
like a margin
colon zero
followed by
other details
okay like i'm saying margin colon zero n
padding once again zero
followed by box sizing
this we're saying bottle box
followed by outline
okay none
okay
and
both this will be offering less the
style
here we are also saying none
after that text decoration
text decoration once again
none
after that font family
using one more foreign sense
hyphen sorry
so this would be a first
set of the style which will be global to
all i'll be using this
well earlier we have given the common
style to all now i'll be giving a style
to my paragraphs
so
here in my paragraph we are trying to
save margin
hyphen
bottom i want to give all 15 pixels
because i want to develop all the styles
well in advance before i proceed ahead
we are saying font iphone size
yeah font hyphen size that we want to
give it for 14 pixels
followed by line height
line height i'll grab 20 pixels
after that color
color you can give anything
okay so there's one very common color
called light blue
for that there's one value called
five
f
okay eighty
eight
e and again eight
e
you can see there is called a kind of
light green color which is coming up now
okay which is used now a part of this
paragraph will be using h1 title
okay as shown title and in this h1 title
we are saying margin bottom
margin bottom we are saying 20 pixels
after that color
orange
okay
uh let me put semicolon here
along with this font family
this one family will be giving a loader
okay
along with this we also want to give
curiosity
cursor
okay also text
transform
this text transform i want to use upper
case
along with this font size
this font size i would like to give 38
pixels
followed by font size
yeah so this font size i want to give is
called 38 pixels
or font size you've already given word
spacing we have to give
word spacing was given 25 pixels
followed by letter spacing
uh let us specify 5 pixels
so these are the details we have given
for the h1 title
it's okay so now we'll be talking about
our buttons
which are the look and feel we have to
go or provide to our button so we are
saying once again
dot btn
okay space a means under my button tag a
what i want so i say
width
180 pixels
one second
yeah
with 180 pixels we're giving height
25 pixels
followed by line height
line height we're giving 35 pixels
followed by border
this bottle will be 2 pixels
solid
black
okay after that color
color we want to give it i would say red
would be
sufficient enough
followed by display
display i want to give it a score block
followed by margin
margin i want to give 25 pixels
auto
and
0
followed by texture line
okay
center
so this is for btn a which we have given
along with this btna there are some
other properties are also available i
can dot
main underscore
container
here we would like to provide position
okay
colon
relative
okay
after this position we would like to
also provide the property for navbar
so we are saying
navbar
underscore
or let's talk about neighborhood rest of
the stats will be offering it a little
later
with the snare bar we are providing this
width
okay this width will be a hundred
percent
okay this would be a 100
and also we provide height
this height will be 65 pixels
okay provided by position
position we are providing absolute
after that we are saying display
display we are providing flex
after that we are saying justify content
justify contents we are saying space
around
after that
we are saying align items
this we are getting
a center
okay along with this we are giving this
logo
of type a
so inside this logo we are saying font
family
this form firmly we are once again using
the same
the one which you have used earlier
you remember allura and curacao let me
we can use the same
whatever we have used it earlier
so
same condition you can use it here
so we remember earlier what we have used
in my previous program
okay font family so the same font family
i would like to use it here also
okay so logo a but let me check
somewhere down the line
pod weight
font family so let me copy the same
and paste here right now
okay so we have a god font family with
me
which we have taken it right now
to my existing logo a along with i want
to use call
font size
we would like to use 22 pixels
also color
and as usual i would like to use red
okay
so that is for logo on which we have
basically applied this
a part of this we would like to also use
for navbar
mapper
underscore
item
space uh
and here we would like to provide margin
0
and padding
again
followed by line style
list style sorry
list
style here we're saying none see that is
the benefit of having this visual studio
code because sometimes when you are
going wrong it immediately
give you the idea of like saying like
hey you're going somewhere wrong that's
what the suggestions were not given to
us
so till here we've added furthermore
we'll be adding few more stars into my
code well
never
tell you what we have seen now followed
by saying
dot navbar
okay underscore
items
followed by
ul which we have it and along with this
we would like to go ahead with this list
items also
and in this list items we need
few details first i talk about golf load
so float left for sure then we talk
about color width
width will be 100 pixels
and now we talk about color height
height will be 40 pixels
well
float width height we have talked about
now we talk about background color
background color we can say light
solomon
that looks nice
and opacity
obesity we can just give 1.8
followed by line height
line height i can give called 40 pixels
okay along with this we also want
texture line
once again
center
okay
this is for
these items
now under the same nav bar you may have
some other properties also
okay this is for navbar uli
and we can also have the same property
copy
but along with this li i can also have
this anchor tag we can select multiple
elements together
so here i would like to offer text
transform
you see the text transform
upper case
followed by color
this color we are saying black
and we are talking about called text
decoration
text decoration we want nothing
along with this i want display
and as usual it will be a block type
okay that was li and within this anchor
tag i also can have a hover
let me copy the same
and with this anchor i can have the
property name called what
cobalt
so what property you are expecting for
this
so here in my hover property i can say
background color
and i can use
tomato
okay
well after this in the same name bar
items
i also want to have after the anchor tag
what should happen so this conditions i
want to utilize because i want to offer
some of the animations behavior
right over there
so what animations i would like to go
ahead that i need to offer under this
navigation items like so i just copy
this
paste it below but this over which we
are talking about we would like to
change from
to after
okay
after so i'm removing this background
color with this because background color
can be changed to something else
so i can change to white
right
well let me have few more properties to
be get added
first thing we are trying to secure
position
position will be absolute
okay we want from left side
left i want to give 50 percent space
after this from bottom
i'm saying zero
okay
now i want to talk about transform
you remember the property available in
css
and here we are saying
translate
x and inside this translate x i say
minus 50 percent
okay and here we are saying after that
scale
x
okay and here we're providing what zero
so that's what the condition we want to
provide it for the transform
and the next thing will be transform
origin
transform origin by say 50 percent
and again
15
after this we would like to talk about
width
width will be 100
okay and we also want this height
height will be two pixels
okay with hundred percent height two
pixels
after that we talk about transition
in this transition we can talk about
code transform
okay transform to 50
ms
okay so these are so far the details
which are available with us
which i would like to use it in my code
okay that is for after of this anchor
tag
so when you talk about hover you further
want to change the behavior over there
so in this case i would like to use the
same
condition i just copy that
and here
when you say colon
so you can see
ally
space
a colon over
colon after
so what conditions you want to use it
here so
transform
okay so here
translate x
okay so here is a
minus
fifty percent
scalex
1.0
followed by we would like to use again
dot
navbar
okay underscore item
okay ul
followed by li
followed by once again even
once again li and here in this case we
want to offer display now
display
none
okay
so
that's okay and one more conditions i
would like to take it here is
here when i say ulli li colon hover so i
can say ally
colon
over uli so we will say display
block that's the condition
okay so so far we have written this much
of css we would like to go ahead and try
to implement some of the html behavior
and be back to our css to make this
possible
okay everyone so we have developed a lot
about css it's time for us to move
towards our next
ui that is called the html part okay so
here
i've already kept it just for the kind
information i've just downloaded few of
the images
okay from the internet just to utilize
into my application
i'm going to create
the another
file and give the name called index.html
okay this index.html file let me have
this template with me okay so i have a
got template with me
now here
we want to use some of the
awesome css styles for of my usual
development
so within my head tag i would like to
use this link
this is for css so say link real equal
to stylesheet
and href equal to now i'm going to give
the location so this css anyways is
there there's equal style we want to say
called styles.css
and
one more style i would like to use in my
code
but the location will be somewhere else
i'm saying
https cdnjs
dot
cloud flare
dot com slash
ajax slash libs
slash font
hyphen awesome
okay that is a well-known style sheet we
are giving the version called 5.15
dot one slash
css slash
all
sorry
on dot
min
dot css so that is the location actually
okay now i want to just check but this
location does exist or not so i'll just
copy this
paste it in my browser to verify
well yes this
style does exist so
we would like to go ahead and continue
well i would like to give some title in
case if i want so this is a document i
can just get the name called
website
okay let's keep this double capital
website development
coming to my body tag
here i just want to give a div
class equal to let's give the name
called main
underscore
container okay and also we want to give
id
equal to
oh
that is a div tag for that
okay
now along with this
i want to give some other type of div
tags to where i want to use it now here
within this div tag i want to give
another div tag
where i want to provide the navbar so
do
equal to navbar
okay and within this nav bar i want to
use another div tag
which says
class equal to
logo
okay
within this div tag we want to provide
double hlf
okay a href equal to
here we want to provide this hash
okay
and this will be provided to
home so this is we have got dev glass we
have a quality of class equal to logo
and under this we are providing this
hashtag and using
simply done
solutions
okay that is the first anchor tag the
div tag is getting closed and we would
like to start
another div tag and in this div tag we
would like to say
class equal to
navbar
underscore
items
okay
within this div tag we would like to use
this ul
and within this ul i would like to use
this ally
okay and in this ally
uh
we would like to bring some
ahref
equal to
hash
that is the link which i need to provide
okay
so in this anchor tag we want to provide
a location called home here
the first list item which is there like
this i can provide some other list items
too
like i need to talk about call about
we're saying hash
about and here we say
about here so this anchor tag is getting
closed
okay
and
here before i close this list item here
you would like to take another url tag
okay in this ul tag we would like to
paste this list item again
and here with this hash we can just give
the name call
something whichever you want to give it
again
blank
and
empty
so after that ul is also getting closed
li is also getting closed here
okay
after this
we can provide few more li tags here
okay so href equal to here we would like
to provide a real url remove the hashtag
and say
https
simplyland.com
slash
corporate hyphen
training
okay and here we will be giving
the option called services
this falls into the category of what
services
like this we would like to provide one
more anchor tag for contact us
that's a
contact
one more for call our team
okay and here we say
our t
okay let me go back to my index.html
file
and check
illustrators
well it looks pretty nice now here we
have got simply learn solution with us
and right inside you can see now here in
about you see how the things are working
for me
this links are coming up automatically
it came because here if you remember
in my code
when i was saying this about
okay this was a part of our current code
and due to that it is now making it
possible for us and that is possible
because here in my style.css
if you remember
we were using this
a kind of
navbar uli
okay so the moment i try to hover
okay so this was giving me the complete
details and due to that
i was in position to get all the details
so it looks pretty nice
okay so going forward what i would like
to do is within my program
as i could see in my index.html file we
have provided this
tag so ul is getting close this div is
getting close this tip is also getting
closed
okay
now here we would like to start another
table
we say dev class equal to banner image
minor underscore
image
okay
now within this div i would like to use
one more div tag within this div we say
class equal to
banner underscore
content
okay
banner underscore contract now within
this div class we would like to use this
h1
here we can say
welcome to
welcome to simply learn okay after this
break tag as you know that is a for
break
and now
in this expand tag we can say
words
okay
words
number one bootcamp
okay here the action tag is getting
closed
after that the paragraph tag within this
paragraph we can say
get certified
get
ahead
this value
after this the div tag is getting closed
the second tif tag is also getting close
let me check
okay so that we need to organize it
uh in a better way so but initially we
have a god welcome to safety learn
words number one bootcamp
now
how my look and feel
is really gonna help because this banner
part i want to organize it because i do
not have a css for this
clear so certainly i need a css to
organize this particular banner
getting it because when you talk about
banner content so i need to tell where
it needs to go because i also would have
some banned image also too so i'll go
back to my css now
and in my style css
here
let me say banner content
banner underscore
content
and here we can save
text align
center and say color
you can say
white smoke
okay
and also within this banner content
we want to use the h1 tag
within this h1 tag you have to just say
text transform
uppercase
and
line height
line height 30 pixels
okay and
margin bottom
this margin bottom we want to use 15
pixels
okay
so that's when we have it let me close
this
sorry
and here we want to use one more
property called banner content
with h1 and the span tag so that i can
change the color
so here
banner content
one we also want to use
span tag
within this i want to say
color
and you can just say
tomato and let's check does it affect my
application
yes exactly it does effect now you can
see it is somewhere coming down the line
like this
okay
so i can further change it
to my application
like
if i talk about about and all so this i
can change it for sure because if i have
some images also
those images i also want to change
towards my application but it is just a
simple part
we are talking about called
banner
and we have also have to take some
images too
for this banner image
so let's go back
and talk about our index.html file and
see
what some of the banners i want to
utilize it here
okay
now when we talk about get a head i
certainly need some of the banner image
too but banner image is not available so
let me go back and try to use some
banner image whichever we have to define
under my
css
okay so here in my style css let me go
here and say
dot
banner underscore
image
in this banner image we have to say
background url
background
colon now you just say
url and in this url we have to use this
image called images
slash p4
dot jpg
that will be my image and also we would
like to use one very common option that
is called no repeat
so that it should not repeat it and i
want to fix it to the top
and in the center
okay now let's check
perfect it is coming up but it is not
looking as good as it looks like it
so we want to use few more important
things same as background size
background size
cover and also want to use width
width i want to use 100
and height
we want to use it called 600 percent
okay display
we want to use it flex
and
justify content
we want to use it call center
and align items
center let's check this out
okay now you can see it looks pretty
better compared to the previous version
whatever we have written it
but this image needs to be look even
more better
okay and the content needs to be more
awesome
but anyways that is the first thing
which we have written after that we have
to write an about us and other areas but
that is initially which i would like to
make it
even more better and more look
okay
okay so we have seen the value still
call option called get certified get
ahead
the div tag is getting closed and i want
to use another
div
and inside this div we want to say
class equal to above
okay and
i'd equal to about
okay
and within this div tag i want to use
this h1 tag
with the setup tag i say
class equal to
title
okay here i want to say
about us
as well time is closed
after that i want to define this
paragraph
and want to give some details about the
simplest okay like
and talk about simply learn
words number one
training okay we can just
provide
you know some details training providers
that's it so
we can write it that much about in
paragraph tag
and we can use this tab again
within this tip we
say to
plus equal to
bdn
and say
a
href
equal to
and in the search results we would like
to save
colon
simply learn
dot com okay slash
resources and here we can just give the
option name called
learn
more
to this anchor tag the div tag is
getting close later on
okay and now
just like in dev we have provided here
we can also offer the details with
regards to your
services so i can just copy the same
and provide about the services we can
say
services id equal to
services and you can provide anything
whichever you would like to provide
title is same about us we can say our
services
our services
so
you can give any details if you want
okay paragraph
now here after this paragraph using div
class equal to
div
underscore services
and we may not have any hrf right over
here so we are removing this href tag
okay dip class equal to
diff on sickness very long
d
i developed inter services
here we want to use another div tag
and uh in this div tag we want to say
class equal to
enter
underscore
services
underscore
item
we have to basically provide
and within this i have to use this
option called img
src equal to now you have to provide a
location so i'm saying
under this images folder we have a call
services
of course the resource1
dot jpg
alt equal to
in case of the service is not available
you can just say
service underscore image
okay whether it is
once this is close you like to use a h3
diagonal
and in this h3 tag i just say
class
equal to
sub
underscore
title and here we get the title name
called
web development let me go back and check
yeah so i can see this option called
about us is coming up
learn more if i talk about learn more
you see i'm taking you to the
website of this
simply done resources which are
available to us so this link is working
perfectly fine
and
i can see here called our services
it is the same well going back so we
have a call
this our services
so alt equal to
services underscore image
sd class equal to subtitle web
development and
that's it
so the div tag is getting closed here
and i may choose to
talk towards
diff service item so let me have
another div tag here and
in this div tag we say
class equal to
dev
underscore
services underscore item
div underscore services underscore item
okay now within this dev tag
okay
so
what you want to offer now
i want to offer some again certain
images
so what those images will be let me try
to copy this
and the s3 tag to let me copy this again
service one i'm giving call service to
service underscore images so underscore
title rather than using web development
we can say app development
okay
so this div tag i will copy it again
which is getting closed and try to use
one more
so deep underscore service underscore
item okay images i'll say
service 3 instead service image and here
i can say online certification
online certification
okay
so
like this
all the 3d tags are getting close now
and after that we will start meanwhile
let me check
so these image sizes are pretty big so i
just want to make them small
but initially they are okay
okay you can see we have called our
services
okay
so
you can see like web development
so ima sizes are pretty big which we can
make them small
to cover up the way they are supposed to
but this way we'll be doing it little
later on let's go ahead and talk about
the complete html portion which we want
to complete it now
okay so that online certification we
have taken
so also the three div tags are getting
closed now here onwards
we want to start the another tab
okay with this div we want to say class
equal to
equal to we want to use contactors
we want to say
contact us and here
id able to
contact us
let me try to wrap it with this single
course
okay and here we use this h1 tag
within this h1 tag we say
class equal to
title here
and here i say contact us
contact us okay that is for the first h1
tag we are using it now
after that let's start with another div
tag
with this div we want to use class
equal to
form
underscore
wrapper
okay dip class equal to what form
underscore word wrapper
div
again
okay
class equal to
form underscore what input
and here we say
the input tag
so it is input applicable to what a
check box for me
so i would like to say
text instead input applicable to what
text and uh
just say remove the name and id and say
placeholder equal to
email
okay so this div tag is getting closed
after that i can also use
so for
i would say subject as well as for
message i copy this
form input
so once again placeholder
subject
and once again placeholder equal to what
three options we are using it right now
okay dude
after this
once it is over we would like to use
another div tag
and do
class equal to
btn
and within this i want to use
some anchor tag
a hf equal to hash
ethereup equal to what hash
and want to use submit
okay that's it
now
now you can see we have got these three
properties are coming up at the end
but certainly we can go back and try to
fix those images
which are there behind the scene
okay using what the style
so
first important thing is
we have got this images with us
what those images are if we just check
here
we have a called
def service item
okay we have a call what dev service
item so that we want to change it but
before that i will go back to my style
and after this h1 span we want to use
for dot
about
ok dot
service we press enter
service
or i can say services
here we talk about dot
contact us
we also talk about dot dot
our team
okay
so these four properties we are going to
use it by saying
text align
center and
[Music]
adding 5
10 percent
okay now
we talk about services so we saying dot
services
with the services we can say
background
white
smok
now we would like to provide the tip
services where we have this options with
us we say dot
div underscore
services
here
margin top
25 pixels
from margin top here same after that
display
we are selecting this call type flex
also justify contents
of type space between
for dev services
now in this disk services we may get
many different type of options
okay this is the first dev service now
in the same option in dot
dev services
space
we talk about dev services underscore
item
okay and here we want to save it
thirty percent
okay now
i copy the same
in this div services item
so we want to use
image part that is the most important
area
here we say
width
100
okay and margin button
okay margin bottom 25 pixels
okay
okay now you can see this images looks
pretty nice
yeah looks better so that's how you see
your websites are really creating some
difference compared to the previous one
now they're aligned properly and
you can see here
these images are really nice
okay that's the benefit so we have this
technical devices
yeah and
once this image part is closed we would
like to talk about h3 part
let me copy this
item
and with this item we say abstract
and this s3 will say color
tomato and margin bottom
this is 15 pixels
okay for this h3
and when it comes to this text boxes
certainly you can change the look and
feel how you really want it
so for this you can say dot
form underscore
rebel
home underscore
input
okay form wrapper form input
we say
margin hyphen bottom
15 pixels
okay perform input
now in a similar line
uh form input we may have a hot text
area
input
text area and in this text area we
want to offer some of the details like
i'm talking about like in width we talk
about padding
let's talk about like in the width
i'm saying 250 pixels
okay we said padding
we say 12 pixels
and
20 pixels
we talk about
height
80 pixels we talk about resize
we talk about
none
we say border
this bottle we say one pixels
solid
and
white
this is for this
and in a similar one i can use it for
the text box so form colon input
whatever we have used it
form wrapper
form input so let me copy this
okay form input and here we say input
equal to
type of text
so what
combination you'll be using so i'll be
using width padding and border
copy
i need ridge padding and border height
and resize we're removing it
and
awesome
so they look
pretty nice
okay so we have this three text boxes
with us
and all are looking
nice the way
we are expecting from our application
okay so that's the one
which my application is offering about
this
text area and all
so that looks really nice the way we are
expecting right now
okay
so
what are the areas we have seen
tiff services
item
and everything whichever you are saying
like this
so let's go back and check
my index.html file
so we have a call
form wrapper which is the outermost
okay
you see now here it contains a lot many
things
so here in my
program when i see like form wrapper
okay
form underscore wrapper dot form input
and uh
talk about like the other details
talk about input type equal to text
you see like the border is like that
so if you want to have this border some
different color
and certainly use black
now you can see it looks pretty nice
because earlier it was looking like
pretty much different now at least i can
see
here the location has been given
okay uh so going back towards the
previous
html page so we had a call a submit
button with us
okay after this the
all three div tags are getting closed
and now onwards we would like to start
working with team details
so we are saying do
so div
plus equal to
our t
and
id equal to
team again
okay and now we want to use this h1 tag
here this h1 tag we say
class
plus equal to title
and here i say
13
in a h1 tag
now once it is over we will use again
another div tag
which having
class equal to our team wrapper
our
team
underscore
wrapper
now within this step tag
uh we want to use one more div tag
here in this
class equal to
team underscore or team iphone one
base
t
what is the div tag
now here we will be using a lot of other
div tags inside this like
i say
div
class equal to team members
team members
okay
and data hyphen
name equal to you can give any name like
let's give the name call
space k
okay
and within this i want to use one image
tag
img space src equal to
images slash
jpeg
okay
so that's the first thing
we have it so this div tag is closed now
uh i copy the same
the total i want to use this three one
two
three
and
here team members i would like to change
the name here
rather than display let me get the name
called
average
and
one more
that is gone
okay and change the name to
forward five three
okay so this is the first div we have
used it so this dream tag is getting
closed right over here
along with this the second dip tag is
getting closed
so
after having this
two div tags closed we want to use
another one so for team two
okay so i just copy the same
okay uh
i would like to go ahead with
team two team so team members
and uh here i would like to say four
five
four
five
six
and change the name
like
you can give anything i just give the
name called
suppose
so these names we are using it now let's
go back and see how it really looks
so these images are coming like that
okay
so we want to use those images in
somewhere not like this or horizontal
vertical
so this spot fix that issue i have to
once again look back to it to my styles
okay where
this option can be used in better way
i like to go back to my style.css
and want to use
the first option called dot over 3.
background
sorry
background now here we say
quite small
now
again our t
wrapper
so in this i would like to say display
flex
and flex direction
space between
oh sorry column
let's check how it really looks like and
this is no more change
but
certainly few more classes can really
make a difference
so our team
okay underscore rapper
let's check this is the same name we
have used it
yes our team
now in the same way we want to use this
team
so
again our team wrapper
okay
dot
team
display
click
and justify content
space between
okay now here
we talk about t
we also want to say uh
our team underscore wrapper
dot
team
underscore
members
here we would like to give width
how much 30
and height
this will be auto
and here we'll be having cursor
pointer for sure
and overflow
hidden
and position
relative
this is for team members
now you can see it looks better now now
we have to basically divide those
because we have got separate team
members are available so we have to also
divide them too so here after this we
want to say
dot
our team
wrapper and again dot
team
member space img
these images we say
display
block
width
100
okay
height
auto
okay
transition
transition
or
transition i can say or type all
like
this
okay and in a similar way
copy this team
and we'll say members
over
image
and we can say
transform
scale
1.1
that's it
okay so we have this
look and feel appeared
okay with
transition image over so they're all
ready with us
okay everybody so after writing all
those the only difference i've made it
like i had used hyphen but i'm using
underscore here
finally when i see my look and feel
of this
i can see now it is moving you can see
now it is all moving okay so that gives
me the confidence of like yes exactly
the code is working the way it was
expected earlier
in my index.html file
okay so once this portion is over
okay we want to go ahead so three tip
tags are getting close one two and three
and here
we would like to start working with a
footer so here we start
folder
so within this footer i say class equal
to
butter
okay
now after this i use container there
okay
dip class equal to what
container
and again
div
equal to
row
okay
now
div class equal to rho
again another div
equal to
footer hyphen col
call footer hyphen column
now let me use h4
within this h4 i say
company
okay
after this we want to use this ul
within this um
once again
i want to use some
link items
list items within this list item
a
equal to
so this hrf tag we want to save
http okay we have already used this
simplyland.com url
here
let me copy this
come down
http.com rather than resources i can say
about us
about hyphen us
and here we say about this
it is getting closed
so i copy this line again
okay
so
one more thing i want to use it think
href equal to
dash
and here we will say
our team
okay
after that
we want to offer the couriers so we save
and we want to
use careers
here
review
concept
aluminum speak
so this is the detail of this so the url
tag is getting close
and uh after this your tag is getting
closed
we want to use one more div class equal
to footer hyphen column
okay i copy this
it is getting closed here
okay so do classical to photo hyphen
column so rather than using company we
want to use discover
discover
and here in this discover we say
simplylink.com
and here we have this option called
skillup
iphone
free iphone
online hyphen
portal
okay so here we will give the name call
scale up
okay
after this
we have this called careers we say
resources
very much
resources
here we can give the name for resources
again
resources
we have called tutorials
reset
tutorials here
so like this we can create as many
number of urls as i want
okay
so
once it is over
let me copy this again
and here
photocolumn we say follow us
follow
us
or else we can say this option in call
work with us
but
right
in this work with us
we can have
some options with us and you will
remove those two
in this we would like to say guest
blogging
we say
guest
blogging
yes blogging we can say blog has guest
blog
honey
guest
another link which i have it here that
is called become our trainer
here we say
become
and we say
become an instructor
okay
so like that you're offering it and
once it is done
i can copy it once again this
div
and
provide few more
photo hyphen column
followers
okay
and
[Music]
follow us we would like to use another
table
okay we say
class
equal to
social hyphen
links
and this dev tag will be closed later
okay
templates equal to social links
in this i can have some facebook.com
and
you know twitter.com and many more
names i can take it so here in our
dev classical social link here i will
not be using any url here
i will not be using any ally here
okay so i'm closing this even in a live
closing this url and i like
to
well simplyname.com or else we can just
give the name called twitter.com
okay
twitter.com
simply learn
okay
so
we can offer the user
to follow us on
instagram also or to the
twitter also so here we say
a hdf
but what we need to give it so we can
say trader.com
slash simply learn
we remove these values whichever we have
it so instead we use this i
okay and in this i i say
equal to
okay anchor tag is closed
so in case if you want to talk about
like a
typical
you know instagram that instagram also
you can use it now so here
we say http www.insta
we say instagram.com
okay slash
simply learn underscore
underscore e-learning
okay and i want to use the same option
there also
i
entered this
remove this
okay
so here you just give the name called
every hybrid
instructor
now let's go back and check
okay so you can see now we have got this
links coming up for facebook as well as
what
of this instagram so that looks really
nice that gives us a feeling of yes
exactly the code the way we are looking
forward for it is working
the way it was expected
okay
and
if you want to offer
any other type of details that also you
can offer but this is the first thing
which we have taken so this is the
navigation links are available
these navigation links
you could also change the way they
always look forward for so i'll be
providing some links which we can later
on use it
okay everyone so finally we are all
ready so i have basically added some of
the additional styles to my code you can
see here from
this point onwards we've added this
image url
this is for body this is for star
container row ul
this is for footer
this is for photo column so because we
are also using some photo portions into
my code as you can see we will call
photo column and photo class equal to
what
footer so implemented this photo
background color equal to black we have
used it padding 70 pixels footer column
footer column because we are using this
h4 tag also you remember like we're
using this h4 tag also
so for all h4 tags this would be the
basic setting
for footer column h4 before we would
like to give the contents like this by
giving this background color height box
sizing width and then all
footer column unli not last time we
gonna give this margin bottom and this
is the style for photocolumn uli and
list items
clear and here we can see this font size
we are giving it this is for over this
is for photo column where we have our
social links whichever we have created
so it is showing me the display in line
block margin border radius
and this is for social links when i try
to click on or over it so the color will
change to this white color
and the media this is for responsiveness
to make sure like in case if i reduce
the size of my browser they look
better the way it is expected
so when the line size will change to 720
pixels so this color will be changed and
this is the styles for arrow photo one
this all we have implemented and finally
my application when i refresh it
actually looks like that see now this is
the photo area of my application
so i'm sure that this looks even more
better and convenient because when i try
to
reduce the size
you see now it's still going to give you
the responsiveness
can you see this now this is going to
give you the responsiveness reason
because here we are using this
logic for
media when the change
of width well to 720 pixels if it is
going to 767 pixels so like that you
implement that so guys our project is
now ready i'm sure that you enjoyed
thank you very much for enjoying this
project so final our application is set
and our application is working the way
it is supposed to work for us html
stands for hypertext markup language it
is the most widely used language for
developing web applications it was
created by berners lee in the year 1991
but it was published in the year 1995.
html4 was a popular breakthrough version
and got published in the year 1991.
this version gained a lot of popularity
and was adopted all over the globe for
developing web applications so without
further ado let's get started with the
interview questions based on html it's
the first question
what is html html stands for hypertext
markup language and it is the language
of the internet it is a standard text
formatting language used for creating
and displaying pages on internet html
documents are made up of the elements
and tags that format it properly and
display it on pages
so we have our next question now
what are html tags
so the answer for this question is html
tags are used for placing the elements
in a proper and appropriate format tags
use the symbols greater than and less
than to set them apart from the html
content
the html tags need not to be closed
always for example in case of images the
closing tags are not required for an
image tag
now followed by the second question we
have our third question what are html
attributes the attributes are the
properties that can be added to an html
tag that change the way the tag behaves
or displayed for example an image tag
an image stack has src attribute with
which you can use the source from which
you have to display the image from
now the attributes are added right after
the name of the html tag inside the
brackets the attributes can only be
added to opening or self-closing tags
but never in closing tags
now followed by third question we have
our next question what is mark you in
html mark you is used for scrolling text
on a web page it scrolls the image or
text up down left or right automatically
to apply for a marquee you have to use
marquee tags
now we have our fifth question how do
you separate a section of text in html
we separate a section of text in html
using the below tags which are the break
tag paragraph tag and block code
the break tag is used to separate a line
of text it breaks the current line and
shifts the flow of the text line to a
new line followed by that we have the
paragraph line the paragraph line is
used to write a paragraph of text and
third one the block code the block code
tag is used to define large quoted
sections
now we have our sixth question define
the types of lists in html so we have
the three types of lists in html which
are the ordered list unordered list and
definition list so first we'll discuss
the ordered list the ordered list uses
ol tag and displays elements in a
numbered format next we have the
unordered list the unordered list uses
ul tag and displays elements in a
bulleted format thirdly we have the
definition list the definition list uses
dl dt and dd tags and displays elements
in the form of definition
like a dictionary
next we have our seventh question
how do you align list of elements in an
html file we can align the list elements
in an html file by using indents if you
indent each nested list and further than
the parent list then you can easily
align and determine the various lists
and the elements that it contains
now we have our eighth question
differentiate between ordered list and
unordered list so the answer for this
question is an unordered list uses ul
tags and each element of the list is
written between li tags the items are
displayed as bullets rather than numbers
now coming into ordered list so for
creating an ordered list you'll be using
ol tags and each element inside the list
as written using li tags the list items
are displayed using numbers rather than
bullet points now we have a sample on
the screen right now so the first three
elements are
a set of unordered lists which are
represented using bullet packs and the
second set which is the coffee tea and
milk is an ordered list which is
represented using numbers
now moving ahead we have the ninth
question how do you display a table in
html web page so the table and html can
be created or displayed using the table
tag
so it also uses to manage the layout of
the page for example header section
navigation bar body content photo
section etc etc so given below are a
list of html tags used for displaying
table in an html web page so we have
table t r th etc etc table is used to
define a table tr is used to define a
row in a table th for header td for a
cell caption is used to define a caption
and we have the call group which is used
to specify a group of one or more
columns in a table for formatting next
we have call which is used with call
group element to specify column
properties for each column next we have
t body which is used to group the body
content in a table next we have t head t
footer which are used for header content
and footer content respectively moving
forward we have our 10th question
how do you display the given table in an
html web page so the answer for this
question is written on the right side
part of my screen this is the sample
code which you can use to represent or
display a table which is given in this
particular format over here now followed
by this we have our 11th question how do
we insert a comment in html so the
answer for this question is
we can insert a comment in html by
beginning with lesser than sign and
ending with a greater than sign for
example as shown in the right side part
of my screen which is hello world now
moving ahead we have our 12th question
how do you insert a copyright symbol in
html so you can insert a copyright
symbol by using ampersand copy semicolon
or ampersand
169 semicolon in an html file now moving
ahead we have our 13th question so what
is a white space in html so the answer
for this question is an empty sequence
of space characters is called as white
space in html this white space is
considered as a single space character
in html white space helps the browser to
merge multiple spaces into one single
space and so taking care of indentation
becomes easier
white space helps in better organizing
the content and tags making them
readable and easy to understand
with this let's move into the 14th
question
how do you create links in different
sections within the same html web page
so the answer is anchor tags we can use
anchor tag along with referencing
through the use of hashtag symbol to
create several links to different
sections within the same web page moving
ahead we have the 15th question how do
you create a hyperlink in html so the
answer is we can use anchor tag again
here the same thing we can use anchor
tag to create a hyperlink within the
html that links to another web page the
hyperlink can be added to images too now
moving ahead into our sixteenth question
define an image map so the answer for
this question is an image map in html
helps in linking with the different
kinds of web pages using the single
image it can be used for defining spaces
in the images that are made part of the
image mapping process
moving ahead we have our 17th question
why do we use stylesheet in html a
stylesheet helps in creating a
well-defined template for html web page
that is both consistent as well as
portable a single style sheet template
can be linked to various web pages which
makes it easier to maintain and change
the look of the website now the 18
question what is semantic in html
so the answer for this question is
semantic html is a coding style it is
the use of html markup to reinforce the
semantics or the meaning of the content
for example the semantic html b tag is
not used for bold statement as well as i
tag which is not used for italic instead
we use strong and em tags
now followed by the 18 question we have
our 19th question
what is svg in html so the html svg is
used to describe the vector or raster
graphics svg images and their behaviors
are defined in xml text sheets it is
mostly used for vector type diagrams
like pie charts two dimensional graphs
in an x y coordinate system
now moving ahead we have our 20th
question
what would happen if there is no text
between the html tags so the answer for
this question is really simple there
would be nothing to format if there is
no text present in between the tags
therefore nothing will appear on the
screen some tags such as the tags
without closing tag like image tag do
not require any text between them
now followed by the 20th question we
have our next question how do you create
nested web pages in an html so nested
web pages basically mean a web page
within a web page we can create nested
web pages in html using the built-in
iframe tag the html live frame tag
defines an inline frame for example
which is displayed on the right side
part of my screen you can see the iframe
source
which redirects the user to simply
learns official web page
now followed by that we have our 22nd
question how do you add buttons in html
so we can use the built-in button tag in
html to add buttons to the html web page
so on the right hand part of my screen
you can see the implementation of button
to an html web page now followed by 20
second question we have our 23rd
question what are the different types of
headings in html so the answer for this
question is there are basically six
types of heading tags in html which are
defined with h1 to h6 stacks
each type of the heading tag displays
different text size from another
where h1 is being the largest and h6 is
being the smallest so on the right hand
part of my screen you can see the
implementation of heading tags from h1
to h6 now the output for this particular
code segment is the h1 h2 s3 h4 h5 h6 so
you can see that h1 is being the biggest
one and h6 is being the smallest one now
moving ahead into our 24th question how
do you insert an image in the html web
page so the answer for this question is
you can insert an image in the html
webpage by using the following code
which is displayed on the right side
part of my screen you can see we have a
image source is equals to tulip.jpeg
which is used for inserting an image
into your html webpage
now our 25th question what is the alt
attribute in html now the answer for
this question is the alt attribute is
used for displaying the text in place of
an image whenever the image cannot be
loaded due to any technical issue
so basically when you have poor internet
connection and you are trying to load an
image you can see some sort of text in
place of an image so that particular
text is nothing but the alt attribute
now moving ahead we have our 26th
question how are hyperlinks inserted in
the html web page you can insert a
hyperlink in the html webpage by using
the following code which is present on
the right side part of my screen
you can use the anchor tag along with h
reference and inside that particular tag
you can use the url to which you want
your users to redirect to
now followed by this we have our 27th
question how do you add color to the
text in html
so the answer for this question is you
can add color to the text by using the
following code which is present on the
right side part of my screen where you
can add a red color and blue color green
color to this particular paragraph and
headings now followed by 27th question
we have our 28th question
how do you add css styling in html so
there are three particular ways to add
css to your html there are inline css
external style sheet and internal style
sheet we'll discuss each of these
methods in a bit more detail first we
have the inline css
so it is used when less amount of
styling is needed or in cases where only
a single element has to be styled to use
inline styles add the style attribute in
the relevant tag now moving ahead we
have the external style sheet this is
used when the style is applied to many
elements or html pages each page must
link to the style sheet using the link
tag
now we have the last one which is the
internal style sheet it is used when a
single html document has a unique style
and several elements need to be styled
to follow the format
internal style sheet is added in the
head section of the html page by
style tag now followed by this we have
our 29th question
what hierarchy do the style sheets
follow
the answer for this question is if a
single selector includes three different
style definitions the definition that is
closest to the actual tag takes
precedence inline style takes priority
over embedded style sheets which takes
priority over external style sheets now
our last question for the session today
how do you add javascript to an html web
page so the answer for this question is
we basically have three methods to add a
javascript to our html webpage they are
inline script block and
external javascript file first we'll
discuss the inline
you can add javascript to your html
elements directly whenever a certain
event occurs javascript code can be
added using attributes of the html tags
that support it now the next one that is
the script block you can define a script
block anywhere inside the html code
which will get executed as soon as the
browser reaches to that part of the
document this is why script blocks are
usually added at the end part of the
html documents now the last one that is
the external javascript file you can
also add or import the javascript code
from a separate file and keep your html
code clutter free this is especially
useful if there is a large amount of
scripting added to the html webpage so
this session will be about become a
front-end developer
so let us begin
we are going to discuss the things you
need to know to become a web developer
first we will start with basic skills
which every web developer must know
before moving into more advanced web
frameworks then we will understand what
react is and why it is so popular after
that we will go through another web
framework called angular
then we will also get to know about a
comparatively new front-end framework
called vue in the end we will go through
the front-end developer salary trends
which will give you an insight of the
job market
so without further ado let's get started
first the basic skills let us understand
what basic skills are required to become
a web developer
there are a few recommendations in that
you must learn for either path
these are the common things every
programmer should know
the first one is the github
so git is a free open source version
control system that enables
collaborations in a particular project
it is designed to handle both small and
large-scale projects
git is a tool used to save code and
create different versions to better
manage the feature updates in the
product or an application
so followed by the github the next
important thing we have is the data
structures and algorithms a data
structure is the location used to store
and organize data
an algorithm is a collection of steps to
solve a particular problem
learning data structures and algorithms
allow us to write efficient and fast
computer programs so followed by data
structures and algorithms we have the
text editor
get familiar with the text editor of
your choice
visual studio code is the top choice for
most of the web developers and my
personal choice too because of the large
support of languages and of course the
speed
the text editor is where you write all
your code and the terminal is where you
execute it
so followed by the text editor we have
the command line
the command line is an important tool to
get familiar with
it is how you run your code after
writing it on a text editor
the better you are on the command line
the more efficient you will be as
developer
so followed by the command line we have
the http and https the http protocol is
the backbone of the internet
it handles requests and responses from a
web application it is mandatory for a
web developer to have good knowledge of
both http
and https in order to build fast and
responsive web applications
now that we know what basic skills are
required to become a front-end developer
let's discuss about the most popular
front-end library that has to react
now what exactly react is
so react is a front-end javascript
library used for building beautiful user
interface components
it is an open source meaning it can be
used in your commercial projects without
any restrictions
it is also component based and these
components can be used again and again
promoting code reusability
it is an mvc or model view controller
architecture
react is the v responsible for how the
application looks and feels for the end
user now why should you learn react
react has always been in high
performance as it uses virtual dom
rather in real dom
so basically dom stands for document
object model and
is used by every internet browser for
rendering a web page or an application
react can also be easily integrated with
other javascript frameworks like node.js
resulting in the development of a
completely new web application including
front end and the back end
it is comparatively easy to maintain
large-scale applications written in
react because
it highly promotes code reusability and
code readability
so followed by react the next important
thing we have is the angular
we have an idea of what react is but it
is not the only framework used for
building user interfaces so now let us
know about angular
so now what exactly angular is
angular unlike react is a fully fledged
framework for web application
development which usually does not
require additional libraries for
implementing additional functionalities
like routing
it is also open source and backed by
google and as regularly updated
resulting in constantly improved
performance and addition of new features
in terms of performance it was begged to
be much slower than react but with the
recent versions performance seems to be
on par with react
now why should you learn angular
angular is one of the most stable
frameworks out there
it is also the most complete meaning you
don't have the need to integrate with
other frameworks since it's pretty much
includes everything for the web
development of a complete web
application
angular backed by google is safe choice
for using in long-term projects since it
is not going anywhere anytime soon
angular is obviously used by google for
its web applications and also used by
other large-scale companies creating a
lot of job opportunities
now followed by angular the next one we
have is the view
now that we know quite a bit about the
two popular front-end frameworks namely
react and angular let's now go ahead
into
view and learn a bit more about vue.js
library
now what exactly is view
view is a lightweight and open source
progressive javascript framework used
for developing interactive web user
interfaces
it is meant to be integrated with other
libraries to develop a complete web
application
like react vue.js is mainly focused on
the view part of the web application and
hence it's a bit faster when compared to
angular which is a complete web
application solution
view.js is commonly referred to as view
and pronounced as vue.js or vue is
rightly so
now why should you learn vue
any beginner web developer can easily
understand view and start building their
own web user interfaces
like react view also uses virtual dom
resulting in better performance and it
also uses the component-based code
design promoting code reusability and
code readability
vue.js has become popular in recent
times and many companies are starting to
use it owing to its lightweight
performance and easy integration with
other web libraries and frameworks
now with this let's move into the next
section where we will discuss about the
front-end developer salary trends
now that we know what skills we need to
become a front-end developer let's now
have a look into the salarians of a
front-end developer
front-end developers are always in high
demand since new web applications are
launched and managed continuously
there are generally offered generous
salaries across the globe
the salaries also depend on the factors
like frameworks skills and the work
experience
the average salary of a front-end
developer in india is 5 lakh 6 000
rupees per annum
the average salary of a front-end
developer in united states is 76
929 us dollars per annum this session
will be about web development roadmap in
2021
so let us begin
assuming that you know what web
development is the roadmap is divided
into three sections the first section is
all about the common skills which every
web developer should know while the
second and third are about front end and
the back end development the main areas
of web development
so you can either learn front end or
back end or both depending upon your
choice so if you want to become a full
stack web developer then you have to
learn both front end and the back end
there is no escaping there in the end we
will also go through the salaries of web
developer
so without further ado let's get started
the first one that is the common skills
let us understand the basic skills that
you require to become a web developer
there are a few recommendations in that
you must learn for either path these are
the common things every programmer
should know
the first one is git
get is a free and open source version
control system that enables
collaboration in a particular project it
is designed to handle both small and
large scale projects
git is a tool used to save code and
create different versions to better
manage the feature updates in a product
or application
the next one is the data structures and
algorithms a data structure is a
location used to store and organize data
an algorithm is a collection of steps to
solve a particular problem
learning data structures and algorithms
will allow us to write efficient and
fast computer programs
followed by data structures we have the
text editor
get familiar with the text editor of
your choice
next visual studio is the top choice of
the most web developers and my personal
choice too because
it has a large support of languages and
of course the speed
next
text editor is where you write all your
code and the terminal is where you
execute it
so followed by the text editor we have
the command line
a command line is the important tool
that you need to get familiar with
it is how you run your code after
writing your code on the text editor
the better you are on the command line
the most efficient you will be as a
developer so followed by command line
interface you have the http or https
the http protocol is a backbone of the
internet it handles the requests and
responses of a web application
it is mandatory for a web developer to
have good knowledge of both http and
https in order to build a fast and
responsive web application
so followed by common skills we have the
front-end developer
front-end development is all about
developing the user interface and its
interaction with the client end
let's go ahead and look into this field
of web development
there are a few things that you must
know for becoming a front-end developer
let's discuss these things
so the first one is the web development
basics it is necessary to know the
basics of web before moving on to
programming languages
next you should know stuff like web
applications protocols like http and web
development in general so followed by
web development basics we have the html
and css
html and css are the backbones of any
website html provides the structure
while css provides the style to make
them visually appealing
mastering these two technologies is a
must to become a front-end developer
browser in the end renders html and css
on the web page regardless of the
technology used to develop that page
followed by html and css we have the
javascript javascript is an extremely
important technology that every web
developer should learn
most of the popular web frameworks like
react.js and node.js are built upon the
javascript
javascript makes the web applications a
love by adding interactivity and dynamic
updating of web applications followed by
javascript we have the typescript
typescript can be considered as an
extension of javascript angular uses
typescript as a space language
it adds type safety to javascript to
cache errors in the development phase it
also helps in developing object oriented
code for javascript so followed by
typescript we have the angular
angular is a web framework used to
create a single phase applications
it is backed by google therefore
learning angular is a good choice for a
modern web developer
so followed by angular we have react js
react is a popular library for
developing fast and responsive web
applications
it is backed by facebook and quite
popular because of its simplicity and
performance
it allows you to create a reusable
components that can be used to create
modern web applications
so followed by react.js we have view js
view is like other frontend frameworks
that is used for building user
interfaces
it is comparatively easier to integrate
view with other libraries or existing
projects
it is a newer framework but it has
really picked up speed last year and
being adopted more
now followed by the front-end developer
we have the back-end developers
so back-end development is more about
caring how application works and ensure
that it keeps running smoothly let's go
ahead and know more about this field of
web development there are a few things
that you must learn for becoming a
back-end developer let us discuss those
things
so the first one is the node.js node.js
is a javascript runtime built on
chrome's v8 javascript engine it allows
you to develop a complete web
application using javascript
it is best suited to be used for web
applications in conjunction with
javascript frameworks like react.js
so followed by node.js we have python
python is a popular language used in
various fields of tech applications
django is a back-end framework based on
python used for server-side scripting it
is also known for its speed and
efficiency python is also easy to get
started with programming language if
this is your first time coding followed
by python we have java
java has been the most used language for
a long time it is primarily used for
back-end development
you can either use core java or java
with spring boot for high performance
back-end
next we have
next we have ruby ruby is a dynamic
programming language that focuses mainly
on simplicity
it has a syntax that is very easy to
read and close to english language
phrases
the web framework ruby on rails is
popularly used for developing packing
systems so followed by ruby we have php
and mysql
php although treated as a hard to learn
language is still the easiest way to
write server side code
at least 50 of the internet runs on php
and mysql
mysql is the most popular database for
storing data of a web application
now followed by the backend developer we
will enter the next important stage of
web development roadmap in 2021 that is
about the web developers salary trends
let's now have a look on the salary
trends of a web developer web developers
are always in demand since new web
applications are launched and managed
continuously they are generally offered
generous salaries across the globe
salaries also depend on the types of web
developers for instance full stack
developers are paid more than the front
end and back-end developers
the average salary of a web developer in
india is 3 lakh 86 000 per annum
the average salary of a web developer in
the united states is 68
524 us dollars per annum i'm sure you've
all heard the phrases software
development and web development
and i wouldn't be surprised if you use
them interchangeably or even mistook a
software developer for a web developer
well let me break your bubble
they are different
today's topic of discussion is software
developer versus web developer
so moving ahead who is a web developer
now a web developer builds and maintains
websites and other web applications he
takes web design and turns it into a
website
web developers are responsible for how a
website or web application looks and
functions from its user interface and
page layout to back-end systems for
gathering data
a web developer is expected to
collaborate with clients stakeholders
and organization leaders to design
unique and engaging websites for
businesses non-profits government
agencies and anyone else who is looking
to communicate more effectively online
so diving a bit deeper a web developer
can specialize in different areas based
on their skill
you have the front-end developers now
these are experts who are in charge of
how websites and applications look and
function from the user's perspective
next there are back-end developers who
focus on the technical aspects of
websites and web applications that
support both
basic and advanced functionality
now they largely work on administrative
components which include databases
website architecture application logic
creating new apis and user interfaces
based on predefined specifications
and lastly there are full stack
developers who are professionals
responsible for the development of an
application from start to finish
they specialize in both front end and
back end of the application development
typically a web developer should have
good skills in various frameworks and
markup languages like html css
javascript
react chairs angular and database
management systems like mongodb
and back-end tools like node
so i hope this helped you understand who
a web developer is some of their
responsibilities and their basic skill
set
next up
let's understand who a software
developer is
now software developers are responsible
for creating more complex applications
and programs for computers and mobile
devices
they create conceptualize program
document test and upgrade software and
their components
software developers invent manage and
optimize computer programs that run on
desktops laptops smartphones and other
mobile devices
these computer science professionals
write complex code that governs how
desktop applications function
they also specialize in troubleshooting
code bugs
updating user interfaces creating new
tools and much more
just like web developers professionals
in this field are often categorized into
specific roles based on their
specializations
we have the application software
developer and the system software
developer
now an application software engineer is
a professional who focuses on designing
specific desktop and mobile applications
tools and games for consumer audiences
and a system software developer
is largely concerned with designing
systems level software for enterprise
customers rather than the public
the software they develop is used to
manage corporate network apps database
management systems and other critical
infrastructure
talking about their desirable skills
they need to be proficient in
programming in the field of javascript
java c-sharp php python and ruby
they must also have a good understanding
of operating systems network and
database management
so now moving on to the main topic of
discussion software developer versus web
developer
first let's compare the two based on
their prowess or area of expertise
a software developer is associated with
developing products that can be run on
multiple systems
this product could be any kind of
software
their area of work includes requirement
analysis
planning coding testing of applications
implementation deployment and
maintenance
talking about web developers they are
responsible for the development of
websites
they are also expected to follow the
process of the software development
lifecycle while building their products
next up is the type of product
now a software developer creates
programs for standalone desktop or
mobile platforms
on the other hand a web developer takes
care of the web framework server side
functions api integration and the
business logic
the third point of comparison is product
compatibility
now software development applications
are compatible across multiple operating
systems or platforms
the web applications on the other hand
are designed to be compatible across
multiple web browsers
next up is the learning curve
well software engineering never focuses
exclusively on coding
however you should know at least a
couple of languages and a deeper
understanding of how they function
some of the languages that you should be
proficient in include java c-sharp
python and some of its libraries and
frameworks javascript and ruby among
others a web developer should be
familiar with markup languages like html
css
javascript libraries and frameworks like
react and angular
you should also have a good hold of
back-end frameworks like python django
and node
the next parameter is a job title
now there are different job titles for
these professions
some of them for software development
are software developer software engineer
junior software developer senior
software developer and a software
architect
on the other hand a web developer could
receive titles like front-end developer
back-end developer
stack developer or just a web developer
now of course companies have discretion
over assigning these job roles to their
employees
lastly let's look at the job outlook and
salaries
now the job growth projections for
software developers are even more
optimistic than those for web
development roles
alongside promising job growth software
developers also have higher salaries
than other it professionals
now the average salary of a software
developer in the us is around 76 000 us
dollars per annum
and the average salary of a software
developer in india is around 5 lakh
indian rupees per annum
for a web developer the average salary
in the us is around 68 000 us dollars
per annum and in india it's around 4
lakh indian rupees per annum
now i'm sure you must be confused as to
which one to choose
well to be frank it's just a matter of
preference if you have strong knowledge
of data structures file systems
algorithms source control operating and
network systems then software
development would be a better choice
but if you have creative ideas for
websites love designing them have a good
understanding of html and css and
ultimately the knack to integrate your
design ideas to create responsive user
interfaces then a web development role
could be a good career path
then web development could be a better
career path to choose
today's topic is web developer versus a
web designer
now it is extremely common to get
confused between a web developer and a
web designer
now these roles are used interchangeably
given their names and dependency on each
other
however there are a few differences
among them
people aspiring to get into web
development often ask me
which role is suitable for them or
rather where do they fit in or what has
to be done during the process of web
development
so i've particularly kept this session
cleared to clarify all your doubts and
provide an insight into both web
developer and web designer roles and
their responsibilities
so let's begin
first let's look at what's in store for
us
we'll first look at what web development
is
then we'll understand who exactly is a
web developer
after that we will have a look at what
web designers actually do
moving ahead we'll compare between web
developers and designers to give you a
greater insight into both the roles then
we'll look at the current salary trends
of a web developer and a designer in the
tech industry
and lastly we'll conclude with deciding
which role to go for
so without further ado let's get started
what exactly is web development
so web development is the process of
building websites and applications for
the internet
now keep in mind that web development
and web design is seen as different
fields in most of the use cases even
though they collaborate together to
provide the end result that is the web
application
so the web development can be broken
down into three layers that is the
client-side coding which includes the
front-end then you have the server-side
coding which is the back-end and then
you have the database technologies
but who exactly is a web developer
now that we know what web development is
let's understand this
so here are some of the technologies
used by a web developer there's html for
web layout
css for web styling
javascript for making web applications
more responsive and interactive
there's react.js which is a javascript
framework used for front-end development
and then there's node.js which is a
javascript framework again used for
server-side development
there's mongodb which is a database
technology for storing data for web
applications
and then there's also angular which is
another front-end development framework
based on typescript
now there are many other technologies
like php java ruby etc
and these are most commonly used by all
the web developers
but
you might be wondering who a web
developer is now the role of a web
developer is to build and maintain
websites
he also takes a web design which has
been created by either a client or a
design team and turns it into a website
now web developers are also responsible
for building a product that meets both
the clients needs and those of the
customers and the end users
web developers collaborate with
stakeholders clients and designers in
order to understand the vision
a web developer also has to perform
specific tasks
however these responsibilities may vary
depending on whether they're working as
a front-end back-end or a full-stack
developer
generally full stack developers
specialize in both the front end and the
back end
so let's go ahead and know more about
each type of web developer in this field
now there are basically three types of
web developers
there's a front-end developers
who build and maintain the client side
of an application
then you have the back-end developers
who work behind the scenes and manage
the services of a web application
and finally you have full stack
developers who manage the project
workflow and work on the required
features of a web application
now let's look at each role in detail
first up when it comes to front-end
developers they usually code the client
side of a web application
while the back-end developers build and
maintain the services needed by a web
application behind the scenes and then
you have the full stack developer whose
province is in both front-end and
back-end development
now front-end developers convert the
design into a real-life application
using html javascript and css
back-end developers on the other hand
ensure that the web applications keep
running smoothly
and full stack developers supervise the
development and guide on best practices
front-end developers ensure responsive
and adaptive user interface for your
applications
back-end developers manage services like
api data storage for the web application
and so on
and full stack developers know both the
business requirements and the user
interface requirements
now let's go through the skill set of a
web developer
the skills that a web developer must
have
are html that is the markup language for
building web page layouts
css which is the style sheet for styling
the html elements in a website
there's javascript which is a scripting
language for bringing web applications
to life by making them more interactive
and responsive
and he should also know front-end
frameworks like react angular view that
help in making the client side of
applications look better and speed up
the development
moving on you have the backend developer
skills
there's php which is the backend
language that helps in maintaining all
the work that happens behind the scenes
in a web application
and then there's python which is a very
popular language used in various
software development fields it is used
to handle server-side tasks in web
development then there's java which is
one of the most used languages for
software development and therefore is
also used in backend development by
developers
and then there's database management so
databases like mysql and mongodb are
used for storing data for web
applications
now full stack developers
have skills that cover both front-end
and back-end development of a web
application
therefore they manage the workflow of a
web application development environment
moving on who exactly is a web designer
now here are some of the technologies
used by a web designer
there's adobe photoshop for image
editing and web design
there's adobe illustrator for working
with vectors and scalable web elements
sketch for designing user experience for
web applications
adobe xd also used for user experience
design of web and mobile applications
adobe indesign for marketing campaigns
like banners posters and magazines
there are many other technologies like
adobe after effects blender that are
used by web designers as well
but you might be wondering who exactly
is a web designer
so web designer is one who plans and
designs the layout and other elements of
a website or an application
he performs digital retouching along
with image editing or video editing in
some cases
web designers are responsible for
designing a product that meets both the
clients needs and those of the customers
and end users
he also designs products that are user
friendly appealing and visually
effective
the design is preferably modern and also
easy to use at the same time
so let's go ahead and know more about
the design role
some of the popular design roles include
web designers who design websites and
its elements there is ux designers or
researchers who are responsible for the
user experience of a web or a mobile
application
there are multimedia specialists who
specialize in handling media for web
applications like images and videos
and then you have game designer which is
another role that employs similar tools
as that of web design like adobe
creative cloud
now let's look at each role in detail
a web designer designs the look of
websites and its elements a ux designer
designs and prototypes the look and feel
of web applications and mobile
applications
a multimedia specialist handles media
requirements like editing images videos
etc
then you have the game designer who
designs the props and characters of a
game for various platforms
a web designer typically uses tools like
adobe photoshop and adobe dreamweaver
a ux designer uses tools like adobe
illustrator sketch adobe xd
a multimedia specialist mainly uses
adobe creative cloud which includes
photoshop illustrator and after effects
and then the game designer uses tools
like adobe illustrator autodesk software
blender and unity
so let's go to the skill set of a web
designer
the skills that a web designer must have
adobe creative cloud this is the
industry standard software for web and
multimedia design a web designer must
have an imaginative mindset to design
modern web elements
a web designer must also be creative
enough to make the app look visually
appealing
he must also have the ability to give
attention to detail for minor features
and improvements in the web or mobile
applications
some of the other soft skills include
communication skills collaborative
mindset and patience
so now let's make a detailed comparison
between web developer and a web designer
so to summarize we've put together a
table for you
so a web developer
builds web applications using languages
like html css and javascript while a web
designer designs the web applications
using tools like adobe photoshop or
sketch
a web developer frequently uses
javascript frameworks for more
streamlined development
while a web designer uses adobe creative
cloud for most of the design needs
a web developer should possess good
coding skills while a web designer
should have good graphic design skills
web developers have to keep themselves
up to date with the latest web
frameworks and libraries
while web designers have to keep
themselves updated with the latest
design trends and color palettes
so going ahead let's look at the
industry trends
web developers usually have a trend of
earning more than the web designers
still it depends on how well you perform
in your particular job role
so if you're good in web design you
might actually earn more than a fellow
web developer
so the average salary of a web developer
in india is around 3 lakhs 90 000 rupees
per annum
the average salary of a web developer in
the united states is around 68 000
per annum
the average salary of a web designer in
india is around 3 lakh 60 000 rupees per
annum
while the average salary of a web
designer in the united states is around
53 000 us dollars per annum
so
moving to the most important question
which one should you choose
it is really a matter of preference
if you have a creative bent of mind and
enjoy using good looking web and mobile
applications and also enjoy designing
them then i would suggest you go for a
web or ux designer role if you have a
technical background like java or python
and you're interested in bringing the
designs to life i would suggest you go
for a web developer role javascript was
developed in the year 1995
by a person named brendan ike
brendan was working for netscape
communications while he developed
javascript in 10 days
there were a few changes in the name of
javascript initially it was moca which
was later changed to live script and
then it finally became javascript
the start of javascript wasn't that good
as so many developers who were using
java at that time
they considered javascript as a language
for designers and non-engineers
no one ever knew that this small side
scripting language would have a great
future today more than 90 percent of the
websites out there they are using
javascript somehow many of you guys gets
confused with java and javascript let me
clear it for you that both java and
javascript they are different languages
they have almost nothing in common
many people say that javascript was
named after java as a part of a
marketing strategy to gain wider
acceptance and recognition in 1995 java
was a buzzword when javascript was
developed that's why they renamed
javascript after java let's move on to
what is javascript
have you guys ever been through a
website where you can see images that
slides automatically one such website is
amazon the home page of amazon where we
can see different types of ongoing sales
is an example of javascript
in layman language javascript is a
lightweight scripting language used to
make web pages more interactive and more
lively earlier when javascript was
developed it was only a side scripting
language to do basic tasks like you can
add pop-ups in your web page or you can
make your webpage more interactive
nothing more than that but now the whole
scenario has changed with the help of
javascript we can create applications as
well
if we talk about applications let's take
an example let's suppose we want to
create an app we can create it in
android or in ios but we have to learn
few different languages to create those
apps for android we have to learn java
and xml and swift we have to learn for
ios but with the help of javascript you
can create hybrid applications which can
work on any platform without any problem
tech giants like google paypal amazon
and youtube they are using javascript
these days the evolution of javascript
in the past few years was unbelievable
suppose you want to create a single page
website every one of us is familiar with
gmail let's suppose
so gmail is a single page website which
looks more like a desktop software than
a website so gmail is based on
angular.js
it is a popular framework by google
which is free of cost and it is totally
based on javascript now let's go over
some of the features of javascript these
features are actually why it is
considered that using javascript is
advantageous over other languages
so let's start with some of these points
javascript is not a proper programming
language indeed it is a scripting
language
which works in the runtime environment
just like python
so there are few other languages like c
plus plus and java they need a compiler
to work but with javascript you don't
need a compiler once you are done with
the script
it will interpret and show you the
output in the browser directly
next up is lightweighted javascript can
provide programming facility to some
extent in javascript you don't need to
specify any data type or return type
which helps in making development more
quicker that's why it is known as light
weighted
javascript is both client-side as well
as server-side technology
client-side technology runs on the
user's computer whereas the server-side
technology runs on the web browser
initially when javascript was introduced
it was introduced as a client-side
technology but with the introduction of
node.js in 2009 one can now work in the
backend as well
there is a way to validate the user's
data before sending it to the web server
and we can do that with the help of
javascript the data will be checked for
correct form and value
all we have to do is start a loop give
it the condition
to check the data javascript is also
platform independent although originally
designed to work on browsers only but
now it is a platform independent
language which means once you are done
with the script you can use it on any
browser or platform without any problem
javascript is an object based scripting
language although many programmers do
not consider javascript as a true
object-oriented programming language due
to its lack of class concept
it does support other features of
object-oriented programming like it
supports encapsulation it supports
polymorphism and also it supports
prototypal inheritance the last but not
the least feature of javascript is case
sensitive so when it comes to keywords
identifiers names and functions
javascript differentiates between
capital and lowercase letters we have to
keep this in mind while programming
now i will quickly go over some of the
javascript applications where javascript
is currently being implemented
first one that comes to every person's
mind is web development it was also the
main motive behind developing javascript
we have technologies like angular we
have node.js we can create beautiful web
pages
also javascript can be used along with
html and css to make those static
looking web pages more engaging if we
talk about other applications of
javascript we can use it in app
development either mobile app or web app
like we took the example before that how
hybrid apps made with the help of
javascript can take over traditional
android and ios app
one of the most important and unique
application of javascript is in
smartwatches the bengal.js is an open
sourced smartwatch powered by javascript
gordon williams the man who is currently
working on this project it is said that
this new open sourced stack built around
javascript will replace the onboard
firmware soon the next application of
javascript is client-side validation as
we discussed earlier javascript is used
to validate the user data whether the
user's input is correct or not by
cross-checking it with the given
condition like the user wants to enter
in your website and you want it to be a
user with at the right gmail.com in his
email id so you will give that condition
to javascript and it will cross check it
with the user's information like when
the user will try to enter in your
website it will check that if at the
rate gmail.com is there or not in the
user's email id
so it can validate the user also apart
from that one more application of
javascript is game development
javascript can be used to make fully
fledged 2d or 3d games using different
libraries although most javascript game
development focuses on creating games
used in browsers only
till now we have an idea about what
javascript is
its features and its applications so if
you want to learn javascript you need to
do some basic things to make your
learning experience more smoother let's
take a look at the prerequisites to use
javascript the first one is the basic
knowledge of html and css to use
javascript along with html and css you
first need to know how html and css
works see html is used to create the
structure of a web page while css is
used to style that webpage in order to
use these two with javascript you need
to have the basic knowledge of html and
css because if you want to learn a new
language first of all you need to know
why to use that technology and to learn
javascript more efficiently you need to
have the basic knowledge of html and css
it's better to have a web browser that
supports javascript like google chrome
or mozilla firefox or you can use safari
as well if you are using a macbook you
will need an operating system like
windows linux or mac operating system to
learn javascript a computer with minimum
512 mb of ram would be enough for you to
start learning javascript but i will
recommend you a computer with 1gb of ram
or 4gb of ram for a better experience
you can use any text editor you have
notepad which is free and is already
available for windows
if you don't want to use notepad you can
use other free softwares like sublime or
you can use visual code in this
particular course we will be using
visual code and i'll tell you how to
install visual code and what are the
features of visual code also suppose you
do not have any prior knowledge about
javascript don't worry about it we will
take you through the whole course and we
will ensure that you can understand
javascript let's start this video with
some facts about javascript
javascript is the only programming
language that a browser can understand
25 years ago when developers were
thinking about a language that a browser
can understand
there were a few languages that were
present in the market at that time just
like java still there were some problems
with these languages
that these languages need a server to
work with the browser javascript on the
other hand can work directly with the
browser you write the code in the editor
the browser will go through it it will
interpret it and then runs the program
the popularity of javascript increased
with time being a language which can do
so many tasks whether it be designing a
website's front-end or going through any
website's back-end javascript can do
anything by the end of 2018 over 95
percent of the internet was powered by
javascript means almost every website
out there is using javascript in some
way or another
do you guys know about stack overflow a
website for every programmer don't worry
you will get to know about it once you
start with the programming part stack
overflow states that javascript is the
most popular programming language used
by the developers
let me quickly run you through the
reasons why one should learn javascript
and then we'll briefly elaborate each of
these reasons
javascript has the most powerful
frameworks
javascript is constantly growing and is
a well paid job
javascript is beginner friendly and it
has the largest community
javascript provides wide range of usage
as well
let's move on further and see
why each of these reason is important
javascript has the most powerful
frameworks for every task a user wants
to do like for designing a single page
website like you want to
design a website like gmail you can use
angular.js if you want to design ui
components or user interfaces for single
page application you have react.js you
want to develop a mobile or a desktop
application let's suppose you have
view.js for that as well basically you
can do anything with powerful javascript
frameworks
next up is constant truth one of the
main reasons behind one should learn
javascript javascript is one of the
fastest growing languages and stands
among the top 10 languages used by the
developers with so much increase in
mobile market mobile web development has
seen an immense rise in need of
interactivity
which is possible only with the help of
javascript that's why javascript is
continuously growing and there is no way
that javascript will go down shortly
the developers working in javascript are
well paid across the world anyone who
wants to be a web designer or a web
developer needs to learn javascript it
is a must have skill for being a good
web developer we will discuss it in
javascript jobs section
javascript is an easy to learn language
compared to many other programming
languages
like java python and php javascript
provides easy entry points to the world
of programming the best thing about
javascript is that it comes
pre-installed on almost every web
browser so you don't need to set up any
environment to start development in
javascript which means you can start
coding right away
javascript has the largest community
among all the programming languages out
there
community size does matter when it comes
to programming language because the
larger the community size is
the more help you would be likely to get
currently javascript has the biggest
stack overflow community it has
overtaken java in terms of community
size and is still growing at a rapid
pace wide range of usage in my opinion
one of the most important reasons why
one should learn javascript by knowing
javascript you can build an entire
website from its backend to the front
apart from that you can also build a
full flash mobile application for the
back end you don't need to learn other
programming languages node.js is enough
with a bit of knowledge about database
and apis there is nothing you can't do
with javascript when it comes to website
development
let's move on and discuss few jobs you
can take up after learning javascript
and we'll also discuss their average
salaries in usa and in india
so the first one is a full stack
developer a full stack developer is one
of the highest paid jobs in web
development sector a full stack
developer is equally proficient in
client side as well as server side
development a full stack developer earns
around 9 lakh per annum which is quite a
decent amount of money for a person
living in india but if you are a full
stack developer in u.s you can earn up
to hundred thousand dollars per annum
which is a huge amount
a front-end developer is the one who
deals with the front end of any website
or application it's obvious that a
front-end developer will not earn as
much as a full stack developer but the
amount of money a front-end developer
earns in a year is decent a javascript
developer works on the front-end and
sometimes back-end also
a javascript developer may be
responsible for the whole website or
just a few aspects or pages of different
websites they earn quite well when it
comes to salary a js developer in us
earns around 75 thousand dollar per
annum which when converted to indian
rupees sums around 55 lakhs approx which
is a huge amount
designing a ui is an interesting job as
it needs creativity along with skills
it's always fun to design interfaces to
attract users one should need a lot of
creativity for this job the amount of
money a ui ux designer earns in india is
around 7 lakh per annum but it can go up
as much as 20 lakh per annum depends
upon the skills possessed and creativity
of the designer so choose your career
wisely let's start this video with the
introduction to dom
dom stands for document object model it
is an api for html and xml documents
which helps javascript to understand
what is there written inside the html
document api stands for application
programming interface to understand api
better let's take an example of a
restaurant
imagine yourself in the restaurant you
are sitting at the table with the menu
the chef in the kitchen is also part of
the system the waiter here works as a
messenger between you and the chef
that's what api does it works as a
moderator between javascript and the
html document
dom defines the whole html document in a
hierarchical form to make it
understandable for javascript so that
other javascript functions can work over
it
it represents the entire document in the
form of object and nodes
whether it be elements or text or
anything stored in the document the
entire page content can be accessed or
manipulated by javascript dom is not
used with javascript only other
languages like python also uses dom dom
was designed to be used independently to
begin with dom there is nothing special
you have to do different browsers have
different implementation of the document
object model
every browser uses dom to make the web
page of the document accessible by
javascript let's move on and see what is
document object model with the help of
an example i believe you guys have the
basic knowledge of html and css a
prerequisite for this course let's start
things off with a basic html example
here we have a code that consists tags
like html head body heading tag etc we
have the html tag here the opening html
tag and the closing html tag
inside the html tag we have the head tag
which contains the document's header
part inside the head tag there is a
title tag that contains the title of the
web page
then comes the body tag which contains a
heading tag and two div tags with ids as
div 1 and div 2 a div tag defines a
particular section in the html document
the id used within the div tag it is an
attribute basically that has to be
unique within the document to make the
element unique from other elements next
up we have a paragraph tag with a class
attribute within it css and javascript
uses classes to select and access
specific elements don't worry guys if
you have no idea about it
let us first see the output of this code
before going to the document object
model
of this whole document so guys this is
the output of the previous code we just
came through here we can see the title
of the web page as well as heading after
it there were two different div tags
used in the code here is the output of
both the div text the question here is
where are those id and class attributes
seen in the output the answer to this
question is there's nothing on this web
page that can show both of them we can
use them in our css file or through
javascript to specify the containers in
which they are used so we have concluded
how a normal document works and how the
browser interprets the html code but how
javascript uses this code is a bit
different that's where dom comes into
play when the actual html document is
loaded in the browser another
representation of that document is
created known as document object model
here's the model you can see on your
screen
each of the tags used in html document
is correspondingly represented as object
in the dom
like starting from the html tag and
covering all the other tags like head
title body and few more
the same hierarchy as there was in the
html document goes with the document
object model also
document object model is simply the same
html document with different
representation the reason behind this
different representation is that it's
easy for javascript to interpret this
format
javascript can't understand tags but it
can understand these objects javascript
can easily manipulate these objects
using different functions which we will
see in future while working on these
functions for example if you want to
access the text present inside the
heading tag you can do it by accessing
the heading tag with javascript
you can also work on the style of this
text with the help of javascript as well
javascript uses the concept of nodes it
can access nodes of the document object
model there are many types of nodes
present in the dom the basic three types
are element node attribute node and text
node the element node consists of all
the tags used in html document like the
head tag and the body tag the attribute
node contains the attributes used in
html document by now i hope you have
understood the concept of attributes so
javascript can access these attributes
as well and the user can work upon them
as per requirements
the text here in the html document that
is simply
it can also be accessed with the help of
javascript it is the value of that
particular element
before installing vs code let's discuss
a few things about what is an ide so ide
stands for integrated development
environment it is a software application
basically it comprehends facilities to a
programmer for software development just
like photoshop makes it easier for us to
edit photos in the same way ide makes it
easier for a programmer to write code if
you want to write code ide will help you
write that and it will help you in
software development
there are a number of ides present in
the market today we have sublime we have
pycharm we have comodo we have notepad
and notepad plus plus as well but in
this particular course we will be using
visual studio code or vs code we can say
so let me run you through some of the
advantages that why we are using vs code
for this codes so first of all vs code
is free to use as it is an open source
software so you can use it without any
cost
it supports multiple programming
languages there is nothing like you need
any web support or work on different
editors for different programming you
can use vs code for different languages
extensions are also one of the main
reasons behind using vs code see you
want to work on a programming language
it does not support all you have to do
is add an extension search for it and
you are good to go it will also not
affect the speed of the editor as it
runs as a different process
it can also detect code snippet whether
it is complete or not like you are using
a variable in your program and you
forgot to declare it
vs code will do it for you this property
is known as intellisense
besides all these properties one main
key feature behind using vs code is it
is cross platform it is available for
mac it is available for linux and
windows as well i think there are enough
features we have discussed till now
there are many more features we will
discuss them while installing or while
working in vs code so for now let's move
on to the installation process the
installation process for vs code is
pretty simple just go to google and
search for vs code
the next page which will open here you
can see that the first link available is
from the official website click on that
and you will go to their official
website here in the front you can see
the download this you can download the
stable version from here only
or if you want to download it for you
according to your pc's specifications
you can click on the download button
present at the top right corner of your
screen here you can see that vs code is
available for different platforms it is
available for windows for linux and for
mac as well you can download it from
here as well so if you want to download
this for windows you can click here
it will take you to another page and it
will start downloading vs once the
download completes open the setup file
from your downloads and it will take you
to the license agreement page you have
to agree with all the terms and
condition you can go through the full
license but then it will take a lot of
time to go through all this once you
click on it
this window will open where you have to
select the location you want your vs
code to locate any id you install the
default location for all the editors is
the same you can click on browse and
select any other location if you want
but for now i'll be leaving it as it is
and i'll click on next now this will
open and you will click next from here
now it will ask you some questions like
if you want to create a desktop icon or
not select all of them and click on next
now click on install and it will install
vs code for you sit back and relax it'll
take time so once you are done with the
installation process click on finish and
the visual studio code will start
automatically
so here we are you can see that we are
on the welcome page so let's start with
these icon present on the left side of
the editor this icon here is explorer so
vs code works with the folders in your
system click on open folder
and just
search any folder or you can take any
folder of your choice
so here in my pc i'll go to work and
i'll
take javascript as my folder i'll select
it and see it will open the folder and i
already have a few programs written over
here like this
and i have a few more programs like this
and this
you can open any program from that
folder by using this explorer option you
can open any program present in that
folder so basically what it does any
program you make in visual studio code
you will save it in this folder only so
it will be easy for you
to open any program anytime next up we
have the search button
to find any keyword or word present in
your code whatever you write here it
will show you where it is present in
your code or in your document
so let's suppose i write here simply
learn c it will show you simply learn in
your main screen so you have a shortcut
key for this also press control plus f
from your keyboard and write anything
here like it's written simply linear
press enter and it'll show you the
result the third option here is for
version control if you want to use any
version control like you want to use git
vs code has very good integration with
kit the next button here is for debug or
it will run your program once you are
done with writing the code click here
and run and debug just open it with
chrome you have a shortcut for this as
well press f5 from your keyboard and it
will do the same the next button here is
for extensions here you can find many
extensions given by the vs code
community they are free to use
for now
we will use these three extensions the
first one is html css support just click
on the search button write html css
support the first option click on that
and install that extension similarly you
have to install few more you have to
install javascript and type script
nightly
and you have to install live server in
the same way i'll tell you the use of
live server in the next video when we
will be writing our first hello world
program let me end this video by giving
you a shortcut let's create a new file
here click here create a new file
just
close it create a new file we will name
it as
new
dot html
so it's new.html here one thing you have
to keep in mind
while saving a file make sure to save
that file with dot html extension here
we are about to start writing our first
program so just write
exclamation mark and press enter
it will do this see it will write the
basic html code which you will need in
almost every program from now on so you
don't have to write this code every time
just do it this way and start writing
main program we are using vs code studio
as a text editor to write the script
here we have already discussed the
benefits as well as the features of vs
code in the previous video so as i have
already mentioned you must have a web
browser with javascript enabled in it so
if you are using google chrome it's
quite easy to enable javascript let me
take you through open google chrome go
to settings and just write javascript in
the search option go to site settings
and scroll down you will find here
javascript allow it if it's not allowed
in my case it's already allowed so i'm
good to go
once you have downloaded the editor and
you are done with the environment setup
and all you can start writing the
program so let's go
to escort we will open a new file here
and save it with the name let's open a
new file and we will save it with name
first dot html make sure to save your
file with dot html extension as it will
make it easy for the computer to
understand that this particular file is
an html file so
in the last video we installed an
extension named live server let me tell
you how to use it and what are the
benefits of using live server so let's
write a basic html program or
just press the exclamation key and press
enter here we are with the basic html
program
we have not done anything yet just edit
it a little bit we will add a heading
tag and inside the heading tag we will
write a heading let's suppose we are
writing
hello so now right click on your desktop
and click on open with live server
what this will do it will open your
program in the browser see it's the
basic thing
so let me tell you what its benefits are
it will open your program in the browser
and whatever changes you are making in
the programs will be directly shown in
the browser the moment you save them see
just use google chrome or whatever
browser you are using
and in the vs code side by side we'll be
using it side by side now let's suppose
we'll change something here let's add a
word here hello
world and the moment we save it it will
be reflected in your browser as well so
that's the benefit of using livestr we
will be using it during our whole code
so now we are done with that let's start
with the program so here we are with our
basic html code which has only tags in
it it will print that thing if i remove
this heading tag let me remove it and
moment i save it it will print nothing
so guys let me give you a brief
introduction to these tags these html
tags are used to render html files
properties so that the browser can
differentiate between simple text and
html tags
you can use as many tags according to
your requirements in our first program
we will write a single line statement
over the browser for that we will need
the script tag don't worry if you don't
know much about script let me tell you
briefly about this text functionality it
is used to embed a client-side script
language remember guys script tag is
used to embed javascript with html this
is where html and javascript comes
together it may contain the scripting
statements or point towards the external
script through the src attribute we will
see the src attribute as well we'll use
the script tag inside the body tag or we
can use it wherever we want to use it
like it's not necessary to use it inside
the body tag only we can use it anywhere
in our program so let's start with this
first
let's start the scripted
we are done with it now the script tag
we have to type an attribute
the attribute is the type is it's a text
file
we are done with our script tag to write
on the web page we use a very basic
command the document.write
it is a javascript method using which
you can print anything on the browser
let's see what document.write can do
let's write here something
document.try
and any text you want to write inside it
let's suppose hello world
welcome to
simply good
so guys we are done with this we have
written a text over here hello world
welcome to simply code let's see what
will happen when we save it
press ctrl s and the moment you save it
here it will be reflected on your
browser here you can see in our browser
it's written over here hello world
welcome to simply we can define
javascript in an external file as well
let's see how we can do this how this
script tag will point towards an
external javascript file here what you
have to do you have written script just
before type use an attribute src and
give it the source of the file but till
now we don't have any javascript file so
let's create a file first name it as
script.js remember you have to save it
with dot js extension we are done with
it and we are good to go so here we will
write document
dot right
and any text you want to write here
hello world welcome to
simply learn
we will save it the moment we will save
it here
there's something wrong i guess
okay we have not given the source code
of that javascript so here we have to
give the name of that file it was
script.js
moment we will save it see the text has
changed here
initially it was hello world welcome to
simply code but now it is hello world
welcome to simply learn
this document.write is not interpreted
by the browser that's because this
script tag is now pointing towards an
external javascript file anything you
will write inside this script tag will
not be considered now so we are done
with this script tag here we now have an
idea of how to embed javascript with
html and now let's see some of the
features of document.write so let's
suppose you are you have written this
text here let's erase it and see what
else it can do let's give it a task to
add two numbers let's suppose we have
given here 9 plus 3 let's see if it
works
see
it will give you the output directly
here document.write 9 plus 3 it will
give you the output as 12. similarly you
will do
any mathematical task any calculation
you want to do
let's suppose
7 multiplied by
8
see
you can see here 12 56 square let's
give it another one 9 multiply 5 minus
let's suppose 3 and save it 3 9 into 5
is 45 and if you minus 3 from 45 will
get 42. here is the answer for s42 56 is
for 7 into 8 7 multiplied by 8 and 12 is
for 9 plus 3
so with that we are done with how to
embed with javascript with html let's
move on to another concept in javascript
that is console.log console.log is a
function in javascript that works the
same as document.write
but it will not print anything in the
browser let's give it a try
let's
clear this and suppose we write here
console.log
and give it a command
save it and see there is nothing printed
on the browser let's write something in
the body tag we'll use a heading tag and
write something here let's go again and
go to body tag we'll use a heading tag
here as well
and write something here let's suppose
we write
code
save it see this is printed on the
browser to open your browser's console
go to browser right click here and go to
inspect element or you can use control
plus shift plus i which i normally do
here you can see the console option see
it has many options like elements
consoles sources network and many more
but for now let's focus on console here
you can see the text printed here so
what's the point of doing this whenever
we write a code we usually have many
variables and functions and a lot of
these kinds of things
we don't always know what to expect as
the output maybe we expect a particular
result but we might get something else
one way of debugging our code is that we
can pass a value to this function here
only and we can check the result of that
value
out of the code let's add two numbers
here so if you don't understand it
basically what we are doing for now we
are writing a small piece of code like
the program is not that big but later on
when we are good with javascript and
we'll use javascript as a primary
language the
size of the program will go longer and
longer so not every time you are
supposed to
check the output of your code by doing
that only so if you are using any
variables or you are using any functions
you can check the output here only if
you have to use that variable in that
way or you have to change something so
you will get it here only that's the use
of console.log
let's add two numbers
and remove it a is equal to five and
let these value is eight
suppose
okay we are done with these two numbers
and we will what we'll do we will write
console.log
we have given it the command to add a
and b
let's see if it works here
see the value of a plus b is 13. you can
see it here in console the value is 13
you can see it here so here we can see
that the output is
13 you can do any complex calculation
here in the console it will give you the
correct answer you can see here script
dot js colon 4 the number after the
column is the line in script.js here in
our file we can see that the console.log
command is in line number 4. so here it
is written that it is line number 4 here
so if you click on this
you can see
the script.js opened in a very small
window and you can edit it from here as
well so this is not a random line number
to prove this let's go on to a program
and let's move this to another line see
now the console.log is in line 11.
save it and here you can see this also
changed to 11 so let's make this more
complex add another variable c we'll add
another variable here let suppose we had
c here we'll give it a more complex
equation let's suppose let's c equals to
the moment we save it it will give it
the answer
oh no we are done with the equation
let's change it here also
the value of
c is
let's see if it works or not press ctrl
s it's saved and the value of c is 7
let's see if this value is correct or
not the value of a was 5 5 into 3 is 15
15 plus 8 is 23 23 plus 4 is 27
27
plus
a minus 25 value of a is 5 minus 25 is
minus 20
27 minus 20 the value of c is c it's
correct
check it yourself if you can do
something more interesting with this
console.log or you can do something more
interesting with document.write
so console.log allows us to debug our
code and we can use it if we are not
sure about the output in a lengthy
program so variables are named storage
that a program can manipulate as the
name suggests a variable is a value that
can change according to conditions
variables refers to those memory blocks
inside the computer where we can store
information let's suppose you want to
store any value inside your computer so
variable will represent the location of
that value
in simple terms variables are cups with
stuff inside them and you can use that
stuff later again and again according to
the way you want to before the
introduction of es6 or ecmascript we can
say which is the updated version of
javascript variables were declared using
a single keyword only which is where
we'll try to declare a few variables
here we'll see how where keyword works
so let's comment this thing first
so let's declare a few variables let's
suppose where a equals to
15 we will declare
where b and the value of b will be six
we will declare where
c and the value of c would be
a plus b so here we have defined three
variables a b and c
a is a variable with value 15 stored
inside it and so is b the value of b is
6
but c is a variable that will contain
the value of a plus b let's try to print
this on browser
document.write
and we will print the value of c
save it and here you can see the value
of c is 21
that's the correct answer so similarly
you can also print a and b as well let's
print a and b as well here
what we will do we'll copy this line
we'll paste it for a n
we'll update this here as well
so it won't create any confusion
so here you can see the value of c is 21
the value of a is 15 and the value of b
is 6. it shows the value of all the
three variables we declared but with the
introduction of es6 or ecmascript in
2015
two more ways were introduced to declare
a variable these are let and const we
shall discuss these two terms in the
later part of this session let me show
you how to declare a variable there are
a few things you have to keep in mind
while declaring a variable name here we
have seen we use three variables a b and
c
that was an easy task to do but giving a
variable any name like something other
than a single alphabet so you have to
keep a few things in mind while naming
them start them with a letter underscore
or a dollar sign
you can't use any sign except underscore
or dollar so if you are
giving a variable name
you can't use any other sign except the
underscore or the dollar sign
you can use these two signs only you
can't use any other sign
you can't use a number in the starting
apart from that let's suppose you want
to give it a name as 9be you can't do
that in javascript javascript won't
allow you this if you try to save it it
will throw you an error invalid or
unexpected token so you can't do this in
javascript there is no limit for the
length of the variable name but you
can't use reserved keywords in a
variable name like let's try to create a
variable with name as class class is a
reserved keyword in javascript
we'll save it
and see here it throws an error
unexpected token plus
but
you can use a class with capital c
let's save it and here it will work fine
why it works because javascript
variables are case sensitive if we try
to create a variable with same name
let's see we try to create a variable
with where girl and another variable
will be where girl with capital g this
time javascript will treat these two
variables differently these two are
different variables for javascript as
javascript is case sensitive when it
comes to variables
let's declare a few more variables let's
remove it we'll declare a few more
variables let's comment this part as
well
we'll declare a few more variables
suppose we declare a variable with
keyword where and we'll name this
variable as bikening where
bike name
and press enter
if we leave this variable without
assigning it any value the by default
value will be undefined let's try to
print the value of this variable
right we will try to print the value of
byte name
save it here you can see the value it
shows is undefined so the by default
value of a variable if you do not assign
it any value will be undefined
let's try to give it a value let's
suppose we
try to give bike name
we use
equals to operator to assign it a value
to assign let's suppose we'll assign it
yamaha
semicolon and press ctrl plus s to save
this and here you can see the output as
yamaha
you can also assign a value to the
variable during declaration as we have
done in the previous examples here we
have assigned the variables value at the
time of declaration only let's move on
to let and const
so we will discuss let and cons but
first we will compare let with where let
is also used to declare a variable just
like where is used but there is a
limitation to use let
let is not accessible outside the block
in which it is declared
so we will use let here only let bike
name equals and we will change this
value as well we'll change it to hero
let's say save it and here you can see
the output as hero but
if we try to put this code inside a
block
let's suppose we
put this code inside this block a pair
of curly braces
and we will again try to access
document.write we will try to access
bike name again from here from outside
the block we try to access this save it
and here you can see by name is not
defined it is an error in line 18. so
what's happening here basically you
can't access a let variable outside the
scope you can't access it from here but
it will work with wear we try to replace
let with wear and save it here you can
see it says hero and hero
because first it will interpret this
method and then it will interpret this
as well in case of wear due to its
limited scope let variables are used
when there is limited use only like in
for loop or in while loop we will learn
these loop in future let will not allow
you to redeclare any variable let's
understand this with an example here is
the code as well
we have declared where bike name and we
will remove this
and first we will try to do this with
where let's suppose where bike name
equals to
tvs control plus s it says hero and tvs
so the variable name the bike name is
same in both cases here and here as well
these are same but with where keyword
you can do that let will not allow you
to do this if we use let here in place
of
where we'll write let here as well and
we'll change the value as well we will
give it as
kawasaki
and let's suppose suzuki here
save it
see bike name has already been declared
so that's what light won't allow you to
do you can repeat the same let variable
in different scope it won't create any
problem but it will not allow you to
re-declare any declared variable so
let's move on to const we use const when
there are values we don't want to change
or that will never change basically so
the keyword const is little misleading
as it defines a constant reference to a
value not the constant value we can't
change the primitive value but we can
change the properties of constant
objects
let's write another piece of code for
const keyword
so let's declare a
variable const
x
is equal to
5.
comma y is equal to
7 let's say once
so here what we have done we declared a
variable x and a variable y with value
as 5 and 7 we declared this time with
const keyword and variable z which is x
plus y
we printed z on the browser and it shows
the value as 12 which is x plus y 7 plus
5 is equal to 12 now what we will do
const will let you do this but if you
try to update the value of x let's
suppose we try to
update the value of x as x equals to x
plus 10.
will print
x this time
document.write
x let's save this it will throw an error
assignment to a constant variable in
line 24. so here you want to update the
value of x you can't do this with const
keyword you can do this with let and
where as well but you can't do this with
const
also const won't allow you to re-declare
any variable just like let so if you try
to use const x again
is equal to 10 save it
so here it says identifier x has already
been declared this thing you can do with
cons the scope of const is the same as
let it can be used within the block
where it is declared data types is an
essential concept in every programming
language to work on any variable you
should know its type it refers to the
kind of data which is being stored
inside a variable
the type of variable is holding
basically
every programming language has its own
set of data types which is unique in its
own way we discussed earlier that
javascript is a lightweight scripting
language
because we don't need to specify any
data type in javascript after all all
the variables in javascript are loosely
packed or we can say javascript is a
dynamically typed scripting language we
shall discuss these properties later in
this video for now let me tell you about
different data types present in
javascript
so javascript data types are divided
into two categories primitive data types
and non-primitive data types primitive
data types are stored in stack whereas
non-primitive data types they are stored
in heap
i don't want you to go deep in these two
terms as if you are new to programming
so we'll leave it just keep one thing in
mind that primitive data types are base
data types whereas non-primitive data
types are objects or we can say they are
derived
primitive data types they are further
divided into five categories they are
divided as numbers strings boolean
undefined null non-primitive data types
or complex data types we can say on the
other hand they are divided into two
parts arrays and objects we'll have
separate videos on these topics for now
let's discuss primitive data types to
understand primitive data types much
better
let's declare a few variable here
let's say we declare where x and give it
the value as 16
we'll declare where y
and we'll give it value
hello wool we'll declare one more let's
say where
flag
and the value will be true
here we can talk about those properties
of javascript which i mentioned earlier
javascript variables are loosely packed
and javascript is a dynamically typed
scripting language these two points
refers to the same thing here you can
see we have defined three variables x we
have defined variable x we have defined
variable y and flag as well the values
for all three variables is different
from one another
see variable x is holding a value that
is 16 variable y
is holding a value hello world which is
a string so 16 is a number hello world
is a string
and variable flag is holding a value
that refers to a boolean value in place
of true we can also write false here
so
what's happening here here you can see
there is no data type if you are coming
from a c plus background or a java
background
this will be a little bit weird for you
guys because in c plus plus and java we
used to do it like we will define an
integer let let me show you
so how we will define integer in c plus
plus or what we'll say will use int x
equals to 5
or something like that we already had a
data type for string as well we have
carrying c plus but here in javascript
we have no data type we are only using
the where keyword that's what we call as
loosely typed
this line means that you don't have to
define the data type of the variable
what happens in javascript is whatever
the type of value you will pass to the
variable the data type will change
accordingly
so you don't need to worry about if you
are passing a number or if you are
passing in string
just relax just when you pass the value
to the variable it will be determined
automatically so these are the three
basic primitive data types present in
javascript which are number
boolean value and string
so let's move on to the next one which
is undefined we'll define a variable p
and will leave it as it is so this
variable p has an undefined data type it
means that
any variable which is already declared
but has no value inside it it has an
undefined data type
i i'll tell you a basic operator the
type of operator
will go through the operators in later
videos but just try to understand the
basic need and use it with me for now
this operator will help you know the
type of value a variable is holding see
let's use it here we have declared a
variable p
will check the type of p
so to use this operator you have to use
it with document dot right now
so we'll do document.write and we'll use
two brackets
and inside it we'll write
type of and whatever like we want to
know the type of variable x let's
suppose we'll write here x
semicolon save it and you can see here
it says number this means that this
variable has a value which is a number
similarly we will check for all the
variables present here we'll check for
every variable we'll check for y will
check for flag and we'll check for p as
well let's copy this and
paste it three time and let's change the
value here
from x to y in this line
and room x2 flag here
and here we'll change it to p
so we have done it we'll save it and see
here it says number first variable y it
says it's a string because you know
hello world is a string it's a sequence
of character
for
variable flag it says boolean so it's
defined as true or false and
for variable p it's written here
undefined with this we are left with
only one primitive data type the null
data type there is a difference between
a null value and an undefined value
undefined means lack of value whereas
null means the absence of any value
suppose you are using null as the value
for any variable the type of operator
will return this variable as an object
but if you are not giving any value to
this variable you are leaving it after
declaration the type of operator will
return undefined here is an example for
this c
we'll declare one more variable here
we'll declare where
num let's name this variable num and we
will give it the value as null
we'll use document.write type of and we
will check with the help of type of
operator that what type of value the
variable num is holding
so let's give here
num
we are good to go press control plus s
and c
here it says it's an object
so a null value will always be shown as
an object
we'll talk about the complex types or
composite types in further videos we'll
have separate videos for each of these
types in any programming language an
operator is a symbol that makes the
computer understand that it needs to do
some specific task
like if we want to perform an addition
between two numbers let's say we want to
perform addition between four and five
so guys
if you see the plus sign here this is
known as the operator and the two terms
which are four and five these two
numbers these are known as the operands
we have different operators for
different purposes like we have plus for
addition we have minus for subtraction
we have star or asterisk we can say for
multiplication and many more other
operators as well
so there are many more operators present
in almost every programming language
which is present out there like it
operators are present in java they are
present in c plus in c almost every
programming language out there has the
concept of operators it's essential for
you to know how and where to use any
operator despite of the language you are
working on one needs to understand which
operators are available right
so in this particular video i'll take
you through the basic types of operator
present in javascript i'll let you know
the types and we'll learn about how to
use them and of course i'll take you
through the different categories of
operators present in javascript so in
javascript there are basically eight
categories into which operators are
divided which are we have arithmetic
operators we have assignment we have
string we have conditional we have
logical bitwise comparison and type of
operator
we'll discuss the first three types in
this video that is we'll discuss the
arithmetic operators we'll discuss the
assignment and the string operators
rest we'll talk about in the following
video
first up here is the arithmetic operator
hope you all are aware of the term
arithmetic
right
so
arithmetic operators perform
mathematical calculations like it
performs addition subtraction
multiplication and division as well
so here are the few operators you can
see on your screen the plus operator
minus asterisk division we have modulus
we have increments we have decrement so
these are the basic arithmetic operator
we'll see each of these operator with an
example so let's move on to the
programming part first so guys i want to
mention one more thing here i want all
of you to make a separate file for each
topic we'll be covering from now on like
for operators we'll create a separate
file we'll create a separate one for
control statements and other topics will
cover in future from today so i want you
to create a separate file because you
know in future if you want to access
these topics it will be easy for you to
access those files instead if you are
using a single file for all the topics
it will be
quite confusing so let's start with the
arithmetic operators first let's take
two variables we are in the javascript
file let's take two variables let's say
where
x equals to 6
and we'll take another variable let's
say where y equals to
4.
now we'll perform some arithmetic
operations on these two variables we
have already seen the arithmetic
operators present like we have plus
minus we have increment decrement we
have multiplication division so we'll go
through all of these right so let's
start with it here we are done with our
basic three operators which is addition
subtraction and multiplication i have
commented the division because i have
something to tell you about the division
so let's check the output here first
let's save it and see the output is
addition 10 subtraction 2 and
multiplication 24. for addition it added
the two numbers it's six plus four
similarly for subtraction and
multiplication it is six minus four and
at six multiplied by four
for division i have left division
because i hope you guys know the
difference between division and the
modulus operator let's try to use the
modulus operator along with the division
so what we'll do will come in these
three and let's remove it from here and
what we'll do we'll
paste this here and we'll use the
modulus here so now let's check the
output what it says for division and
modulus
see
we have divided 6 by 4
division it says it's 1.5
6 divided by 4 that is 1.5 it will show
the quotient here for modulus it's
saying 2 because
in modulus it gives you the remainder
and in
division it gives you the quotient as
the answer so keep this thing in mind
guys keep this in mind always take a
note of it so we are done with division
and modulus next up we have the
increment and the decrement operators
let me show them to you real quick
so what we'll do we'll declare another
variable let's say where z equals to 5
and
we'll use the increment operator here
we'll use again document.write
and here we'll let's say we write
increment how to use increment operator
for increment operator you have to use
plus
plus whatever variable you have used so
we'll use plus plus z
and similarly we'll copy this
paste it here and here we'll use
minus minus for decrement
and change here as well
so let's see what happens
let me give some space in between them
so that you won't get confused
let's save it and check the output here
increment is it says 6 and decrement it
is 5.
so you can see here the functioning of
decrement and increment operator the
increment operator will increase the
value of z by 1 and the decrement
operator will do the opposite of this
it'll decrease the value by 1. so we are
done with the arithmetic operators next
up we have the assignment operators
assignment operators are used to assign
values to different javascript variables
let's see the types first and then we'll
see how to use them so we have these
assignment operators here here we have
equals to plus equals to minus equals 2
and we have
multiplied equals 2 we have divided
equals two modulus equals two and a few
more
so let's see each of them with example
maybe not each of them but we'll try to
cover almost every
single operator out there which is
present in your screen so let's move on
and see let's move on to the programming
part so here we are guys let's declare a
few variables let's say we are declaring
a variable a
and we are giving it the value as 10
suppose
and we'll declare another one let's say
where b and give it the value
5
so for assignment operators what
assignment operator
mean
we have used here the equal to sign
right we have used a equals to 10. this
means whatever value present on the
right side of the operator like here it
is 10 it will be assigned to the
variable a
i hope you guys are getting this keep
this in mind
so we have the value 10 and we are
assigning this value to the variable a
it says let's try to check the output of
a let's try to print a on the screen
okay
document
see here you can see that the value of a
it says 10
and similarly the value of b is 5 so
let's do one more thing we will assign
the value of a to b how to do this
let's change the value here only
let's suppose we are using the value of
where a s 13
okay and the value of where b will be
providing as let's say a
so
now let's try to print the value of b
here we will change
will print the value of b only
let's save it and see the output see it
says the value of b is 13
because we have assigned b the value
present at variable a which is 13 that's
why it is showing the value of b as 13.
this is what assignment operator is
let's try other assignment operators as
well
let's take another variable
so let's say where
even
equals to let's say 51
so the next operator we will be using is
let's update the value of a1 first so
how to do this let's say a1 equals to
no it's a 1 plus equals to 9
and
we'll print the value
let's check the output now
see it says the value of a1 is 60. here
we have given that a1 plus equals to 9.
see a 1 plus equals to 9 is the same as
if you don't want to write here a 1 plus
equals to 9 you can also write it as a 1
equals to
a 1
plus 9
both of these lines are same both these
statements means the same they are
performing the same task
so a 1 equals to a 1 plus 9 is same as a
1 plus equals to 9.
that's what i want you to understand
with assignment operators
similarly if you want to perform a1
minus equals to you can do it as well
so let's say a1 minus is equal to 5 and
we'll copy this line from here paste it
here again and save it now let's see the
output here what it says some of you
guys may get confused that here it shows
the value of 6 is 69 of a1 so in the
first statement when we tried to print a
1 here the initial value was 51 then
this statement was performed and the
value was updated to 60. then after that
one more statement this statement is
also performed and the value updated to
69 it's 51 plus 9 plus 9 and the value
we have here is 69 now what happens if
we are using the minus equals 2 operator
what it will do it will
decrease the value of a 1 by 5 it means
that
a 1 equals to a 1 minus 5 the value of
a1 is 69 and it will subtract 5 from 69
so here it says the value of a1 is 64.
hope you guys are getting this
so we have so many operators we have so
many of them like let's try a few more
so we have multiply equals to we have
division equals to we have modulus
equals to so i'll write these and then
we'll see the output
so we are done with it let's check the
output here for a3 a4 and a5 you can see
for a3 we have used multiply equals to
for a4 we have used divide equals to and
for a5 we have used modulus equals two
let's check the output here
save it and see
it says the value of a3 50
it here we have taken a3s5 it's 10 into
5 because a3 equals to a3 into 5 so it's
10 into 5 it shows the value as 50.
similarly
here it says the value of a4 is 3.75
because we have used here 4. so instead
of 4 let's try to use 3 and save it see
here you can see it divides it and gives
you the quotient and the value of a4
divided by 3 is 5.
so
similarly for a5 it shows the value of
a5 is 6. because we have used the
modulus operator here and 20 divided by
7 we have 6 as remainder
so
i hope you guys are pretty clear with
assignment operators now next up we have
string operators the plus operator which
we used as the arithmetic operators
earlier right it also operates as a
string operator so we can use it to
concatenate two strings that mean we can
add two strings as well in javascript it
is possible with the help of string
operator similarly we have plus equals
to operator for strings as well like we
have plus equal to for assignment it has
the same functioning for string as well
let's take the example for these two
operators let's move on to the
programming part so here you can see we
have two variables where str1 and where
str2 the value of where str1 is hello
and the value of where str2 is world so
what we'll do we will add str1 and str2
so let's check the output here save it
and see here you can see the output as
hello world
but there is no space between hello and
world keep this point in mind guys so if
you are adding two strings just like
this there will be no space between the
two string so if you want to add any
space between these two what you have to
do you have to mention it here
separately
and this this is the syntax if you want
to add space between your strings
so now let's save it now and see here
you can see there is a space between
hello and world
so this is the use of plus operator in
strings so the next one we have plus
equals to let's take another string
let's take it as whereas tr3 and we'll
give it the value as
welcome
so what we'll do
we'll use the plus equal to operator
here str3 plus equals to
let's say
to
simply code
and
what we'll do we'll print the value of
str3 here
so save it now
so here you can see the value of str3 if
we remove this this line
let's see what happens now
and we'll give it a space here
save it now
see here you can see it says hello world
for the first str1 plus str2 it says
hello world
for str3 it says welcome to simply code
see here the space is already given so
it will show this in the output but
between welcome and two if you want to
add space you have to
do the same what you have done for str1
and str2 so let's do it here on as well
plus sign yes
save it now and see here you can see
it says welcome to simply code with
proper space now we will cover the rest
of the operators now we are left with
five more these are the first three
operators now we are left with
conditional operators
logical operators we have bitwise
operator and we have comparison and
finally we have the type of operator
so these are the five operators we are
going to cover today
before we start with the operators let
us first discuss associativity talking
about associativity
it refers to the direction in which the
entire expression is evaluated for
example if you have any expression let's
say you have a plus b
so the direction in which this
expression will be evaluated either it
will be from left to right or from right
to left so this is known as
associativity let's understand it with
the help of an example
so here you can see i have taken three
variables i have taken variable a
and i have assigned it value as 12 i
have taken variable b
and the value assigned to b is 8 and
finally i have a variable result which
stores the value of a plus b
lastly what i am doing is i am printing
out the result variable inside the h1
tag here you can see i have used the h1
tags
and
i have used the plus operator to
concatenate the strings right i have
concatenated these two strings along
with the result along with the answer of
result
so the plus operator here is doing two
different tasks right
here you can see it is performing the
addition of two numbers right and here
you can see it is used to concatenate
two strings so now let's talk about
associativity because i guess you guys
are clear with string operator till now
we have discussed them in the previous
video right so let's talk about
associativity now so certain operators
have right to left associativity and
certain operators have left to right
associativity
so when i say right to left
associativity in this case the value
present at the right side of the
operator see if you are using any
operator for example here you we have
used the assignment operator right we
have discussed the assignment operator
earlier so here you can see the value
present at the right hand side of the
operator will be assigned to the
variable which is present at the left
hand side of the operator so
it's going this way like first the
computer will check the for the value
present at the right it's going from
right towards the left this is what we
are known as right to left associativity
and assignment operators like equals to
this have right to left associativity
let's add here one more variable let's
say we are adding a variable variable c
and we are giving it the value as
5 and what we will do we will update
result as well let me first show you the
output of this particular program see
the output will be value of result is 20
and high there high there is
concatenated with
the string value of result is and 20 is
the actual answer the 20 is the value of
result
so let's add one more variable here
let's say we are adding a variable c and
the value of c will be 5
what we'll do now we will update result
as well here you can see i have done a
plus b plus c
so
save it and
here you can see the value updated
to 25 the value of result is updated
right
so the plus operator has associativity
from left to right till now we have
talked about right to left as for
assignment operators but for plus
operators the associativity is from left
to right it means it will first perform
a plus b
and then the value of c will be added to
that of a plus b first it will perform
12 plus 8 and then finally it will add 5
to that value so it will be 20 plus 5
and that's why the output here is 25 we
know that javascript is a loosely typed
programming language right
which means that we don't have to
specify data types every time
like we are using if we are using any
data type we don't need to specify it
every time like
let's do one thing let's add a string
here so what we'll do we'll add a string
let's suppose i'm adding hello
so practically the answer would be hello
plus
25 or hello 25 it should be the answer
but let's check the output now save it
and here you can see the output is hello
one two eight five what happened here is
the associativity of the plus operator
is from left to right we know this so it
will start from the left and it will see
that okay the first thing to add is a
string so it will assume that everything
ahead of this will be a string that's
why we have the output as hello
12 8 and 5 so 12 8 and 5 all are acting
as string here
let me clear this one for you with a
little bit of modification now what
we'll do
we'll
remove this string from here and we'll
add it somewhere else let's say we are
adding it here
so
let's add one more variable to make it
more clear let's say we are using
variable d and the value will be 10
and what we'll do we'll perform a plus b
before the string and then we'll perform
c plus d
right
so here you can see when you save it
it says 20 hello 510 so when it reached
out the first variable it finds out that
the first variable is a number so it
added the first two numbers right it
added 12 and 8 the answer is 20 then it
came across this string hello and then
finally assume that everything ahead of
this will be a string so that's the
output 20 is the addition of a plus b
and then the string hello and finally we
have the value of c and d as string so
we have the value 5 and 10 not 15 right
i hope you guys get this
so
let's move on to conditional operators
the conditional operators assign a value
to a variable based on a certain
condition like it contains a condition
and you know for every condition like
there exists only two possibilities
either it can be true or it can be false
there is nothing else you can do with a
conditional operator so it works the
same as if else statements which we'll
cover in further videos the only
difference between if else and
conditional operators that it takes less
time or we can say its usage is pretty
easy
so here is the syntax for conditional
operators
so it seems pretty straight forward
right so here you can see we have a
variable name we have a condition
depending upon the condition we have two
values
here's the example as well
c
you can see we have a variable voter
next up we have a condition if age is
less than 18 so it will check for the
condition that if the value of age is
actually less than 18 let's suppose the
value of age is 15 so it will check if
15 is less than 18 it's true then it
will print 2m or if the value of h is
greater than 18 then it will print false
or you can say it will print old enough
here
so let's move on to the programming part
so here you can see i have taken a
variable x and the value assigned to x
is 30. what we'll do in variable y i
have given it a condition so it will
check for x which is 30 if 30 is greater
than or equals to 50
so if it's true if 30 is actually
greater than 50 then it will print true
else it will print false
so we'll check the output once let's
save it and see here you can see the
output as false so if you update the
value of axial let's suppose we are
updating the value of x let's suppose
it's
60 save it now and see the output has
changed to true because 60 is greater
than 50 right
also if you want to write a message here
only you can do it write it here as
so we'll copy it from here we'll copy
document.right and we'll paste it here
just remove this
document.right and we what we'll do
we'll
use this bracket
here
and if any message you want to write
like you want to write
value of
so
and now what we'll do will
save it
see it says value of true
so
or you can write any other message here
as well you can write value of x is
greater than or you can write whatever
so if you want to update it like value
is
and here we will update true
with
greater
and here we will use
smaller
save it now
see here it says value is greater value
of x is greater than y
so that's all for conditional operators
also one more thing and conditional
operators has three different parts
right
and that's why it is also known as
ternary operator three different parts
as in it has a
condition like here it is it's okay it
has a condition and it has two values
right it has true or false so that's why
it is also known as ternary operator
next up we have the logical operators
so logical operators are used to
determine the logic between two
variables
or values we can say
we use logical operators to check
whether multiple conditions are true or
false
here on your screen you can see the
three different types of logical
operators present in javascript along
with the syntax and example
so the end or not are the three
operators present in javascript
the and operator here you can see
it it is holding two values right it
it has x less than 10 and y greater than
one
so the end operator will return true
only if both the conditions are true
like x has to be less than 10 and y has
to be
greater than 1 so here you can see we
have taken x equals to 7 and y equals to
4. so both the conditions are satisfying
here so that's why
the output of the end operator will be
true
for our operator the case is a bit
different so if any one of these two
conditions like we have two conditions
if any one of these two is true then the
output will be true and if both are
false then only the output will be false
the north operator on the other hand
will check if x is equals to y if the
value x is holding is equals to that of
y if the value is not equal then it will
return true
i hope you are getting this that's a
little bit
confusing but if the value x and y
holding
if they are not equal then it will
return true if they are equal then it
will return false
right
we will understand the programming
concept of logical operators in further
videos when we learn about control
statements we primarily use logical
operators with the if statement through
which we'll come across in the following
video in the next video we will go
through the control statements so we'll
understand the programming part of
logical operator there only
next up we have the comparison operators
so comparison operators are similar to
logical operators in some way
they are also used to check for true and
false as the name suggests we use
comparison operator to compare two
values or we can say to compare two
variables using different operators
so here you can see on your screen
these are the different types of
comparison operators present in
javascript we have equals 2 we have not
equals 2 we have equal value and data
type we have greater than less than and
we have a few more so
i hope you guys must remember from the
previous video that a single equals 2
operator is an assignment operator so if
we are using a single equals 2 then it
will be considered as an assignment
operator for comparison we have to use
double equal to keep this thing in mind
whenever you are using any operator in
javascript or especially the equals two
operator so if you want to compare two
values you have to use double equals two
because single equals two is used to
assign values this is an assignment
operator so let's move on to the
programming part now
so guys here you can see i have taken a
variable x and the value assigned to x
is 10.
this code seems a little bit longer to
you but that's a simple piece of code
like i have used almost every comparison
operator we came across in the previous
slide i have used each one of them and i
have used the document.write after every
comparison operator to put some spaces
in between so that you guys don't
confuse between them
so let's check the output now see as you
can see i have used the double equals to
the triple equals to i've used x not
equals to it so let's check the output
save it and see here it says false false
true true true false true false
so for x equals to equals to it it
compared the value 10 with 8
and 10 and 8 are not equals to so the
output will be false as similar for 10
and we have used the triple equals 2
operator which means equal value and
data type so
both 10 and 8 have equal data type they
both have the same data type that is
number but the values are different
so it will print false
for x not equals to it it says 10 is not
equals to it yeah 10 is not equals to it
actually so it will print true similarly
for x
not equals to equals to it it will check
that
both the values are not equal but the
data types are equal right so it will
print true for this as well
for x greater than 8 yeah 10 is greater
than 8 so it will print true
similarly for it will check for x
smaller than 8 and it will check for x
greater than equals to it and also for x
less than equals to it
so
by now you have understood how
comparison operators work so comparison
operators are the easiest to use in
programming
and that's all for comparison operators
let's move on to the next one we have
the next type of operator we have is the
type of operator you guys have an idea
about the type of operators right
as we have discussed it earlier in case
you haven't watched the previous videos
let me give you a brief introduction
about this type of operator
so the type of operator is used to
provide you with the type of whatever
value you
put to the right of it like
if you are using any data type and you
want to know about the data type of a
particular variable let's say so you can
use the type of operator it will tell
you the actual data type of any variable
so
in javascript as we have discussed
earlier in the video where we have
particularly discussed about the data
types so there are five different types
of primitive data types right we have
the numbers we have strings we have
boolean we have null and undefined
so let's try to use type of operator
so here you can see i have used four
different variables which are i've used
variable x
variable y
and variable flag and variable p so the
values are different the x is holding 17
y is holding hey there and flag has the
value as false and i have defined p but
i have not assigned it any value till
now
so what i'll do i have used the type of
operator to find out the type of every
variable like here i have used it for x
for y for flag and for p
let's
check the output now
save it and see it says number string
boolean and undefined
see here we have given x the value as 17
so 17 is a number then it says it is a
number for hey there it says it is a
string for false it says it is a boolean
value like
in boolean value we have only two values
like false and true
so for variable p it says undefined
you know there is a difference between
undefined and null data types undefined
means lack of value whereas null means
this absence of value that there is no
value at all
so suppose you are using null as the
value for any variable right the type of
operator will return
object
but if you are not giving any value to
any variable like you are using the
variable as it is like here we have not
given it any value so if you are doing
this the type of operator will return
undefined so let's take an example of
null as well
let's declare another variable let's say
where
abc
and we'll give it the value as
null
so and finally what we'll do we'll
use type of operator
save it and see here it says the type of
variable abc is an object
so remember this thing guys
and now we are done with almost seven
operators we had and we are left with
one operator only
so let's move on to our last operator
which is the bitwise operator this
operator doesn't have that much of
practical usage in the real world they
are not definitely useless but this is
something like we are not going to use
on a daily basis so in computers
if you know the numbers are stored in
binary format
bitwise operators work on 32-bit numbers
and we have decimal numbers like we
understand decimal numbers computer
works on binary numbers right so when
bitwise operators are used any operand
present in the operation
is first converted to a binary number
and then converted back to a javascript
number
so
here you can see on your screen
we have four different
bitwise operators we have the and
operator we have or we have not and we
have zor or we can say exclusive or
the result and the answers are also here
it's pretty simple see
we have used the and operator before as
well while we were in logical operators
but the syntax was different and
here you can see we have a single
ampersand sign to use bitwise and
operator
so here you can see
how the decimal number first changes to
a binary number suppose we have x as 5
here you can see x is first changed to a
binary number this is the binary
equivalent of 5 and 1 is also changed to
a binary number and finally the result
whatever result we get it is changed to
a decimal number so that's how bitwise
operators work
let's take an example of bitwise
operators
so here you can see i have taken two
variables i have taken variable x and
the value of variable x is five and
another variable is y and the value of y
is one and then i have used
all the four bitwise operators like i've
used x and y i have used x or y i have
used not x and i have used the xor
operator between x and y so let's check
the output now
here you can see
if we talk about the output
see here it says 1 5 minus 6 and 4 so
for x and y see
the value of x is 0 1 0 1 and for end
operators
it will return 1 if both the values r1
if any one of the two values are zero
then it will return zero so what it will
return here it will return zero for zero
zero for one zero it will also return
zero similarly for zero zero it will
also return zero and for one month it
will return one
which is the binary equivalent of one so
the answer here is one
for x or y it will return one if any one
of the two values are one
see if both are zero it will return zero
if any one of the two values is one it
will return one
it will return zero again and finally it
has two ones so it will return one
and zero one zero one is the binary
equivalent of 5 that's why the output
here is 5.
for not operator it works a little bit
different it gives you the output which
is same as minus x minus 1 so minus x
minus 1 will be
see minus x minus 1 will be minus 5
minus 1 which is minus 6 so this is a
bit different here the not operator here
is a bit different
for
xor operator or we can say exclusive or
it will return 4
why it will return 4 it will return 1
when any one of the 2 values is 1 if
both are 1 then also it will return
false it will return one only in one
condition if any one of the two values
is one then only it will return one
that's why the output here
the output here will be zero one zero
zero that's why it's written as four
which is the binary equivalent of 0 1 0
0. the term control statement is pretty
self-explanatory and straightforward
right we came across javascript
statements in previous videos javascript
statements are the instructions that
tells the browser to perform specific
actions
control statements are also instructions
and they govern the flow of control in a
program
so let's take a look at control
statements with the help of an example
let's suppose we have a piece of code
that has n number of statements here
let's say we have this code and so the
conventional workflow will be it will
first execute the first statement then
second then third and so on till
statement n right
so this is the basic flow right from
statement one till statement n and it
will execute each statement in between
however in real world the scenario is
different
like we don't write the code in same
menu every time
for example let's suppose
you are in line 5
and you want to print this line 10 times
so what should you do you can write this
line 10 times or
you can copy paste it right okay let's
forget about 10 times let's suppose you
have to use this
code or we can say let's suppose you
have to print this statement 100 times
doing
this like copy pasting it for 100 times
or writing this statement 400 times
that's useless and unnecessary right so
that's where control statements comes
into picture
we'll discuss them in a while let's
assume another situation
this time you want to make a choice
based on certain conditions you can use
conditional operators but then it has
limitations right to tackle this problem
we have control statements in javascript
so these are the very basic reasons why
we need control statements for
performing a certain activity like if we
want to perform a certain activity n
number of times or if you want to make a
certain decision-making kind of
scenarios in your program that's where
we need control statements in javascript
in javascript we have two different
types of control statements depending
upon what action we are performing so we
have the conditional control statements
and we have the iterative or
we can say
looping control statements
talking about conditional statements as
the name suggests
we use conditional statements when we
have to make decisions based on
conditions when we have two choices or
when we can say when we have two
different conditions and we want to make
choices accordingly so that's where we
use conditional statements we have two
different types of conditional
statements the if else statements and
the switch case
talking about the iterative statements
as the name suggests if you want to
perform any action more than once or
maybe number of times instead of writing
them again and again
we use loops so loops are basically
statements
we use loops to perform any activity n
number of times with
specific conditions so in javascript we
have four different type of loops we
have for loop while loop do while loop
and foreign loop
so the for loop while loop and do while
loop you might have heard about them
earlier because they are also present in
other programming languages
but this foreign loop this is a new type
of loop present in javascript we use
foreign loop with objects we'll go
through objects in
upcoming videos and of course we'll be
looking at each of these control
statements in detail
we'll have a particular video for each
of these topic
now let me introduce to you the break
and the continue statement
they are not the types of control
statements but they do assist in other
control statements
the break is used to exit a switch
statement or loop like when used in a
loop
it breaks the loop and continues
executing the code after it
and
on the other hand the continue statement
breaks a single iteration when used in a
loop when we use continuous statement in
a loop it breaks a single iteration and
it breaks the iteration only if the
specified condition occurs and then it
will continue with the next titration in
the loop so the if else conditional
statement is used whenever we work with
condition
it can be either a single condition
or maybe more than one condition or
multiple conditions we can work with
so let's try to write a basic
program with a single condition
so then we'll
move on to multiple conditions using the
elsif statement so we'll create a new
file today so i hope you guys know the
importance of creating a separate file
for every topic you know it will be easy
for you to work or to find out that
separate file later if you want to
revise that topic
so here is the program where we have
taken a variable x
and the value of x is 10 so what we are
doing in this program is we are checking
if the value the variable x is holding
that is the value 10
and if the value is less than
10 or if the value is
greater than 10 so we have only two
conditions either the value can be less
than 10 or the value can be greater than
10 or equals to 10 as
so here in this program what we'll do
will
first we'll update this value as 8 so
the variable x is holding the value 8
so to check the output let's save it and
here you can see it says the value of x
is less than 10 of course the value 8 is
always less than 10 right so
for 8 that's fine it will say the value
is less than 10 and similarly if we do
the same for let's say 11 save it now
and see it says the value of x is
greater than 10
so that's quite simple right but what if
we are giving the value as 10
we know 10 is equals to 10 so save it
now and see here you can see
it says the value of x is greater than
10.
this is happening because what we did we
as we told the interpreter to check the
value if the value of x is less than 10.
we didn't mention that if what to do if
the value is equals to 10 so it will
check for only x is less than 10 not for
equals to 10 or greater than 10
so here what it is doing it is checking
if the value is less than 10
so that it says okay let's print this
statement if the value is less than 10
or
if the value is not less than 10 or if
the value is equals to or greater than
10 it will print the value of x is
greater than 10.
to avoid this type of misunderstanding
we use an elsif statement so the concept
of elsif statement is the same as if
statement what we are doing we are using
multiple conditions right we are giving
it more than one condition so how to use
elsif it's quite easy
and the syntax is also similar to
the if statement the only difference is
that it contains an else before if so
it's an elsif so what we are doing is
we are giving it a condition that else
if x equals to 10.
so now what it will do it will check for
two conditions that if the value x is
holding is less than 10 or equals to 10
and what we'll do is update it as
let's check the output now
save and see here it says the value of x
is equals to 10 right so i hope you guys
are getting this
the execution flow for this program will
be like it will check for the first
condition if x is less than 10 if yes it
will print the value of x is less than
10. if no it will move on the to the
following condition like under the else
if statement it finds a condition that
if x is equals to 10 it will check for
it if yes if x is equals to 10 then it
will print the value of x is equals to
10
or if not then otherwise it will move to
else statement and print the value of x
is greater than 10. we don't need to
specify any particular condition for
this you know because we have already
specified the two conditions that
if x is less than 10 or if x is equals
to 10 now we'll take a look at some
basic programs other than this one will
take a look at a few more basic programs
so here is the another program
what we are doing here is we are taking
a variable x and the value of x is 5
so what we are doing is we are checking
if the number is an even number or an
odd number
thing you have to keep in mind is the
logic to find whether a number is even
or an odd number so to check uh whether
a number is even you what we do we'll
divide that number with 2 right but
basically we want is we want
the remainder as 0 when we use the
modulus operator so what we'll do here
we have written x mod 2 equals to equals
to 0 so if the remainder is 0
then the number will be an even number
because it is divisible by 2. else it
will be an odd number so that's quite
simple right let's save it and check the
output for 5 it says odd number yeah 5
is of course an odd number right so
that's for even an odd number
so here we are with another program here
it says we have a variable y and the
value of y is
let's say
8
and
what we are doing here is we are
checking if a number is positive or
negative or zero so we have three
different conditions either number can
be positive or it can be a negative
number any number greater than 0 is a
positive number right and any number
less than 0 is a negative number and the
third one is
a number 0 it's neither positive nor
negative
so let's check for the number eight save
it and see here you can see it is a
positive number let's see for
minus two save it now it says a negative
number for zero it will say zero
so these two programs are quite simple
guys right the conditions are pretty
simple we use
modulus operator we used greater than or
less than sign and
that's quite easy to use right so let's
move on to the next program which is a
bit tricky than these two
so what we'll do in our next program is
we'll check if a number is positive or
negative
and at the same time we'll check for
even and odd also
if we are giving any number as input
like let's suppose we are using 5 we'll
check if the number is positive or
negative and odd or even so we'll do
this simultaneously let's move on to
this program so there are two ways to
check whether the number is
positive or negative and
order even
so the two methods we'll discuss them
one by one the first one here is
to use nested if and another one is when
we use logical operators along with the
if else if statement
so this one here you can see right in
front of your screen is
the
nested if method so here you can see we
have used the if statement we have given
one more condition inside another if
statement so first it will check whether
a number is positive
or not for x greater than 0 it will
check if the number x is greater than 0
then if yes if it will find it that yes
this number is greater than 0 then it
will move on to the
nested if and it will check for odd or
even
for odd number and even number it will
check if it finds that the number is
even it will print that the number
is positive and even
if the number is not even it will print
the number is positive and odd
so
here you can see the difference what the
interpreter is doing is it will check
for the number as positive and if the
number is positive then it will move on
to the nested if and check for the even
or odd so if it finds that the number is
even it will print positive and even
otherwise it will print positive and odd
then it will move on to the next
condition which is for negative number
if x is less than 0 then it will again
move to the nested if and it will check
for even and odd
so if it finds that the number is even
it will print negative and even
otherwise it will print negative and odd
and the last condition is for the number
0
let's
try to find out the output of this and
what we'll do we'll update the value of
x as
8
so save it now here it says then
positive and even so 8 is a positive
number and even as well
let's update the value of x as minus
5
save it now it says negative and odd
number minus 5 is a negative odd number
right so that's how it will check for
positive
or negative and odd or even so we are
doing both the things simultaneously in
a program we have an alternate method as
well here you can see on your screen we
have written a program and here we have
taken a variable x the functioning of
both the programs is same
both of these program will check for
positive or negative and
order even
so here you can see i have taken a
variable x let's say the value of x is
7
it will check for
x greater than 0 and x
mod 2 is equals to equals to 0 so we
have 4 different conditions right a
number is
greater than 0 that means a number is
positive and even a number is positive
and odd a number is negative and even a
number is negative and odd and the final
one is a number is zero
okay we have five conditions and we have
to specify these four conditions
so here you can see we are using the
logical and operator this means it will
print this statement let's suppose for
this statement it will print this only
if both the conditions are true
right if the number if the value x is
holding is both greater than 0 and an
even number
so if you try to
find out the output now save it and see
here it says number is positive and odd
so the number 7 is greater than 0
but the number 7 is not an even number
that's why this line is not there on the
browser it will print this line because
the number is
positive and odd the switch case is
another conditional control statement
and just like the if else control
statement there is a difference between
the usage of if else and switch case
statement
now both if else and switch case works
with conditions and we have to choose
when to use switch case
over if else switch case is generally
preferred over the if else when there is
n number of test cases present or we can
say when we are working with a lot of
conditions let's say we are working on a
program and you ask the user for
an input between 50 and 100 a numeric
input basically and in the output we
have to print the textual form of that
number suppose if the user enters 75
right the output will be like this
so what we are doing we we are taking a
number from the user as an input and we
are printing the textual form of that
number right
so we can use the if else
or we can say elsif control statement
but the program will be so lengthy and
not so clean
also switch case is much more efficient
than if else when it comes to execution
time like if we have a number of
conditions then using switch case is a
better option
we'll get to know why in a bit so let's
move on to the programming part and
today
we'll write a program where we have to
find the month in a year by accepting
its number
so we have 12 months in a year for
example if we enter 4 then the output
will be april and if we enter 8 then the
output will be august because august is
the 8th month of the year right so i
hope you guys are clear with the
question of course we can do this
program with the help of if else
statement but we discussed earlier that
using if else in such cases is not
efficient right we can use switch case
in this scenario so let's create a
variable first let's say we are creating
a variable where month and
you can
give any value to this variable from 1
to 12 you can provide it with any
initial value
so let's create a variable first let's
say we are creating a variable where
month
and
the value we are providing it one as the
hardcore initial value for simplicity
again we are not taking the input from
the user or from the browser to do so we
have to first go through the dom
manipulations and we'll go through it in
later videos so let's start with the
switch case now
the syntax for switch case is quite
simple just write down
switch and
pass the variable month
so we have to check in this round
bracket for the variable month because
you know any value you are providing to
month the switch will check the program
accordingly so for now we have taken the
value as 1 for month we can take any
value like we can take 3 we can take 11
12 or any value other than 1 to 12 as
well so whatever value you are providing
to the variable you can provide the
variable to the switch statement right
so
next up we have an open and curly braces
for the body of the switch case we have
to test for 12 different conditions
inside this
starting from 1 to 12 right so the
syntax goes like this you have to write
case
and then the value
month variable might hold like 1 2 3 and
so on followed by a colon right so we
have to write the value 1 and
a colon not a semicolon but a colon keep
this thing in mind guys
and below that we are going to write
what we want when the value is one like
what the output we want when the value
is one so we have to write
document
dot write
and
whatever you want as the output like for
one the first month is january so we are
writing here
january
and a semicolon
so if the value of the month is 1 you
will get the output as january save it
and here you can see the output is
january
let me increase the font size for this
as well
so here you can see the output is
january right next we'll use a break
statement
if you guys remember we discussed the
break statement in the control
statements video right the break
statement is not actually a type of
control statement but it assists other
control statements or we can say it
helps us manage the control statements
right what this statement does is
once we are done with our output we get
our output right once we are done with
case 1 we get our output as january this
break statement helps us to come out of
the switch case so to understand this
much better let's write here one more
case
so let's say we are
writing here one more case as
two
and the output will be
document
dot write
the second month is february right
and february we can write so
we'll include one break here like will
come in the first case and include a
break statement so here's how you can
write a break statement how you can
include a break statement in your code
so let's check the output now so for now
it says january
so if we don't include this break
statement here when the interpreter will
execute this code
and it will see that the case is one
right so it will print january
but
it will print other statements as well
so for example if we remove this break
statement and save it now see you can
see here the output as january and
february january and february both are
getting printed on the output so we need
a break statement to break it here see
the value is 1 and if we include break
statement here
the moment the interpreter finds the
answer the correct answer as january it
will come out of the switch case
so i hope you guys are getting this
similarly will write all the cases for
all the months let me show you all the
cases
so here you can see on your screen that
we have 12 different cases from 1 to 12
one for each month depending on the
value the variable month is holding
right
the output will be june if the value is
6 and if we say 10 the output will be
october and so on and so forth
now
the question here is what if we try to
write a random value for the variable
month
by random value we mean that
if we try to write any value other than
these 12 values from 1 to 12 if
if we leave these values then if we try
to write another value like if we write
here 13
so what will be the output now let's
save it and see
there is no output and there might be no
error for this as well so if you try to
check for an error go to inspect and
check out
see there is no error right so in that
case we have one more case like we have
default case
so let me show you how to include
default in your program what you have to
do is write here
default
with a colon and write
document
dot right and
let's suppose we are writing here
wrong input
what is happening is let's try to run
this program first press ctrl s and now
you can see it says raw input for value
13.
so what is happening is the switch case
will first check these 12 cases and any
value other than 1 to 12 will get the
output as wrong input it works the same
as the else statement right
in else statement we don't need to
specify any particular condition any
condition other than the if condition or
else if condition will fall inside the
else statement it's not necessary to add
default in your program it's just if you
want to give the user a prompt that he
has entered a wrong value
so
you must include this default case in
your program every time by using switch
gears because it's quite useful you know
okay
so this is the complete program to find
out
the month by accepting its number
if you try
6
and save it now it will say june if we
try 10 save it it will say october if we
try 12 save it it will say december so i
hope this is clear to you guys
next up let's discuss about switch case
in detail because
the switch case in javascript works
differently from other languages like
switch case is also present in c plus
and java but in javascript it is a bit
different so in javascript
switch case can accept numbers it can
accept strings and boolean values as
well
now let's have a look at how the switch
case works with string values
so here is an example of string values
you can see the value variable month is
holding is june right and you can use
this string in case as well so here you
have to
give the case as a string value right
because we are using switch case
statement with
strings so the first case here is when
the value will be june
the output should be sixth month and
when the value is july the output will
be seventh month so let's check it out
if this is working or not let's save
this program and see for june it says
sixth month and similarly we can check
it for july as well let's check for july
save it and see it says seventh month
you can include the default case as well
if you want to
it will be similar like there is no
difference for default case let me show
you how
we'll write here wrong input
and save it and now let's try to change
the value here let's say we are using
may
save it and see it says wrong input but
if we use a numerical value here let's
try to use two save it now it says wrong
input for two as well
it will give you the output when the
value is either june or july
so any other value you try to use here
it will give the output as wrong input
in the same way it works for boolean
values as well let me show you how it
works for boolean values
so what you have to do instead of 2 you
have to give here a boolean value let's
suppose you are writing here true
and for true you have to change the case
as well for true
you have to change the output as
let's say for true it the output will be
one
okay and similarly for false
the output should be
zero
and the output should be wrong input for
any other case right so save it now
and see here for true it says one the
output you can see here is one
and if you try to do the same for false
like let's write here false
and now try to check the output see here
it says
0
you can see the output is correct right
so iterative statements or looping
statements we can say are used when we
want to perform an activity multiple
times or n number of times so we don't
have to copy paste that code every time
but we can use iterative statements
using iterative statements will make our
code clean and definitely more efficient
so we have four different types of
iterative control statements right we
discussed it in the previous video let's
move on to for loop which is a first
iterative control statement and we'll
move on to the programming part directly
so before we start one thing to keep in
mind guys is that
we use for loop when we are clear with
the number of iterations in advance
so let's start with our first program in
this program we will print the
multiplication table of 10
from 10 into 1 to 10 into 10
let's start with coding
first we write the 4 keyword and then we
have
three different parts we have the
initialization
which is separated by a semicolon next
up we have the condition
and finally
we have the increment or decrement
so this is the syntax for for loop
next up we have
the open and closed curly braces for the
body of for loop
will change these three values
as these are not the actual values right
or parameters for these three different
parts of the loop are going to be
different
so let me comment this one
so we'll what we'll do we'll leave it
here only we'll change it from here so
in the initialization part what we are
going to do is we will create a variable
let's say we are creating a variable
where a and the value of and the initial
value of a will be 1.
this initialization happens only one
time when the for loop begins we have to
be careful about the condition we are
going to use
because sometimes what happens is the
loop runs forever because of a wrong
condition which will ultimately crash
our program
so in the condition what we have to do
is we have to give a value as in for how
long a for loop should execute here in
this case
we want to print the table of 10 right
we want to have 10 iteration
so what it will do it will start from a
equals to 1 and it will go till this
final condition so let's suppose we are
writing here a less than equals to 10
it will start from a equals to 1 and it
will go till a less than or equals to 10
and next up we will use the increment
operator we want to increment the value
of a by 1 every time right so we'll use
increment operator a plus plus or we can
say a equals to a plus 1 both are the
same things right so here the condition
will be like this for variable a equals
to 1 a less than equals to 10 and a plus
plus so here you can see the loop will
execute from a equals to 1 till a equals
to 10 and the value will be increased by
1 every time
because we have used the increment
operator right next up the body of for
loop will go like
so what we want to print here we want to
print the
table of 10 right so we'll use document
dot write and inside document dot right
we'll use the h1 tag
so what we want to do is we want to
print the table of 10 right so
we will multiply 10
by a
for every iteration the value of a will
be multiplied by 10 and then it will be
printed on the browser
so we'll close the h1 tag here
in the semicolon
so here you can see we have printed 10
into a let's save it and check the
output first and then we'll look at the
execution flow of this program
see here the multiplication table of 10
is printed on the browser you can see 10
20 30 40 so on and so forth till 100
so what is happening is firstly the for
loop is also known as the entry control
loop it means
that the condition is checked initially
the first time the for loop runs
we perform initialization only once so
here the value stored at variable a is 1
initially the value is 1 next up it will
check for a less than equals to 10 is a
which is 1 is 1 less than equals to 10
then true the control will be shifted to
document.write and it will print
10 into the value of a is 1 right so it
will print 10 here
next thing it will go for the increment
and the value of a will be changed to 2
from 1 1 plus 1 or we can say 1 equals
to 1 plus 1 right so it will be 2 now
next thing it will leave this now
because the initialization happens only
once now it will go for the condition
directly now it will check for is 2 less
than or equals to 10 if yes then again
the control will be shifted here and it
will print 10 into 2 because the value
of a is 2 now and after that it it will
print 20 here and after that
the value of a will be increased to 3
because we have used a plus plus then it
will check for 3 is 3 less than 10 and
same thing will happen it will print 30
and so on and so forth till the value of
a is 10 now if the value of a is 10 it
will print 100 right and when the value
is incremented it will become 11.
so what will happen now it will check
for 11 less than equals to 10.
no we know that 11 is not less than
equal to 10 right then it comes out of
the loop and it will print nothing after
that so this is the basic working of the
for loop we'll go through one more
program wherein we'll print the odd
numbers between 1 and 10. so what are
odd numbers odd numbers are those
numbers which are not divisible by 2
right
so we have the odd numbers as 1 3 5 7 9
and we want to print them so the
difference between each number is of 2
the 1 plus 2 plus 2 plus 2 till 9 right
so what we have to do is we have to
write here a
plus equals to 2 we have to increase the
value of a by 2
and instead of writing here 10 into a
because this time we don't want to
print any multiplication table we want
to print a number only right so we'll
use a only save it and check the output
it says 13579
so these are the odd numbers present
between one and ten
keep one thing in mind that you have to
give the condition wisely every time
so next up we have the while loop like
the for loop while loop is also an entry
control loop which means that the
condition will be checked first so the
question here is how while loop is
different from the for loop if you guys
remember when we discussed that we must
know the exact number of iterations then
only we can use the for loop right so
the while loop is preferred when we are
not aware of the number of iterations or
we can say we don't know if the
condition will be true for a certain
number of times
we'll start with the programming part
now
and then we will discuss more about when
to use while loop over for loop
so let's start with the program in this
particular program we will print odd
numbers up to a specific number
let's say
we want to print all the odd numbers up
to 50.
so we want to print all the odd numbers
from 1 till 50 right
we came across the same program in the
previous video as well but this time we
will use the while loop instead of for
loop
so the syntax for the while loop is
relatively easy to use
the code goes like we start with the
while keyword
then
opening and closing round brackets and
finally the body of while loop in curly
braces
if you guys remember from the previous
video wherein we used the for loop we
had three different parts right we had
the initialization we had conditions and
the increment decrement part here we
have only one condition and until this
condition holds true the while loop will
be executed for example here we want to
print all the odd numbers from 1 to 50
right so we'll first initialize a
variable
let's initialize a variable first let's
say we have a variable x and the value
of x will be 1
we used here 1 because
1 is the very first odd number right
after that inside the condition what we
want to do is we want to print the odd
numbers
up to 50.
so while the condition will be like
while
x
less than equals to 50
so the loop will go till x
is less than or equals to 50
or we can say x less than 15. that
depends on us if we want to check for 50
or not so the odd numbers will go like
1 and then we have 3 then we have 5 then
we have 7 and up to 50. so the last odd
number will be 49 so inside the while
loop we will print the value of x so
here we will print the value of x let's
print it
document
dot right
and inside this we will print the value
of x inside the h1 tag
suppose we try to run this program now
it will go on an infinite loop and the
reason for this is we are not doing
anything to increment the value of x
just like in for loop if you remember we
had the initialization first we had the
initialization here as well
then we had the condition we have a
condition here as well and then finally
it has an increment or decrement part
right so here we don't have that same
increment or decrement part we have to
do it separately so we'll increment the
value of x here only so here we will
write x
plus equals to 2 or we can say it is
same as
x equals to x plus 2. you guys are aware
of it right so the reason is simple
because we want to go from 1 to 3 to 5
and so on that's why we use x plus
equals to 2. we incremented the value of
x by 2.
save it here and let's check the output
so here you can see it says 1 3 5 7 9
and
so on and so forth till 49 so 49 is the
last odd number before 50 because we are
checking between 1 and 50 right so 49 is
the last
odd number
let me show you how the program goes
into an infinite loop
so for that what we have to do we will
comment this whole line here let's check
the output now save it and here you can
see
it is refreshing forever and this is
basically how a program in an infinite
loop looks like
the output of this program is the
program will ultimately crash so what we
have to do we have to
open a new tab and then again we have to
run the program with
correct increment part so here you can
see you can wait for it to become
responsive or exit the page so here you
can see we have all the odd numbers from
1
up to 50 and the last one is 49
coming back to the difference between
the while loop and the for loop we did
the same program previously right using
the for loop so where to use
while loop
over for loop so consider a scenario
where we are taking input from the user
and the input from the user is why we
want to do something let's say we want
to print something on the screen or if
the input from the user is n we want the
process to be stopped we can give the
condition in the while loop which will
go like when the character y becomes n
the process will be stopped we'll go
through one such program once we are
done with the dom manipulation part
wherein we take the input from the user
let's move on to the do-while loop in
javascript
in the previous videos we have already
discussed that both for loop and the
while loop are entry control loop that
means the conditions are checked first
right but the do-while loop is a bit
different or we can say it is an exit
control loop wherein the condition is
checked after the execution of the loops
body thus an exit control loop executes
at least once
even if the test condition fails or we
can say the condition is wrong the loop
will execute once
using the do while loop is relatively
easy it seems like we are giving the
system a command to do something while
the condition is something
so let's start with the syntax now
the syntax goes like this we write the
keyword do and we have a pair of curly
braces for the body of the loop and
after that we have the while keyword and
here we'll write the condition
make sure you are using the semicolon
after the while loop it's necessary
while using do while loop keep this
thing in mind
so we have two parts in the do-while
loop the do part and the while part or
we can say the condition part while part
is the part where we write the condition
so let's define a variable first let's
say we are using a variable we are using
a variable x and the value of x will be
5.
so here we have taken 5 as a random
value you can take 1 as well now inside
the condition part of the do while loop
this is the condition part where we are
using the while keyword so we'll give a
condition let's say we are using while x
greater than 5 it will check for the
condition that if the value of x is
greater than 5
or if the value of x is smaller than or
equal to 5 it will come out of the loop
in the do part we will write what we
want to do let's say we want to print a
single sentence here
we write document.write
and whatever sentence we want to write
let's say we are using
welcome to
simply code so here you might be
thinking that the condition is false but
the condition will be checked after the
first iteration in the do while loop so
no matter what the condition is the
first iteration will happen always
so if we try to save this program and
let's try to run this
here you can see the output is welcome
to simply code
a single line is printed
what is happening here is although the
condition we used was wrong but the
condition will be checked only after the
first iteration when the do while loop
will perform this particular statement
when the document.write will be
performed after that it will check for
the condition if x is greater than 5 or
not
if we use here 6 instead of 5
let's try to write here 6 instead of 5
and if we run this program now
it will go into an infinite loop because
we are not performing the increment
decrement operator here right as we have
discussed in the previous videos the
importance of increment decrement part
so we need to do it here after the
document.write part so what we'll do
here we'll write x minus minus today we
are using x minus minus and for the
other two loops we use the plus
increment operator right so the x minus
minus is the same as x equals to x minus
1 let's check the output now
save it
here you can see the output is still
welcome to simply code the execution
flow of this program will be like it
will first perform the iteration before
checking the condition and it will print
here welcome to simply code for the
first time when the loop will start
executing it will first perform this
statement and it will write here welcome
to simply code
so then it will perform x minus minus
means the value of x is now 5 because we
are decrementing the value by 1 so when
the value of x is 5 then it will check
for the condition if x is greater than 5
or not so here we can see clearly x is
not greater than 5 because x equals to 5
and it is equals to 5 right so it will
come out of the loop
let's make few changes in the code here
suppose
we use here 10 instead of 6 now
and let's print the value of x as well
it will be easy for you to understand so
we'll print here x
and we'll use a
space
so that it will be clear for you
we'll use here the br tag and now let's
try to run this program here you can see
the output goes from 10 to 6 and it
prints welcome to simply code every time
right if you guys are wondering where we
use the do while loop sometimes it may
happen that even though the condition is
false but we have to execute that
command we use the do while loop when we
want the code to output some sort of
menu to the user or to generate the menu
at least once we'll get to know about
the do while loop in future videos when
we create a program specifically for the
do while loop
this video is just a syntax
demonstration
we'll go through the examples
of all the three loops present in
javascript so today we have three
different problems
for three separate loops right we'll go
through each of the problems and we'll
discuss the execution flow for each loop
we'll go through
so let's start this session with the
first problem statement so the first
problem statement goes like this so here
we have to write a program to check
whether a number is prime or not i hope
you guys are aware of what prime numbers
are right so a prime number is a
positive number that is only divisible
by 1 and itself for example
2 3 5 and we have 7 and 11 these are the
first few prime numbers right if we take
an example let's say we are taking an
example of 7 so 7 is a number which is
divisible by 1 and 7 only no other
number can divide 7 right so here in
this code we have to check whether up
number is prime or not
so let me take you through the code
so here is the code to check whether a
number is a prime number or not let me
take you through this first
so we have a variable number and the
value of variable number can be any
random value like any number you want to
check if the number is prime number or
not you can give that value to the
variable number
so here we have taken 83 next up we have
a variable is prime
whose value is a boolean value right it
can be true for a prime number or it can
be false for a non-prime number
so we have used comments in this program
to make it easier for you guys to
understand so here we have used the if
statement to check if the number is 1
because we know that 1 is neither a
prime number nor a composite number
right so we have to check if the user
enters the value 1 or if we are giving
the value 1 we have to check for it so
if user enters the value 1 it will print
this statement that 1 is neither prime
nor composite
here in elsif we are checking if the
value of number is greater than 1 or not
so if the value of number is greater
than 1 the control will be shifted to
for loop present inside the else if
statement right here you can see we have
the for loop here the control will be
shifted to this for loop so here you can
see we have initialized the variable i
and the initial value is set to 2 that's
because any prime number is divisible by
1 as well right so it won't make any
sense to include 1 here
we'll start from 2 and we'll check until
the value of i becomes half of the value
of number so if we take an example of 10
we'll check until 5 because you know any
number greater than 5 won't divide 10
right it's practically not possible so
we'll check for number by 2 or we can
say we'll check till 5 only and the
value will be increased by 1 every time
till now i hope you guys are aware of
how to use for loop and why we are using
for loop here we can do the same program
using while loop as well but to make it
more clear how to use for loop we are
doing this program with the help of for
loop so then we have the i plus plus or
we can say we have increased the value
of i by one after every iteration until
the value of i becomes
half of the number
so the condition number percent i equals
to equals to zero
so here is the main condition to check
if the number is divisible by
i or not so the execution will be like
if we are taking here a number 10 it
will start from 2 and it will check if
the remainder is 0 or not so if the
remainder is 0
then the value of is prime will be
changed to false and it will come out of
the loop
next it will check for the value of s
prime if the value of s prime is true or
not here you can see if the value of is
prime is true then it will print
n or we can say then it will print that
the number is a prime number else it
will print that
the number is not a prime number if the
value of s prime is false for example
when we took the example of
number as 10 so the value of s prime
will be changed to false because you
know 10 divides by 2 is equals to 0
or we can say the remainder will be 0.
so the value of this prime will be
changed to false and for false it will
print number is not a prime number
so at last we will check if the number
is less than 1 if the number entered by
the user or any other number we have
taken like if we take a minus 5
so it will print the number is not a
prime number
because by the usual definition of
prime numbers
any negative number
cannot be a prime number that's a usual
definition right so we have to keep this
thing in mind and here in this else loop
we'll
print that if any negative number is
entered we'll make sure that the program
gives the output that the number is not
a prime number
so let's try to run this program and
check the output let's save this program
and
the output says 83 is a prime number as
83 is not divisible by any number except
1 and 83 for example if we take here any
number which is divisible by so let's
say we are taking 75 save it now and see
it says 75 is not a prime number okay
here's a spelling mistake it says 75 is
a not prime number so here we will
correct this
is
so we are done with it and save it now
now it says 75 is not a prime number s75
is divisible by numbers other than one
end itself right it is divisible by 3 it
is divisible by 5 15 and 25 as well all
these numbers divide 75 basically
so let's take a different value here
let's say we are taking
minus 7
let's change the value here as or we can
take it as minus 75 let's save it now
so it says the number is not a prime
number
or if we want to try for 1 as well let's
take it as 1
and let's check the output now so it
says 1 is neither prime nor composite
number because we have given here the
condition if number is equals to is
equals to 1 then it will print that 1 is
neither a prime nor a composite number
you can try this program with the help
of other loops as well
so let's move on to the second problem
statement but before that let me take
you through the same program using the
while loop so here you can see we have
used the while loop for
the same instead of for loop here you
can see we have used while i
less than a
number by 2 and we have given the
increment condition here and we have
initialized the value of i
at
the start of the program so if we try to
run this program it will give us the
same output there will be no change in
the output so we can use while loop as
well so we'll use the while loop in
other program
let's move on to the second problem
statement
so in this example we'll learn to write
a program in javascript to check whether
a number is an armstrong number or not
so we'll do this with the help of while
loop let's have a look at how to
implement this program
before proceeding to the coding part
let's have a look at what is an
armstrong number so an armstrong number
of three digits is an integer such that
the sum of the cubes of its digits is
equal to the number itself
so for example 153 is an armstrong
number since
1 into 1 into 1 it means the cube of the
digit 1
plus the cube of 5 that is 5 into 5 into
5 which is equal to 125 and the cube of
3 which is 3 3's are 9 and 9 3's are 27.
so it will go like 125
plus 27 plus 1 so which is equal to 153
so an armstrong number of three digits
is an integer such that the sum of the
cubes of its digits is equal to the
number itself so here we have the code
for the same this is the code to check
whether the number is an armstrong
number or not
so here we have taken a variable
and the value is 153 the value of the
variable number is 153 right because we
already know that 153 is an armstrong
number there are few more numbers like 3
7 1 is also an armstrong number
next up we have taken a variable sum and
the initial value of sum is
0 we have used the variable sum to store
the value of the cubes
and next up we have a temporary variable
so that we can break a three digit
number and we need the number after all
this all this
program all these loops and all we'll
need the number we'll need the original
number to compare it with the sum of the
cubes which will be hold in sum
so but we need to break the number as
well right so we need a temporary
variable to break it
here we use the while loop and the loop
will run until the value of variable
temp is greater than zero so the initial
value of temp will be 153 here in this
particular case the initial value will
be 153 and the loop will run until the
value of 153 is greater than zero
next up we have a variable remainder
that stores the
last digits value as we are dividing 153
by 10.
so
the remainder here will be 3 so the
value saved at variable remainder will
be 3 for the first time then what will
happen with we are updating the value of
sum and the new value of sum will be
0 plus 3 into 3 into 3 so 3 3's are 9
and 9 3's are 27 so the
updated value of sum will be 27 next up
we are
removing the last digit from the number
so
for example we have here 153 and if we
divide 153 by 10
the answer will be 15.3
that's why we are using here percent
because what percent will do it will
convert the float value into an integer
so if we try to perform a simple divide
in javascript like if we try to divide
153 by 10 it will give us 1 5.3 it will
give us a float value but we want an
integer value right so pass it will
change this value to the nearest integer
so 1 5.3 the nearest integer will be one
five so the new value of temp will be
one five then again this loop will be
executed and
for this time the variable reminder will
hold the value of 15
modulus 10 and the remainder will be 5
right
so the new value of remainder is 5 and
the value of sum is 27 plus 5 into 5
into 5 which is 27 plus 125 right so the
new value of sum will be 152
and then again it will go to the temp
and it will divide 15 by 10 and it will
change the value to an integer so 1.5
will be changed to 1. and next up the
final value of temp is 1 which is
greater than 0 right so it will divide
10 by 1 and the remainder will be 1
so next up it will add 152 plus 1 into 1
into 1 that is 153 right and then it
will divide 1 by 10
using the power sent but this time the
value will be 0 because there is no
remainder right
next up we will compare the value of the
sum and the number variable so the sum
variable here it is holding the value as
153. we break this number into three
different parts then we took the cube of
these three number and added them so the
final value of the variable sum is 153
and the initial value of number or we
can say the value we gave to the
variable number is 153 so right it will
print here that 153 is an armstrong
number
or if we use any other number instead of
153 let's suppose we are using
121 so it will print 121 is not an
armstrong number let's
check out the output once let's save it
and see the output here is 153 is an
armstrong number so if we change the
value of one five three to
one to one
so let's check the output now it says
one two one is not an armstrong number
why because if we take the cube of each
of the digit and we'll add them suppose
the
answer here will be 10 because the cube
of 1 is 1 and the cube of 2 is 8 and the
cube of the final one is 1 so 8 plus 1
plus 1 is equals to 10
so that's why one two one is not an
armstrong number
let's move on to our last problem
statement
where we'll use the do-while loop to
find the factorial of a number
so here is the problem statement where
we'll have to write a program to find
the factorial of a number
so factorial of an integer is the
product of an integer and all the
integers below it or we can say before
it till 1 so if we take an example of 5
so the factorial of 5 will be
it will multiply each number before it
if we take 5 the factorial will be
5
into 4 into 3
into 2 into 1
or if we don't include 1 that's totally
fine
so this program is pretty simple as
compared to the previous two we did
so this is a small one too let me take
you through this so here we have the
program
and here we have three variables right
we have a variable i which is
initialized as one then we have a
variable n which is five
and then we have a
variable f whose value is one f is for
factorial
and n is for number we want to check the
factorial of and i is for checking the
condition
so here what we will do we'll use a loop
where
if we for example if we are taking 5
then the loop will go from 1 into 2 into
3 into 4 into 5 from 1 to that number
it's not
like if we are using from 5 towards 1
but we are going from 1 towards 5.
the answer will be same right because we
are multiplying all the numbers in both
the cases
so here we took 5 as the number next up
we have a variable f and the value of f
is also 1 as you know
so here we are using the do while loop
for the first iteration it will perform
this so the value of f for the first
iteration will be f equals to f into i
which means f equals to 1 into 1 which
is 1
so the value of i will be increased and
it will become 2 and now it will check
for
while 2 is less than equals to n yes 2
is less than n so it will
again go up and it will update the value
of f
and the new value of of f will be 1 into
2 that is 2. then again the value will
be increased and it will become 3
and then it will
change the value of
f as well if it will become 6 and the
value of i will become 4 then it will
check if 4 is less than 5 yes 4 is less
than 5
and then it will multiply 4 with 6
because the value of f was 6 right so 4
into 6 it will become 24 and then
finally the value of i will be 5 and it
will check if the value of i is less
than or equals to 5 right while i is
less than equals to 5 yes that's true
because now 5 is equals to 5 and it will
again execute the loop and the value of
f will be 24 into 5 which is 120 and
then again the value of i will be
increased now it will become 6 which is
greater than 5 so it will come out of
the loop and it will print the factorial
of the number so let's save this program
so the factorial of 5 is 120
because see here we have used the
factorial of
n n is 5
and the factorial is 120 so if we
try to give any other number here other
than 5 let's say we are using here 10
save it
it says the factorial is
362 double a double zero oh it's 36 lakh
twenty eight thousand eight hundred so
if you try to multiply ten into nine
into eight into seven so on till two or
we can say one the answer will be this
you can check it you can google it or
you can go through it in your calculator
the typical definition of function
states that to work in a proper or in a
particular way
similarly functions in javascript are a
block of code that is used to perform a
specific task
in this particular video we will go
through the syntax and usage of
functions
so a function has a particular name and
we can reuse that block of code again
and again in our entire program
for example
let's suppose that we have to add two
numbers in a program that's a basic
program right sum of two numbers so
let's write the code first so we are
going to take a variable x and the value
of x will be 10
then again we are going to take a
variable y and the value of y will be 5.
lastly we are going to take a variable
total and the value of total will be
x plus y
so
the last thing
we are going to do is we are going to
print this on a browser
so here we are we are done with our
program we are done with adding two
numbers so let's save it and check the
output see the output here says 15.
so what is happening is
the value of x plus y which is 10 plus 5
is stored in the variable total and we
are displaying total on a browser
so that's a very basic program right
now consider a scenario where we have to
do this addition for n number of times
at different intervals so we have to
perform the same task of addition at
different intervals so in that case what
we can do is we can copy paste this same
code repeatedly but the length of the
program will increase because of that
right and it doesn't make any sense to
copy paste the same code again and again
so this is where functions come into
play with the help of functions we can
create a separate function to do this
particular task and we can call that
function again and again i'll take you
through it so basically a function has
three parts will go through each of them
a function has function declaration then
it has function definition and then
finally it has function calling
so we'll perform this same program of
adding two numbers we'll add two numbers
but this time we'll use the concept of
functions
so we'll use this whole code
we are going to use it inside the
function so let's move on and see how
the function looks like how the syntax
of function looks like
so we use the keyword function
and then we have the function name so
let's suppose here we are naming the
function as sum
then we have the opening and closing
round brackets which denotes that this
is a function
this is the way to write a function
next up we have a pair of curly braces
for the body of the function so this is
the basic syntax of how a function looks
like
the naming convention for functions is
the same as we had for variables in
javascript if you guys remember we have
already discussed this naming convention
of variables
so this is the basic structure of a
function
so now we'll cut this whole code
and we'll
paste it here inside the function
right so we are done with it we are done
with our functions first part first we
declared a function with name sum then
we are done with the definition of
function
now what if we try to run this program
let's save this program and see it is
not printing anything on screen but if
you try to check out for any errors it
won't show any errors see there is no
error in this program
this is happening because we haven't
called the function yet right so to call
the function we have to write a single
word just write sum
with
opening and closing
round brackets and save it now now you
can see the output here is 15. so this
is known as function calling the program
already knows that there is a function
by the name sum
it will go and check for the same if the
function is there or not if the program
finds it it will execute the function
next up a function can also have
parameters what do i mean by parameters
is we don't have to declare these
variables variable x and variable y here
instead of declaring them here we can
pass these values to the function let's
say we are passing x and y here or we
can pass a and b any variable you want
to pass
you can pass it here
now we can remove this
variable x and variable y
we have to write here where because we
still need the variable total and next
up we have to pass the value for these
variables when we call the function so
we have to pass the values here let's
say we are passing the values as
4
and
3
so
let's try to run this program now and
see if it works let's save it and see
you can see here the output as 7
we can also pass strings over here so
instead of 4 if we try to pass any
string let's say we are passing
welcome 2
and instead of 3
will pass
simply code right now let's save this
program and see the output it says
welcome to simply code we don't have to
worry about the data type we'll use here
because javascript is a loosely typed
language right so the function will
automatically adapt to the data type
according to the value we will pass
during the function call
here in this code
variable x holds the value welcome to
and the variable y is having simply code
allocated to them dynamically so this is
what is known as
parameter passing in functions
let's move on and discuss the return
types in functions
so a function can also return a value
right now
we can see that a function is doing the
printing task what if we remove this
document dot right from here and we'll
paste it somewhere else on the program
outside the function so we'll paste it
here right now the function will perform
addition only it won't print anything it
will just perform the addition let's
save this and see there's nothing so if
we try to check for error it says total
is not defined because total is defined
inside the function this is because of
the concept of local and global variable
we will discuss this concept in upcoming
video
so
here you can see it says total is not
defined right
so now what we have to do is we have to
write here
return
total
so now the function will return the
value of total outside
what this return statement does is
whenever we call the function as you can
see here we are calling the function
from outside and we are passing the
parameters as welcome to and simply code
right
so these parameters will go as x and y
and we are getting the concatenation of
welcome to simply code
right so when this return statement
comes into function
the value of this total variable will be
given out of the function
so there has to be a particular variable
to hold the value returned by the
function
we'll
use a variable here let's say we are
using the variable output
and in the rhs we are calling the
function so we have an equals to between
the lhs and rhs that's because when we
are calling the function it will return
a value and the assignment is done from
right to left in the case of an
assignment operator if you guys remember
we came across this
that whenever we are using an assignment
operator the assignment will be done
from right towards the left
so whatever value the function will
return upon calling will be assigned to
the variable output
in this program we are passing welcome
to and simply code right so let's change
these two values now we'll change them
to a numerical value let's say we are
using here
35
and instead of simply code we'll use a
15 and we are going to print here output
on the browser because the variable
output is holding the value returned by
the function right so let's save it now
and see the output is 50.
okay guys so this was the syntax
demonstration of functions in javascript
with a quick small program the
javascript is a loosely typed scripting
language right that means we don't need
to specify the data types every time
so a variable is basically a container
that can store data values those values
can be changed whenever needed in this
particular video we are going to discuss
the scope of variables in javascript so
what does this scope mean in variables
so scope refers to the life of a
variable in a program
there are basically two types of
variables present in javascript local
variables and global variables
depending upon where we are creating a
variable variable may have two different
types of scope so let's have a look at
these two different types of variables
with the help of examples
let's say we are creating a variable
here let's say we are creating a
variable
where a and the value of a will be 5. so
we have created a variable here and
let's print the value of this variable
in the browser so what we'll do we'll
print this value in the
browser
so let's print the value of this
variable on the browser so here we have
printed the value of variable a so here
you can see the value is 5.
so we can print the value of this
variable anytime and anywhere in our
program right so if we try to copy this
line from here and we'll paste it
somewhere else in a program let's say we
are pasting it here so if we try to save
it now see here you can see that we have
two values of a because we have printed
a twice here right once we have used
this a here then we have used this a
here so here you can see we have two
values of a five and five so this
variable a is a global variable which
means
its life is available throughout the
entire program or the entire script we
can say
and when we declare a variable inside a
function that variable is known as a
local variable for that function so
let's try to do it as well we already
know what functions are as we saw in the
previous video right so what we'll do
we'll make a function here let's say we
are creating a function
function
my function
opening and closing round bracket and
the body of the function right so let's
declare a variable here let's say we are
using a variable where x and the value
of x will be 10 right let's try to print
this value
so we have created a function here now
we are left with the function call only
so let's call the function here
but we'll do we'll call my function
right
save it and now here you can see the
output is 10 5 and 5 so if we comment
these three lines if we remove these
three lines and we'll save it now so
here you can see we have the output as
10 only so this variable x which is
declared inside a function so why it is
a local variable because if we try to
access this variable from outside the
function it is not possible so let's
cut this line from here and let's try to
paste it here so now what we are doing
is we are trying to access this variable
from outside the function let's save it
now
let's save this program now and see the
there is no output in the browser
because a local variable can be accessed
only in that function we can't access it
from outside of the function
so this is happening because as soon as
the function is executed the variable
gets destroyed means there is no
variable present in the memory now
the same thing applies to the memory
whenever we run a javascript program the
whole browser is present in the ram
or we can say in the memory so these
local variables are created only till
the function is executing once the
function is done running the same
function wipes out of the memory
whereas the case is different for global
variables so global variables are
available throughout the script they
have a global lifetime which means that
they will exist throughout the program's
running or we can say until the tab is
open
the next exciting thing about global
variables is
that we can access global variables from
inside the function so what we'll do
let's
cut this line from here
and we'll paste it
here so now what we'll do we'll declare
a variable here let's say we are
declaring a variable where y and the
value of y will be
15.
so copy this line
and paste it again now what we will do
we will try to access y from inside the
function
so let's save the program and see the
output here is 10 and 15 10 is the value
of x and x is a local variable for
function my function because we have
declared x inside the function whereas
variable y is a global variable we have
declared it outside the function and we
tried to access it from inside of the
function right so we tried to access y
here and we can see the value of y is 15
which is printed on the browser this is
what global variables are one more
exciting thing i want to mention at the
end of this video is if we declare any
variable in javascript without using the
where keyword so if we try to declare a
variable here let's say we are declaring
var1 okay we have not used any var
keyword so what we are doing is we are
declaring a variable and the value of
where1 is 15. so we don't need the where
keyword separately when we are declaring
a variable however some of the newer
versions of web browser have some sort
of issue if we try to declare a variable
inside this function without using the
where keyword
so let's try to access this variable
let's try to access let's declare it
inside the function
okay what we'll do is we'll
declare this variable inside the
function
and will come in this line and what
we'll do is we'll try to access it from
outside the function right
what we'll do is
we'll write here
var1
save this
and see if
you don't understand it let me change
the value of where one let's change this
value to 20 save it now and see the
output here is 10 and 20. so where one
is a variable which is declared without
using the wire keyword right so we can
access this variable from outside the
function as well any variable which is
declared without using where keyword is
a global variable keep this thing in
mind guys we came across the different
types of data types present in
javascript
in the previous video where we came
across the types of primitive data types
in javascript we discussed number string
and we had boolean null and undefined
right so these are the five types of
primitive data types present in
javascript
we know that strings in any programming
language are used to store and
manipulate textual value a string
contains a sequence of characters
written inside double quotes
so let's declare a basic string here
let's say we have a variable
and we have a variable as where x and
the value of x will be a basic string
let's say we have hi there as the value
okay
next thing we'll print this on a browser
document.write and we'll print x on a
browser
so this here is a string that holds a
textual value right suppose we try to
find the type of the variable x so
i hope you guys are aware of that if
you're not then please go through the
previous video on data types in
javascript let's print this value on
browser first
so here you can see it says hi there so
this is a string and let's try to
determine the type of variable x and
we'll see if it returns a string or
something else we'll do it with the help
of type of operator right i hope you
guys remember that so let's try to use
type of operator here
and
here we'll use
type of x
so let's
save it
and see
here you can see we have a string as the
type of variable x so strings are
helpful for holding data that can be
represented in textual form so let's
move on to a first topic for today and
that is escape sequence in javascript so
if you guys ever noticed that in the
previous few videos we use a lot of html
tags in javascript right for example we
use the heading tags so often
like when we are using the document dot
right to print anything on the browser
we use heading tag quite a lot right so
the thing to notice here is that these
tags behaves as html tags right we use
them inside the double inverted commas
just like strings but they still act
like html tags so let's understand this
with the help of an example
what we'll do is we'll remove this code
we'll print a simple
statement in a browser so we'll use
document.write and we'll write here hi
there
and we'll use a
tag
right so a basic html tag we are going
to use
let's say we are using the break tag i
hope you all are aware of the break tag
so the next sentence will be
so here in this example we tried to
print a sentence and we are using the br
tag right so let's print it on the
browser
so we are using the break tag in between
the sentences we have hi there and we
have welcome to simply code
so
we use this break tag
in a string right so the output
what we were expecting was hi there and
the br should be written in
string but there's a difference in the
output right the br tag is actually
functioning as an html tag
so here the break tag works the same as
it did for html so with this we can
conclude that if we try to infuse any
html tag inside the javascript statement
it will act as that tag only
so let's move on and we'll look at some
other types of escape characters present
in javascript
so
let's say we want to print this line
okay we'll
edit this one only so what we will do is
we will remove this break tag and
suppose we want to print this on screen
so we want this on our screen and we
want the welcome to be inside the double
inverted comma
in output as well so if we try to run
this program now there will be nothing
in the browser let's try to check if
it gets any error so here it says uncut
syntax error it says missing
after the argument list
so how to print this on the browser we
want to highlight the word welcome
so if we try to run this program as it
is it's not working right
to do this type of task we have the
backslash escape character
to print the double quotes inside a
string we use a single backslash with a
double inverted comma with the syntaxes
we have to use this backslash before the
double inverted comma so now if we try
to print this on browser here you can
see it says hi there and welcome is
written within double inverted commas
right so that's how you can print this
on a screen next up if we want to use a
single inverted comma we have to use a
single backslash with a single inverted
comma so just like we did here with the
double inverted comma similarly we can
do it for single inverted comma as well
what we'll do is we'll copy this
document dot right and we'll print it
here
so here what we will print is
will print here it's all right okay
so we are using here a backslash with a
single inverted comma now we'll write
s
the output will be it's all right
so
we have to use them because
we need them in our program at times
right so to avoid any confusion one must
know how to use this sequence character
in javascript let's save this and see
if we try to comment this line
let me comment this to make it more
easier for you to understand let's save
it now and see it says it's all right
you can't print it's in similar way
without using the backslash escape
character
lastly if we want to put a backslash in
our string if we want to put a backslash
we want to show it in the browser so the
syntax for that will go like
we have the document.right right so here
we will write
the character
and we'll use
two backslashes
is called
backslash
so let's try to print this
so here one thing you can notice
only a single backslash is printed on
the browser the first one is used as a
backslash escape character and the
second one which we have used will be
printed on the browser
we have a few more escape sequence
present in javascript like the backslash
n or we can say newline
we don't use them quite often i'll let
you know if we use them in future so for
now it's enough for escape sequences
present in javascript if you guys
remember we discussed data type in
previous videos right so data types in
javascript are of two kinds we discussed
the primitive data types and the other
type is non-primitive or we can say
complex or composite data types right so
an array comes under the category of
composite data types or non-primitive we
can say
so
the basic definition of array states
that an array is a collection of
elements stored in contiguous memory
locations so array is a list of similar
type of elements or in javascript array
acts a bit different from other
programming languages we can discuss it
later so let's understand the concept of
errors with the help of an example we'll
move to the programming part directly
let's consider a scenario
where we have a collection of similar
types of variables suppose we have a
list of cars
let's create a small list here for a few
different car companies let's say we
have a variable where carbon
and the value of carbon will be
let's say
honda
okay and then we have another variable
let's say car 2 and the value of car 2
will be kia
and finally we have a variable let's say
where
car 3
and the value of car 3 will be let's say
4 so here we have taken three different
car manufacturers we have honda we have
kia and we have four and we have three
different variables right so if we want
to print all three of them what we have
to do is we have to use the
document.write method right so we have
to use the document.write again and
again
so we can do it for this small piece of
code right let's print the value of all
three variables here let's say we are
using document
dot write and we will print the value of
all three variables
so here we have printed the value of all
three variables right we have carbon the
value was honda we have honda here we
have kia and we have 4 as well
so this task is a bit simple for this
small piece of code right now imagine if
we have 100 values here instead of just
three values or maybe we can say we have
thousand values in a list we can't
follow the same procedure in that case
right
that's where arrays come into play what
we can do is we can use a single
variable and we can store as many values
as we want inside a single variable by
doing this we don't have to access each
and every variable separately while
printing them the data types of those
values present inside the array does not
matter at all so we can save either
numbers or strings or a value with any
data type we'll discuss it in a moment
let's try to define an array here first
so the syntax for array goes like this
we have to take a variable let's say
we'll declare an array here
let's say we are taking a variable where
car
and these opening and closing square
brackets represent the array it means
that it is an array if we are using them
in a variable inside this we can use
double quotes with the value we want to
insert it will go like this let's
suppose we have three values here right
we'll use these three values only we'll
use honda kia and food so to insert
these three values we have to follow
this syntax
so let's say we have the first
manufacturer as honda the next one we
have is
kia
and the last one we have is
ford right so we have all the three
values here present inside a single
variable so we have a single variable
where car and we have all the three
values we have honda we have kia and we
have four
so
we can insert as many values as we want
like if we have a list of hundred car
manufacturers we can insert them in this
array now let's print the output of this
area so the output will go like we will
copy document dot right from here
paste it here and
the output will go like this
so we don't need this piece of code
right now so we'll comment this
so that we can understand the difference
between these two codes
and now let's save this program and see
here you can see we have all the three
elements of the array we have honda we
have kia and we have ford as well
so an array is a non-primitive data type
or composite data type
with one single name and can hold
multiple values here the array name is
car and it stores three similar values
right here we have three string values
we have honda kia and food so this array
can store
any number of values we want to store in
that array
so what if we want to print a single
value from these three values we have we
have honda here and four right so if we
want to print kia let's suppose so it's
easy to print this on a browser all we
need to know is the index number of that
value so the index number in the case of
arrays starts from 0 and
goes further so we have three values
here
as we can see so the index value
for these variables will be so for honda
the index value will be zero and for kia
the index value will be one and for four
the index value will be two
so the index value starts from zero and
goes on further so one thing to keep in
mind guys whatever number of values an
array is holding the last index value
will always be one less than the number
of values so as here you can see we have
three values right so the index number
of the last value will be one less than
three
it means the index number will be two
because the index number starts from 0
let's try to access the element present
at index 1
so we have kia here right all we have to
do is we have to put square brackets
here in the document.write here we have
to put square brackets
and we have to write the index value
inside of these square brackets so if we
write here one and if we save this
program now so here you can see we have
kia only it will print
the element present at index number one
so here in this particular case it is
kia
we can also loop through this area using
the index values let's say we want to
print each element on a separate line
every time right so we can use the loop
here i hope you guys are aware of the
for loop by now we'll write here so
we'll
we have declared an array so we will use
the for loop here and we will print here
for
will take a variable i
and the value of i will initial value
will be 0 and then we'll give the
condition the condition will be i less
than 3 because we know there are 3
values only and it will go till 2 only
because it's going for the index value
and the final condition will be i
plus plus
so here we'll
use the curly braces
because this is the syntax for for loop
and the i value will iterate through the
array and print all the values present
at indexes till the index 2.
so the same thing goes for 100 elements
as well we can use the for loop to
access all the 100 elements in separate
lines
so guys if we save this and here you can
see okay
it is printing kiakia and kia because we
have particularly mentioned here cars
present at index one so we have to
remove one here and we'll save it now
so the document.write syntax will be
changed a bit we will write here i and
if we save it now so we have all the
three values here you can see guys the i
value here will iterate through the
array and print all the values present
at indexes till the index 2. so the same
thing goes for 100 elements as well we
can use the for loop to access all the
100 elements present in the array
we can use the same iteration concept
for doing so
so guys there's another way to represent
an array in javascript it goes like this
we have a let's say we have a variable
this time we'll take the variable as
well fruits
so the syntax will be like new we have
to use the new keyword and then we will
use
new array and we have to give a space
here and the elements we want to store
inside the array so we'll use a apple
then we have let's say
banana and finally we have let's say
mango
okay
and we can access the elements of these
array with the help of a for loop we can
use the similar for loop here
so if we copy this for loop from here
and we'll paste it here
instead of cars
we'll use a
fruits
right and we'll give the value as i
because we want to
iterate the variable i through each
index so we have once again the index
value as 0 for apple one for banana and
two for mango
let's comment this program as well so
that it will be easy for you guys to
understand let's save this program now
and see we have the list of all the
elements present at array fruits so we
have apple we have banana and we have
mango printed on our browser
so this way of array representation or
declaration is less recommended because
the other way which we discussed earlier
like when we discuss the car
manufacturers
so that way is a bit easier to use so
i'll recommend that way only because
this way is a bit tricky as well
so let's move on to our next topic of
discussion so if you know guys errors in
javascript work differently when
compared to other programming languages
like java and c plus plus so errors in
javascript have dynamic nature which
means we can add or remove elements from
an array at runtime
just like we saw the string methods in
the previous video for arrays also we
have a few methods like if we want to
add elements into an array or if we want
to delete an element from an array we
have the push and pop methods available
to do such tasks
to add an element into an array we use
the push method and the syntax for
pushing elements into an array goes like
so we'll
remove this piece of code
and we'll use the first one only the car
manufacturer
so if we want to push
something inside the array
right
we'll write here the variable name dot
we use the push method and we'll push
whatever value we want to push let's say
we are adding another car manufacturer
let's say we are adding nissan
we have to change the value here as well
because what will happen we have used
the condition i less than 3 so it will
check for indexes till index 2 only it
won't check for index 3 so if we write
here i less than 4 it will check for
nissan now let's save this and see a new
value is pushed into the array which is
nissan
so let's move on and discuss the pop
method so the pop method in array
removes the last present element from
the array if we use this pop method here
it will remove nissan in this case so
now you can see we have four car
manufacturers present in a array so if
we use the
pop option now if we use car.pop and
let's run this program
and see it says undefined this is
happening because as you can see we have
pushed the value nissan into our array
so an
address in the memory location was
reserved for that particular element now
if we pop out that particular element so
if we try to use cars.pop once again
let's save it now and see it removed the
element ford as well so
let's try to push one more
value in this particular scenario let's
say we are pushing a value as
hyundai
and now let's run this so you can see
here it have inserted hyundai in place
of food because we have used the pop
method to put food out of our array
so i hope you guys understood this so
these are the different methods for
areas in javascript which are already
predefined to do some specific tasks
like this sort method if we
write here card dot so here are all the
methods
here are all the array methods present
in javascript so if we use this sort
method what it will do it will sort the
array in ascending order
the array.length property so just like
we had the length property in strings so
we have the property in arrays as well
the array.length property is used to
find the length of the array so if we
use it in a for loop in place of this i
less than 4 so
here you can see we have used i less
than 4 now if we write here
array dot length so if we write here
car
dot
length so
now we don't have to change this value
again and again so if we are inserting
any value or if we are removing any
value from this for loop so if we are
removing any value from this
array so we don't have to write here 3
or we don't have to change it to 4 every
time we insert an element we don't have
to change that value basically what will
happen it will check for the length of
the array so the length here is
let's say we have the length here 3
right so it will check for the length
and it will be 1 less than the length of
the array so if we run this program now
it will work fine i hope you guys
understood the concept of array methods
present in javascript the other main
difference
array has in javascript which makes it
different from c plus plus or java is we
can add elements with other data types
in javascript we try to use the push
method to insert a numeric value here in
this car's array so we will push another
value let's say we are pushing car dot
push and this time we will push
a numeric value let's say we are pushing
here 20
so let's save it and here you can see
the value 20 is inserted inside the
array car
so we can
use
any data type inside a array in
javascript objects are the most powerful
and the most used data types in
javascript so far we have seen that we
can use a single variable to store a
value the value can be a string or a
number or any other type of variable
after that we have seen arrays in which
we can store multiple values like we can
store list in arrays
so let's take a scenario here
and let's say we have a piece of code we
are taking a variable let's say where
car manufacturer
and the value of this car manufacturer
will be rd a string right
next up we have another variable let's
say we have
variable car model
and the value of this will be let's say
car from od is q7
then we have another variable let's say
where price of this car
and the price will be
let's say
50 000 us dollars all right
next up we have a function
let's say we are using a function
that is all wheel drive
so we are having a function all wheel
drive the opening and closing curly
braces for the body of the function and
inside this all wheel drive function we
are using document.write
and here what we will write
will write let's suppose
this car comes
with
quattro all-wheel drive
quattro i hope you guys are aware of
this word quattro it means that four
wheel drive
next up we will call this all-wheel
drive function here
so here is the data about a particular
car from a particular brand od right so
the car model is q7 and the price of
this car is 50 000 us dollars so these
are the three different things we are
storing for a car of a particular brand
next up we have a function which states
the capability of the car the function
here is the all-wheel drive which means
that this car comes with four wheel
drive instead of general front wheel
drive or rear wheel drive
so this function is the behavior of the
car right
it shows that the car is four wheel
drive things are pretty sorted here
right we have the data about the car and
a function associated with it so let's
save this and we can see the output here
the car comes with quattro all wheel
drive so this is a basic piece of code
right
we have been through functions we know
how to use functions we know how to call
them so that's quite easy for now right
the problem occurs when we have a list
of cars let's say that we have to
maintain 100 different cars with all the
data of car manufacturer we have car
model price and then we have different
behaviors for different cars not all
cars have the all-wheel drive property
so
what we will do in such a case where we
have to use the same property again and
again for 100 different cars or 100
different entities we can copy paste
this same piece of code repeatedly and
we have to change the value every time
we copy paste it so we have to change
the variable name the car manufacturer
the car model and the price as well
imagine we are doing this for a list of
cars then it goes on and on so this is
the most inefficient way of tackling
this problem right
this is where the concept of objects
come into play
these objects help us to bundle all
these properties and attributes about
one particular entity if we talk about
this particular example of a car we can
put all these properties and many other
properties like car weight we have car
color and so on together under one name
and make it an object
let's move on to the syntax for objects
in javascript
we'll do it for this same program we'll
use objects now let's go ahead and have
a look at the syntax for objects
so before we start
there are few ways in which we can
create objects in javascript we are
going to discuss two different ways of
doing so
the first one is the literal way also
known as the literal object way
so the syntax for literal object way
goes like this
let's say we are declaring a variable
where car and
curly braces so these curly braces
represent that this car variable is
actually an object
inside this
we will define all the cars properties
that is whatever data we want to store
about the car like car manufacturer car
model and price in this particular
scenario so let's
use them here so we have
car manufacturer
and
the car manufacturer is od
right
next up we have car model
car model is
q7
finally we have the price which is
50
dollars
so you can identify the difference here
inside the object right when we declare
a variable we usually use the equals to
sign for assignment but here in objects
we use the colon and we are using commas
here because we have some more
properties so these three are the
properties
for this object car we have three
properties associated with it
we can also add this all wheel drive
function inside the object and when we
use this function inside the object it
will be called a method whenever we use
a function inside a class or an object
so it is known as a method keep this
thing in mind guys so that syntax is
also a bit different when it comes to
methods inside an object the syntax for
that will be
we have to write here all wheel drive
and we'll use the colon then it is a
function so we will write here function
with opening and closing round brackets
and body of the function
so what we want to write here is we want
to we want this function to return the
value right we want this function to
return this value so we'll
copy it from here
and we'll paste it here
so we want this function to return this
value so we'll write here return instead
of
document.write now this function will
return this string that this cars comes
with a quattro all-wheel drive
so if you want to change this string a
little bit you can change because we
have already
used this string in the previous program
we did so let's suppose
we'll write here
four wheel drive now this will be easier
for you to understand this
so this is what an object looks like our
object is entirely ready what we did
here is we bundled all these things and
coupled them we bundled all these things
we bundled all the three variables we
bundled this function we bundled all of
them together inside a single variable
and now this particular variable car is
an object now if we want to access these
properties of the object like car
manufacturer car model etc whatever
properties we have here so what we have
to do is we have to
use document.write
so it is quite simple so after this
object we'll write here
document
dot write
and to access this object what we have
to do is we have to use the object name
with the dot operator and the property
name so if we want to let's suppose
we'll use here
car dot and the property name will be
car underscore
manufacturer
so here is the syntax the syntax is
quite
easy you can see here we have used the
car object with the dot operator and
then we have the property name whatever
property we want to access
so let's save this program now and see
here it says od by using this dot
operator we can access any property of
the car not just a property we can
access the method as well so if we want
to access the method like if we want to
access this all wheel drive function
we can do it simply by writing here car
dot and we'll write here instead of this
we'll write here all wheel drive and
we are good to go so if we save this now
so here you can see it says
this car comes with four wheel drive so
it is quite easy to access these
properties of an object so we can do it
by using this now suppose we call this
function normally with the
document.write inside the function in
place of return so if we write here
document.write
it's normal like how we normally call a
function so if we write here
document.write inside this function and
we can call this function by the normal
method like if you are calling this
function from outside what we'll do
we'll write here car dot
and the function name
so if we save this now
here you can see the string is printed
on the browser this car comes with four
wheel drive and you can see here we
didn't use any h1 tag or h2 tag so you
can spot the difference right
so that's how you can call the method of
an object from outside this is the
normal way
so now you guys might be wondering what
if we want to add more cars into this we
can copy paste it again to do so and
change the value of properties again it
is the same thing we can do with the
variables so this is where the following
way of creating objects come into the
picture
in which we use something different
known as object constructor that's a bit
different from other object oriented
programming languages so don't worry if
you don't know about it also in the
newer versions
javascript supports the concept of
classes and object
so what we used to say earlier is
javascript is an object oriented
scripting language because it does not
supports the concept of classes and
objects fully but now the scenario has
changed javascript do support the
concept of classes and objects but we'll
keep it a bit simple so let's comment
this code as well
and we'll use this code for reference
so we'll comment this that's why we are
not removing it but we can remove this
piece of code
so let's remove it
and let's
move on to user second way of creating
an object
now we will create multiple objects
using a single template which is known
as a constructor function
let's have a look at the syntax for this
method so we'll write the function
keyword and we have named this function
as cars and in parenthesis we will
provide the
properties as parameters so these are
the properties we have car manufacturer
we have car model and we have car price
so these are the properties which we
used in the previous code as well so
here we have also used these properties
so we'll keep it that way only
now inside a function these parameters
are known as arguments so if we talk
about the naming convention so these
parameters are known as arguments
so let's move on to the body of the
function and inside the body we will use
this keyword here
this keyword refers to the object it
belongs to so here in this program this
will refer to the object basically
so what we are doing here is whenever we
are creating any object using this
constructor function we will pass
specific values like the car
manufacturer car model and the price all
of these values
so all these values will be present at
the rhs so let me write this first let's
say we are using this
dot and the property name car
manufacturer
will write here
car manufacturer
so all these values will be present at
the rhs and the actual property of the
object will be this dot car manufacturer
so this is the actual property of this
method you will understand it much
better when we create the object for now
let's mention here the other two
properties and method as well so
let's
use the other two properties which were
this dot
car model
and
we'll write your car model the last one
was this dot
price
we'll write here price
let's add the method here as well inside
the constructor function we'll use this
keyword again to add the method the
syntax will go like this
we'll use this
dot all wheel drive
and this is a
function so we'll write here function
with the opening and closing round
brackets and then we have the body of
the function
inside the body of this function we will
write
whatever we have written in the previous
program so we'll copy it from here
and we'll paste it here
right so this is a complete constructor
function now using this constructor
function we can create multiple objects
of this car type so this constructor
function works like a template or like
the classes work in other languages like
c plus plus and java
so let's create an object here
so we'll create a variable here let's
say we are creating a variable c1 now
we'll use the new keyword
and along with the
constructor function so we'll use here
cars and we'll pass the values for all
the three properties so here you can say
we have
the car manufacturer is od and next up
we have the
model as
q7 and the price is
50 000.
okay so we have created a variable we
have passed the
values for the properties
and now
if you want to access this function if
we want to access this all wheel drive
function we can access this as well we
have to write here c1 dot all-wheel
drive and
this is how you can call a function
if we save this program see here it says
this car comes with four wheel drive so
if you change anything here let's
suppose we are using here h2tech
if we save this program now see you can
see the change here so we are calling
this function here and this will be
printed on the browser so this string
will be printed on the browser
let's create another variable here let's
say we are using where c2 and the syntax
will be same for this as well we'll
write here new cars and we'll pass the
values here so let's say we are using
bmw
and next up we have the model as
x7
and the price of this car is let's say
40 000 okay 40 000 usd
so
if we want to access any particular
property of any object like if we want
to access the car model or if we want to
access the car manufacturer so we can do
it the same way as we did previously as
we did in the literal object way so
to do so we have to write here
document.write
it was quite simple so we have to write
here the object name dot
and whatever we want to print let's say
we are printing here car model so if we
save this now you can see here x7 is
printed on the browser because x7 is the
value of object c2 and let's suppose if
we want to
print here car manufacturer save it and
see here you can see we have bmw as the
output on a browser
similarly we can access the price as
well let's save it now and see here it
says 40 000 so this is how we can create
multiple objects in javascript we'll
continue with the previous program we
made so
today we will use the literal object way
because this method of creating objects
is a bit easier than the other one we
discussed which was the constructor
function method so here we created the
car object which has three properties
car manufacturer car model and the price
of the car we have a method here as all
wheel drive when we use this method here
we use this method with the dot operator
and we
call that function we call that method
with the help of the object
so the output was this car comes with
four wheel drive so this was something
we did in the previous video
if we talk about objects in javascript a
lot of things we know about in
javascript are basically objects like
the boolean values numbers strings and a
few more so
many of these things can be objects if
we define them with the new keyword
basically any of the data type other
than the null and undefined can be
converted to objects or they have their
equivalent object forms if we define
them with the new keyword
so we have a few predefined objects as
well we have the math object the date
object and the regular expression are
also considered objects in javascript a
lot of things are objects in javascript
we'll use objects in dom manipulation
which we will go through in further
videos so that's why it is pretty
essential to understand the whole
concept of objects right so next up
let's look at how we can use different
data types as objects in javascript
so the syntax for using the basic data
types as objects in javascript goes like
this we'll declare a variable first we
have a variable str1 and next up we'll
write here the new keyword and the data
type so stringer is our data type which
we will be using as objects for now so
this is the complete syntax of how to
use a data type as an object in
javascript if we'll write here str
one and we'll use the dot operator so
here we can see we have the object
methods as well right
so i hope you guys are aware of the
methods present in javascript like we
had the string and array methods right
we have methods for object as well like
the index of method we have seen the use
of index of method when we went through
the string methods in javascript so
similarly we have the font color and the
length property for object as well so
length here is the property and other
which we can see are the methods for
objects in javascript so here this str1
becomes the object by default when we
use the new keyword with the string
while declaring
so there are few ways to determine if a
variable is an object or a primary data
type
so the easiest way to do so is to use
the type of operator
so let's use it here and check the type
of variable str1 we'll write here
document.write
and we'll print the type of this
variable
so we'll use the type of operator and
the type of variable str1
so let me put it inside the h1 tag
so here we have written a type of
operator so let's print this value on
the browser if we save it see here you
can see it says object
if we write a string here in place of
this new string so if we
write here any string let's suppose we
are using a string here let's say we are
using
hello
okay let's save it now and here you can
see the type of this variable str1
changed from object to string so this is
the difference between a primitive data
type it was a string earlier but when we
use it with the new keyword along with
the string
and
this is the basic syntax of how to
define a primitive data type as an
object so if we save it now here you can
see it is converted to object
similarly we can use the other basic
data types as well and
the other predefined objects we talked
about like the date object and the math
object will go through each of them in
separate videos so moving on let's go
back to our car object after we declared
the whole object we defined all the
three properties and the method also
somewhere in the program we realized
that we had missed a particular property
and we realized it after we have written
150 lines of code after this car object
so here you can see we have written here
150 line of code so
i'm not writing 150 lines but let's do
it this way so we realized it after 150
lines
in javascript
we can add a particular property to an
object outside the definition also we
can add a property to an object anywhere
in a program the syntax for that goes
like this
we'll write the
object name
with the property name along with the
dot operator so we'll write here one
more property let's say we are using
car color
and the value of this
property will be let's say
black
right what this line will do is it will
here we are using the same object name
here you can see here the object name is
car and here we have also used the car
object name now we have added one more
property to this object car we can check
it let's print it out on the browser
so what we will do we will write here
document
dot write
so here you can see we have used the
document.write method to print this car
color on our browser so we have used
here car dot car color let's save this
program now and see
here you can see the output is black so
this is the property of the object car
now and if we comment this line let's
say if we are commenting this line
let's save this now and see here you can
see
it says undefined we can add more
properties similarly like if we want to
add another property here we can go like
car dot and the property name whatever
property we want to add let's say we
want to add fuel type
so it can be a petrol car or a diesel
car or an electric car it doesn't matter
so we can add properties as well in fact
we can add methods as well so the syntax
to add method goes like we can add a
method here we'll
see it will go like car dot let's say we
are adding a new function
let's say we are adding the function new
one
equals to and here we will write
function
so the
body of the function now whatever we
want to write inside the function let's
say this function return
function successfully
added
so if we try to call this function from
outside we can do it so let's try to
check out the output for this function
let's say we want to access this
particular function so save it now and
here you can see it says function
successfully added so the new method we
added is the new fun and we added this
method to our pre-existing object which
was the car object so i hope you guys
are aware of how to add a new property
or a new method to an existing object by
now what if we want to delete a
particular object
so it's pretty easy to do so in
javascript we can use the delete keyword
object name and the property name after
the dot operator let's suppose we want
to delete car model here we want to
delete this particular property of the
object car so we what we'll do we'll
delete this car model
so the syntax for it is quite
simple so we'll remove this for now and
we'll delete a property let's say we are
using
the delete keyword with
the object name dot method name or the
property name so we'll delete here
car model right
let's save it now
so this particular line will delete the
car model attribute of this car object
let's check it out and we will print
here the car model so
we'll write here car dot
car underscore model
and
save it now so here you can see it says
undefined and if we try to comment this
line and now if we try to save this
program so here you can see the car
model is q7
so this is how we can delete a
particular property or a particular
method from an object one more thing
before we wrap up this video is as we
all know javascript is a loosely typed
language right so we can change the data
type of these properties on the fly now
we will change the data type of this
property we had the price property right
so we'll change the data type of this
particular property now
we know that the value of the price
property is a number let's change this
number to a string data type what we
have to do is we have to write
so we have to write here car dot
price
and
update the value of here let's say we
are using 70 000 and
we have to put a semicolon it's the same
thing we do to update the value of a
particular variable right so if we try
to print the value of price now we'll
get the output as 70 000. let's try to
print it on the browser so we'll cut it
from here
we'll paste it here and we'll print
car price
save it now see here you can see it says
70 000
if we want to check the type of this
property
what we can do is
we can use the type of operator so we'll
use the type of operator
so this is the syntax of how we can use
the type of operator let's save this now
and see here it says string
earlier it was a number but now it is a
string so all these things can be done
dynamically in a program wherever we
want to do them so that's the benefit of
having objects in javascript we have
been using the
document.getelementbyid method for the
past few videos right
we know it is used to access an html
element with the help of an id which is
uniquely provided to each element
so we used that method with text boxes
then with radio buttons and then with
select boxes as well
so today we are going to use a method
that is somewhat similar to
document.getelementbyid method
so we'll be using the
document.getelementsbytagname method in
javascript
as the name suggests this method is used
to access a bunch of similar elements
with the same tag so we have tag name in
our method right so we can access a
bunch of tags with similar name like if
we have a few div tags present in our
program and we want to change each div
text style
we can do it with the help of this
method so we'll look at the syntax first
and then we'll move on to the difference
between id and tag name method
so let's move on to the programming part
directly
what we'll do is we'll create a few div
tags first and then we'll change the
style of these div tags with specific
styling properties we are not going to
use css for that but in javascript we
have other styling properties as well so
we'll be using those styling properties
so let's create the div text first
we'll write here div
and then let's say we are
writing it this is section
one so we'll copy this line
and we'll create four similar div tags
right
we have section one two three and
four
save it and you can see over here we
have four different sections present
now this is a very basic example and
here we have different sections present
right next up we'll try to access these
div tags with the help of tag name
method so let's add a button over here
and then we'll move on to the javascript
part
so we'll
write here
let's use the br tag and we'll write
here input tag again we'll write a input
type is equals to
button and we'll use the on click method
as well so we'll write here on click
and let's say our function name is
fun2
and then we have the
value of this button as let's say submit
close the input tag and save it so here
you can see we have a button over here
submit button and you can see here
nothing is happening on clicking on the
submit button
so next up what we are going to do is we
are going to add functionality to this
submit button for that we have to move
to our javascript file and we have to
create a function over there
so we'll write here
in the javascript file we'll write here
function
fun2 and then we have the body of this
function right so the syntax is a bit
similar to that of the
document.getelementbyid method what
we'll do is we'll take a variable x and
then we'll write here
document dot
get elements by tag name and then we'll
write inside the brackets the name of
tag we want to access right so here we
have added four different div tags so in
this case we'll write here div and we
can similarly access any of the tags
present in a html document we can access
paragraph tags we can access anchor text
and any tag we want to basically
so save it and here now we have a
variable x that holds an html collection
of all the div text present inside the
html file
this means that we have an array of
references of all the div tags here
inside this variable x
so if we try to make changes in a single
array element just like we did in the
select box example wherein we use the
array index to access a particular
element present at a particular array
index right so we can do the same here
we'll write here x and then we'll write
the
index number so this particular
statement will access the element
present at number 1
or this particular syntax will access
the
first div tag of html document because
we know arrays start from 0
and at 0 the first element will be
present so this div tag will be present
at number 0
and then we are going to use the style
property so we know that
x here is not a variable only actually x
here acts as an object and we know that
different objects have certain
properties in javascript so style is one
of those properties and next up we'll
write here
let's say
font family so what we are doing is we
are doing the css part with properties
present in javascript so let's say we
are changing our font to
courier new
right so this is a font name
and we can use any font name over here
so save it what will happen now is on
clicking the submit button
the font of this particular section the
font of div 1 will change to courier new
so let's try if it's happening or not on
clicking the submit button you can see
over here the change between this line
and other three div tags clearly the
font has changed the new font is courier
new and what we did here is we changed
the font family of this particular div
tag
so similarly we can make more styling
changes to other div tags as well so
let's do it here
and we'll
make changes to each of the div tags we
have in a html file so let's say
here we are using the color property and
we want to change the font color to
blue
fine then we'll do the same for element
present at number three for that we'll
write here x and index number will be
two
so then again we'll use the style
property and then
let's say we are writing a
font
style
fine and the font style we want it to be
italic
and then finally we have one more
property
let's say for a
for the repeat so let's say for the last
div tag we are using the background
color
fine
and we'll write here the color name is
red
so we are good to go now save it and we
have four different properties over here
for section four we are changing the
background color so
three will be the index number of the
last
array variable so save it and on
pressing the submit button you can see
the change over here so for section 1
the font is changed to courier new for
section 2 the font color is blue let me
zoom it out a bit to show you guys you
can see over here the color is blue
and then we have italic text in section
three and finally for section four we
have the background color as four right
so you can see how we are accessing any
particular element of the array now
why we are using these properties
separately for each array element
so if we try to make changes on each
element of the array we simply can't do
it in javascript at once
so if we try to write here so let's
comment this out first what we'll do is
we'll write a x dot style dot font
family so basically what we want to do
is we want to change the font family for
all the div tags present right because
we know the variable x is holding an
array of all the div text present in our
html file right so we'll save it and you
can see over here if we are clicking on
the submit button you can see nothing is
happening so if we go to our console
and you can see it over here that we
have an error here so it says it cannot
set property font family of undefined so
this is the problem with this get
elements by tag name method
to overcome this problem we have a
solution as well so the solution for
this problem is we have to use the for
loop
so how this for loop works
so we'll write here
for
and then we'll take a local variable i
and the initial value will be 0
then we'll write a i
less than
x dot length because we want to traverse
the whole array right and then we'll
write here the condition
i plus plus
so we are good to go then we have this
body of for loop and inside here we'll
write x and the index number will be i
because it will keep on changing and we
are in a loop
so
we'll write here dot style and then
let's say the style we want to
do is font
weight and what we want to do is we want
to make our font bolder fine
so comment this line as well save it now
and you can see over here everything is
clean now what will happen is on
pressing the submit button the font will
change the font weight will change
basically so let me zoom this
and if we click on this submit button
you can see the font is more bolder
right
so if we are using another property here
let's say the font
we are using here
background color and we want the
background color to be yellow
fine so save it and on clicking the
submit button you can see the background
color for all the div tags for all the
four section is changed to yellow fine
so this is how we can access all the
elements of an array at once
now what we did is we
started a loop and traversed every
element in the array and applied the
same property to each element
so this is how we can do it with the
help of
tag name method in javascript
now what if we have hundreds of similar
elements like div tag present in our
website and all of them are present at
different locations so let's try to do
it and what we'll do is we'll insert
certain different elements in between
these div tags
fine so we'll include a form and then
we'll include some radio buttons and
anything we want to do we can do it so
we'll add some more elements in between
these div tags
so here you can see we have inserted
two three more elements and between
these div tags so save it and you can
see after each section we have something
else here we have a form with
two different text boxes we have name
and h and then we have a submit button
as well
then after that we have section 2 so
this is our section 2
then after section 2 we have radio
button and the value is a then we have
another radio button b
and in between we have all the dev text
present so basically what we want to do
is we want to change the style for each
of the div tags right
so we will change the background color
here so let's say we'll write here red
and what will happen is on clicking the
submit button on clicking this submit
button what will happen is the
background color of each div tag
so the background color for section 1 2
3 and 4 will change to red so let's try
to do it and let's see if it's
working or not so we'll click on this
submit button and you can see it over
here we have all the div tags with
background color as
red so this is working totally fine
one more thing we'll discuss before
wrapping up this video is the uniqueness
of id attribute for each element
so we are saying this for a long time
that the id for each element should be
unique why so
although we saw in the past videos that
we can use the same id for two different
elements when we did the same for
accessing a css styling property using
the id attribute but if we try to do the
same thing with javascript we'll get an
error for example if we try to access
the value of any particular element with
the id attribute
but we have two elements in a html file
with the same id so it will throw an
error in that case basically and this is
the reason why we use the tag name
method in javascript so that if we want
to access multiple elements of the same
name we can do it with this method
because it's not possible to use the id
method separately for each element
present in the html document right
because we have certain same html tags
present within an html document like we
have the div tags here similarly a
website is long enough to have multiple
similar elements present within it so
that's why we use the
document.getelements
document.getelementsbytagname method in
javascript so guys in the past few
videos we use two different methods of
accessing an element from an html file
using javascript properties so we know
the difference between the id method and
the tag name method right today we will
use another method to access a
particular element in javascript that is
the class name method or we can say the
get elements by class name method in
javascript so before discussing the
class name method in javascript
let's look at why accessing an element
is important in javascript
so we know that the document object
model is used to change
add or delete html elements we saw
earlier that we could change html
elements or the css style of any element
in the document with the help of
javascript properties
so to make specific changes to those
elements we need to access them using
particular methods so we discussed two
such methods before the id method and
the tag name method right so let's move
ahead and look at the class name method
of accessing an element in javascript as
the name suggests the main attribute in
this method will be the class name so we
know the difference between the class
and the id attribute used in html
we know that id has to be unique for
each element but we know that many
elements in an html document can have
the same class right so we used class to
access specific css properties in the
previous videos
and that is the only benefit of using
classes in javascript so we can say that
a single class can be used by many
elements within an html document so
let's dig a bit deeper into this concept
so let's say we have five elements
present on our website and we want to
make changes in three of these elements
right so let's write the code here and
it will be easier for you guys to
understand so we'll write here in the
html file we'll add five different
elements
so let's say we are writing here
div and
then inside this div we'll write
this is
section one
we'll copy this
we'll paste it here
so we'll use two div elements and two
paragraph element right so here in this
p tag we'll write
this is
section three
and then we'll copy this line
paste it again copy this one as well and
paste it here
so we have section one section two three
four and
five
so out of these five different
elements we have three div tags and we
have two paragraph text so we'll discuss
why we have taken two paragraph text in
between the
div tags
so we are done with it here you can see
we have five elements present in our
html document three of them are the div
text section one two and five are div
text
and two texts in between are the
paragraph text so now
let's suppose we want to change the
style of three of these elements let's
say one four and five so we can do it in
two ways right either we can use the id
method or we can use the class method
however we can use the tag name method
as well but
we have to use two different variables
for that right that will be a lengthy
process
why two different variables because we
have two different tags present here
right we have to create separate
variable for the div tag and separate
one for the paragraph text so that will
be a lengthy process so we'll consider
id method and the class name method for
here so considering the id method the
document.getelementbyid method we have
to provide a unique id to each element
so we have to provide unique id to this
div tag then we have to provide to each
and every element here right
because we need to access
three of these elements so at least we
have to provide the id to those three
elements which we want to access right
so in such cases we can use the class
name method where we want to access more
than one element but not all the
elements in an html file
so we'll use the class attribute in each
element we want to access
so let's say we want to access section 1
2 and 5.
so we'll write a class let's say the
class name is cls1
we'll copy this paste it here and we are
accessing one two and four because one
two and five are
the div text so we can access these with
the help of tag name method as well so
we'll access one two and four
fine so we have used the class attribute
here
next up we'll create a button and then
we'll add functionality to a html
document so let's create a button here
we'll again use input type is equals to
button and then we have
on click
and on clicking it will call
funk one
and then we have the value as
submit fine
so save it
and here you can see
in the browser we have five sections
over here we have section one two three
four and five then we have a submit
button which will call the function
on clicking so we haven't added
functionality till now so let's move
ahead to our javascript file and we'll
add functionality to a
html document
so inside this javascript file we'll
write here
function and then we have the function
name is
function
then we have the body of this function
so the syntax remains a bit same
so we'll take a variable first and then
we'll use the document method to take
references of all the elements from a
html file
so we'll write here
where x is equals to
document dot
get elements by
class name right and then we'll write
the class name here so the class name is
cls1
till now what we did was we took the
references of all the required elements
and stored them inside a variable named
x in the form of an html collection so
now we can make changes to these
elements and what we'll do is we'll
again use the style property to make
styling changes in those three sections
so we have these three sections present
inside an array and we can access any
one or all the three elements right so
we'll write here x and then we'll
provide the index number so let's say we
want to access section 1 that is the
first div tag so we'll provide the index
number as 0
then we'll write dot
tile
and this style is a property dot
then let's say we want
to
change the font style so we'll write
here
font
style
font style will be
italic
save it so this piece of code will
change the font style of the element
present at index 0. save it and on
clicking the submit button here on the
browser
we can see the change in this section
right so if it's not visible so let me
zoom it a bit for you here you can see
guys the font at section 1 is changed to
italic right so in this case we have all
the three elements present in a array
and we can make changes to each of these
elements so let's try to do it and we'll
use element present at index 1 now
we'll copy this line and we'll paste it
here again two times because we want to
make changes to all the elements right
we'll write it two and we'll write here
one
and let's say
we want to change the font color for
this one and the font color will be blue
for this we will change the font weight
let's say
and we want to make it
bolder
so we'll write here bolder
save it and on clicking the submit
button you can see we have all the three
sections with some minor changes the
first one is changed and we have italic
over here for the second one we have
blue color as font color and for the
third one which is section four we have
the
font weight as bolder so you can see the
change over here so this is how we can
make change to each element separately
and we can also make changes in all the
elements at once as well so for that we
have to use the for loop
just like we did for the tag name method
right
so for that we'll write here so let's
comment these three statements first
and then we'll write here
for and
it will take a local variable here we'll
write you where
i is equals to 0 i will start from index
0 and i will go till
x dot
length
and then we have the condition is i plus
plus
so inside the body of for loop we'll
write here
x and
instead of index number we'll write here
i because we want to traverse the whole
array then we'll write here style
dot
and let's say the style we want is
background
color we want the background color to be
let's say
yellow
fine
so this is how we can use the for loop
save it and we'll see on clicking the
submit button on our browser
the background color for all the three
sections that is 1 2 and 4 is changed to
yellow
this is how we can use the
document.getelementsbyclassname method
to access all the elements present in an
html file with a particular class next
up let's discuss the difference between
the id method tag name method and the
class name method
so we'll discuss when to use which
method so
let's start with the id method so the id
method is used when we want to access a
single element and we have to provide a
unique id to that element in order to
access it so the id method is quite
useful when we want to work on a single
element
apart from that if we want to work on
more than one element we have two other
methods
we can either use the class name method
or the tag name method for more than one
element
so the tag name method is also quite
useful when we want to access elements
with the same tag name
we can access all the similar tags
present within an html document with the
help of tag name method the only problem
is we can access similar types of tags
only at one time we can't access two
different types of tags with this method
so this is where the class name method
comes into play we can access more than
one element with this method and the
elements can be different just like we
did here we had
div tag and paragraph tag right so
the section 1 2 and 5 are from div text
and the section 4 and 3 are from the
paragraph text so we can access two
different tags with same class name with
the help of class name method in
javascript so with this we came to the
conclusion that more than one element in
the html file can have the same class
and can be accessed with the class name
method so by now i hope you guys
understood the concept of all the three
methods which we have discussed
the
id method the tag name method and the
class name method in javascript we can
use any of these methods according to
our needs
the word promise seems a bit familiar we
make promises regularly right if i say i
promise you that will cover everything
on promises in this video now this
promise that i made can only have two
possible outcomes either the promise
will be fulfilled or resolved or we can
say the promise can be failed or
rejected the promise will be resolved if
we'll cover everything on promises in
this video but if i left out some topic
or there is any sub topic within
promises which we forgot to cover in
this video that will be a failed promise
or we can say a rejected one
now there is another term in between
these terms that is pending pending is
the time in which the system works on
the promise
so just remember these terms as you may
hear them during an interview so let's
move on talking about a proper
definition of promises we can say that a
promise is an object which will produce
value sometimes it either gives us a
value or an error with the proper reason
there is no specific definition for
promises in javascript you will
understand the topic much better while
working on the syntax
so let's move ahead and we'll go through
a simple example first to understand a
promise in javascript
as we mentioned earlier that a promise
is an object so what we have to do first
is to take a variable and declare an
object so for that we'll go to a
javascript file and we'll write here
we'll take a variable let's say a
variable name is prom and we'll write
here new
promise so this statement here is a
promise we have an object named prom
next up this promise will take a
callback function we have already
discussed the concept of callback
functions in the previous video so if
you haven't watched that video yet i
recommend you to watch it so a callback
function is a function passed to another
function as an argument remember so
we'll write here
inside this
object we'll write here
function
and now this callback function here will
have two arguments one to resolve and
another for the reject that's because we
can have only two possibilities in a
promised right either it can be rejected
or it can be resolved so we'll write
here
resolve and then after a comma we'll
write here reject fine then we'll have
the body of this function
so this is how a promise will look like
you can change the name of these
arguments instead of resolve or reject
you can write here anything but we have
kept it simple for now so that it will
be easy to understand next up let's use
a simple condition here let's take the
example of driving a car fine
what we'll do is we'll take a variable
drive
and we'll check if the user learned how
to drive a car if yes then the promise
is fulfilled otherwise the promise is
rejected
so let's do it here we'll write here
where
drive
and let's set the value of this drive as
true for now let's say the user learned
how to drive a car
so next up what we'll do is we'll use
the if else conditional statement to
call any one of the two functions we can
either call resolve or reject right so
we'll write a if
and the condition will be
drive so if we left it with drive here
it will check for if drive is equals to
true right so we'll call the function
resolve if the condition holds true
and then we'll use the else statement
for else we'll write it else and then
we'll write here
reject
fine
any value other than true will call the
reject function here so what we did here
was an easy task we know that the value
for the variable drive is true so in
this case the resolve function will be
called if we set this value of variable
drive to false
then the function reject will be called
the next part of the program is to
execute this promise so this will be the
longer part as we have to use two
methods here so for that the syntax will
start with the promise name and then
we'll use the dot operator so let me do
it here we'll write here
prom and then we'll use the dot operator
next up we'll use the then keyword so
this then keyword or
it is a method actually
it is called when the method is resolved
or when the promise is resolved so we
have another method for the rejection of
promises that we'll discuss afterwards
so we'll write here
prompt dot then
now this is a method so we will use
brackets here
when this method is called it means that
the promise is resolved we'll use a
callback function within this method so
we'll write here
function and
then we'll use
the resolve function here so we'll write
here
resolve fine
and then we'll have the body for resolve
so
this is how the execution will look like
for promises and on filling the promise
there will be a statement printed on the
console
so it will be like we'll write here
console.log
and we'll write here something so let's
say we are writing here
resolve
and
let's say
the user
knows how to
drive fine so we'll write here this
now we are done with the part in which
the promise will be fulfilled one thing
i forgot to mention here is we have to
pass
this resolve here so whatever value
we'll write here will be shown in
console so let's say we are writing here
for true value we'll write here yes
fine now if we save this program and
check for the output we'll get the
output as yes the user knows how to
drive we can check it so let's save it
and here you can see in the console we
have the output as yes the user knows
how to type let me put a space here so
let's save it now now it's clearly
visible so it says yes the user knows
how to try
so this is working fine now the next
part will be for the condition if the
promise gets rejected so just like we
had
the then method for resolving the
promise similarly we have one more
method for the rejection part
so for the rejection part we have the
catch method so we have to change this
method here only after the then method
so we'll come here and will write
dot catch
and the rest of the syntax will remain
same so we'll write here function
and then we'll
call
reject
then we'll have the body of this reject
part and we'll write here inside this
console.log
and we'll write here reject
plus
the user
does not
know
how
to drive
fine the catch method uses the reject
function and the output will be no the
user does not know how to drag so before
that we'll have to pass an argument here
so we'll write here
no
and save it now so for now it says yes
the user knows how to drive
to check for the reject method we have
to set the value of variable drive as
false so let's change the value here
let's say we are using
false here now save it and you can see
here the output says no the user does
not know how to drive
fine so this is working totally fine now
you guys might be thinking that this
program we just did is so easy we could
have done it with if else conditional
statements then why are we using
promises for this the syntax is extended
and we have to remember a lot of terms
and methods for a promise right
the good part is this was just an
example to make you understand the
syntax of promises in javascript
next up we'll go through an example
wherein we'll discuss the dependency of
promises as well so let's move ahead and
in this example what we'll do is we'll
create three separate functions let's
suppose we want to learn promises in
javascript
but for that we must know about the
concept of functions and callback
functions in javascript then only we can
go through promises so what we'll do is
we'll create three functions in which
the current function will depend upon
the previous function if the user knows
about functions he can go through
callback functions and if the user knows
both functions and callback functions he
is good to go for promises
so let me take you through the code guys
so here is the code we have three
functions the first one is for functions
topic so this functions is the topic
similarly we have callback and promises
as well so the first function is for the
functions topic and
if the user is done with functions in
javascript then he can move on to
callback functions and then to promises
so we have three different promises for
each function right so each function
here like the first function returns a
promise
right similarly all the three functions
are returning a promise here we are
directly resolving it we don't need to
wait for the user to learn functions
completely otherwise we can use here the
reject function as well
for now we are just resolving it
which means that the user learned
functions in javascript already the same
goes for callback functions and promises
as well
next up what we have to do is we have to
execute the promise that once the user
is done with functions he can move on to
callback functions and then to promises
so for that we have to execute promise
like this only
but the syntax will be different so let
me show you guys
so here is the code for that as well
what we did here is we use the first
function here
so functions is our first function and
on resolving we call the function
callback with the result and we did the
same thing again for a callback on
resolving the callback function it will
call the promises function and finally
it will print this good to go message on
the console with the previous messages
returned by the resolve method
so we are basically working on the
dependency of promises in javascript
now let's save this program and we'll
check the output on the console so
save it and here you can see it on the
console it says
good to go and then it says learned
functions learnt callback functions good
to go for promises in javascript
now this same program can be done with
the help of callback functions as well
but the code will be so confusing
because we have to nest all these
functions inside a single function and
then it will be a mess right the code
with promises is clean you can see here
the code is clean all we had to do here
was to create functions then return
promises on call and then we can execute
those promises with their dependency
so this is how promises in javascript
now we have been using functions in
almost every video since we came across
this topic whether it be
dom manipulation or using an event in
javascript functions are everywhere
right
so this concept of arrow functions
is just a change in the syntax of
declaring and defining a function
so let's go through the concept of
functions in javascript quickly so that
it will be easy to change the syntax
later what we'll do is we'll create a
function with multiple parameters and
then we'll create another function with
no parameter at all
so we know these concepts already so
let's write the code here
so we'll go to a javascript file
and we'll write code here so we'll write
a function
let's say the function name is function
and then this function have two
parameters a and b
now this function will return something
so we'll write here return
let's say this returns a plus
b
fine now the code we wrote here is to
find the sum of two numbers right we'll
pass the two numbers as arguments while
calling the function so let's check on
the console once if the code is working
fine or not so we'll save it
go back to the browser go to inspect
and then we'll go to a console and we'll
write here
function name and then we'll pass
certain parameters right so let's say
the parameters we are passing are 15 and
25
so the output we are expecting is 40 and
the output is correct we have the output
as 40 you can see here we have the
output as 40 here
so this function is working totally fine
next up we'll create another function
first and then we'll move to the arrow
function syntax so for the second
function we'll write a
function let's say the function name is
funct2
and this function will have no
parameters at all right so let's say
this function prints something on the
console right so we'll write a
console.log and then
let's say this
function prints
welcome to simply code
we are done with it so let's do one
thing we will call this function here
we'll write a function calling the
function is pretty easy we can do the
same thing here as well so let's save it
and check the output here you can see we
have the output as welcome to simply
code in our console
so this is how we were using functions
till now the simple syntax for functions
right so let's move on to the concept of
arrow functions
now this function over here has two
parameters right this function has
parameters a and b
and what we'll do is we'll change the
syntax of this function and the new
syntax will be more simple once you get
used to it so let's write the newer
syntax just below the previous one we
don't need the function keyword with
arrow functions so all we have to do is
we have to take a variable so let's do
it first so let's say we have a variable
where
arrow one fine so this is a variable
this statement is simple we have a
variable named arrow
and this will be the function name so
arrow 1 will be the function name as
well right when we use the function
keyword in traditional syntax of
functions it automatically creates a
variable with the function name here we
have to declare the variable by
ourselves next up we have two parameters
here a and b as you can see here we have
a and b
we'll write the parameters within
parenthesis now so what we have to do is
we have to write
parameters so let's say the parameters
are a and b for this function as well
so these are the parameters we have to
write them within parenthesis
now we'll use an arrow that actually
makes this variable a function now this
is the main concept to create an arrow
what we have to do is we have to write
equals to and
then we have to write this so this is
the arrow mark which makes this whole
statement a function
and then we'll write the body of the
function so the body of function will
remain same so we'll copy the body from
here
and we'll paste it here so this function
here this function arrow one here is the
same as function func one and the output
will be the same
this arrow function here has only one
line here so the advantage provided by
arrow functions in this case is quite
help
what we can do is we can make this
function a one-liner if we remove this
return keyword and the curly braces here
so we can remove these curly braces as
well what we have to do is we have to
make this function a one liner right so
there will be no difference now so this
is how the arrow function for this
traditional function looks like now both
the functions will return the sum of two
numbers the only difference is in syntax
let's check the output for the arrow
function as well so what we'll do here
is
we'll save this program
and we'll
go to a console so let's do one thing
we'll call func one first and the
parameters let's say are
5 and 15
and then we'll call the arrow function
with the same parameters so we'll write
here arrow
5 comma 15
now
we have the output as 20 in both the
cases right so these two functions are
working similarly these two functions
are same the only difference is in the
syntax
next up we have another simple function
here and what we want to do here is to
convert this traditional function into
an arrow function right now we are
talking about function functo so let me
comment this first function here what
we'll do is we'll comment this and now
we are good to go
so we have function functo here now what
we'll do is we'll create an arrow
function for this function
so we'll write here
let's say we are writing here where
arrow 2
and then we have no parameters so empty
parenthesis and then we have
the arrow
operator so the body will remain the
same we'll copy the body from this
function
and we'll paste it here
now we have used empty parenthesis here
because we don't have any arguments here
let's try to run this code we'll call
the function here only so
for this we have to write here
arrow two and we are good to so save it
and the output we are expecting is
welcome to simply code twice because we
are calling funct2 as well right so save
it
and here you can see the output is
welcome to simply code let's change
something here so what we'll do is for
arrow function we'll write here
simply learn
fine
so save it now and here you can see we
have the output as welcome to simply
code and welcome to simplylearn let me
zoom it for you if it's not visible so
here you can see the first output for
funct2 it says welcome to simply code
and for arrow 2 it says welcome to
simply learn
that's working fine
now before we wrap up this video let me
tell you another benefit of using arrow
functions so we already discussed that
we don't need to use the return keyword
if we are writing a one-liner function
similarly if we have a single parameter
we don't need any parenthesis we'll
create another function here so let's
say we are writing here
where
arrow 3
and let's say it has only a single
parameter as new name
fine
then we'll
use the arrow operator and then inside
the body of this we'll write here
console.log
and then we'll write here
here there
plus the name provided by us in the
argument so
now we are good to go this function here
will give us the output as hey there and
then whatever name will pass while
calling the function so let's check it
let's call this function as well so
let's say
we are writing here arrow 3 and
the name let's say will be
caution
save it and here you can see it says hey
there caution for arrow function 3 so
this is also working fine
and i hope you guys are now clear with
the arrow functions in javascript it's
not essential to use arrow functions
everywhere but now that we are clear
with promises and callback functions it
will be good to write minimum code and
arrow function will help you with that
now have you guys ever heard about
validation or pattern matching in
javascript we come across these terms
when we hear about passwords mostly
right
so we say that we can use the if else
statement to match if the user's
password matches with the one we already
have for that we write if password is
equal to is equals to some sort of
string or characters
and then we see if the password matches
will let the user enter otherwise the
entry will be denied so we are
discussing all that because regular
expressions are objects used to perform
pattern matching or if we want to search
for something in a string or even if we
want to replace something from a string
we can do it all with regular
expressions
so we'll go through the syntax for
regular expressions and some more
important things about regular
expressions in javascript so regular
expressions are present in almost every
programming language it's not limited to
javascript only and the concept remains
the same everywhere the syntax may
differ a bit between different languages
but the logic behind them will always be
the same the name might be a little bit
confusing but
the reality is entirely different they
are pretty easy to use and if you
understand the basics clearly you will
face no problem while working on
advanced topics
so let's go through the regular
expressions before we move on to
validations using regular expressions in
javascript so let's understand the
concept
entirely so that it will be easy for you
guys in further videos so consider a
scenario where we have a string and we
want to find a particular word in that
string or we can say we are in a static
website i hope you guys are aware of the
term static where we have the search
option to find some word in the entire
html document we have to write the word
in the search box and it will return as
the location of that word in the html
file or in the website
right what we'll do now is we'll use a
word and we'll find that word in a
string we'll make some changes to that
word with the help of several functions
used along with regular expressions in
javascript so the syntax for regular
expressions goes like this we'll move to
a javascript file and we'll take a
variable here so let's say the variable
is where
rejects
and we use two forward slashes for it
generally we use the double slash for
comments but it will be recognized as a
regular expression in javascript if we
write something inside these double
slashes so let's say we are writing
something here let's say we write here
hello now
this word hello is present inside the
variable rejects and this word needs to
be searched in a string
so let's use a string as well so for
that we'll write here
where let's say the string name is str1
let's say we are writing here
welcome
to our
youtube
channel
full stop
say hello
if
you are new here
fine so let's say this is the string we
have
now this string contains the word hello
in it all we have to keep in mind is to
add the main keyword in the string for
now
moving ahead what we want to do is we
want to find this word in the string
right we want to find this hello world
in this string
so next up we'll go through certain
essential functions which we use with
regular expressions and we'll see the
functioning of these essential functions
the first function is the exact function
so let me write here guys
this is the first function exec
function
now this function returns an array if
the word is present in this string
otherwise it will return null if the
word is not present in the string the
syntax is pretty straightforward all we
have to do is to use the exact function
with the variable that contains the
regular expression now in this case the
word rejects contains the regular
expression we have to use it with the
function and the string name will be
passed as a parameter to this function
so
let's write the syntax here and it will
be easy for you guys so let's comment it
out
and we'll write here let's say we are
taking another variable where output
will write here the
variable name
dot function name will write here exec
and the string will be passed as a
parameter fine
so this is the syntax now this output
variable over here will have an array
and the array will return the index
number of the word hello industry
fine so let's print this array on the
console and we'll write here
console.log
output fine
save it and open the console so we will
move to a browser and we'll open console
here
see here we have an array and if we
click on this array we can see that we
have
the word hello at index 36 so if we
count from here and the counting should
start from 0 because array index always
starts from 0 so at index 36 we can find
that hello is over here and so it will
return the index of this particular word
now
if we write here something else other
than hello let's say we are writing here
2 save it now and you can see here we
have 2 present at index 8 so if we count
from here we can see that 2 is present
at index 8 so this is working totally
fine now another scenario is if we write
here 2 with a capital t save it now and
you can see here the output is null
why so because regular expressions in
javascript are case sensitive case
sensitive means it differentiates
between the capital letters and small
letters fine
but the good part is we can make them in
case sensitive as well so all we have to
do is we have to use a modifier a
modifier is actually used to make
modifications in the search so what we
have to do is we have to write here in
the beginning we have to write a single
letter and in this case we'll write here
i because this modifier will tell the
system that there will be no problem
with the case sensitivity of the word
now
it will work fine and if we save this
program
we can see we have the output as index 8
now if we change this string and will
write here something other than this so
we'll write here h e
l o but
the three letters of this word are
capital letters
so save it now and you can see we have
the output as
index 36 so this is working fine now one
last situation is if we write here more
than one hello in a single string so if
we write here hello and welcome to our
youtube channel now there are two hello
words present in a single string save it
and you can see we have the word hello
at index 0 so it will return the first
hello world in the string now if we want
to get access of the second hello and
for if we write here this piece of code
again what we are expecting is we are
expecting it
to give us the index of second hello as
well but it will not happen save it and
you can see it will give the index of
first hello twice you can see here we
have index as 0 in both the areas right
so it will not work
now the solution to this problem is
modifiers again what we have to do is we
have to use another modifier here now we
have to write here the letter g and save
it
now this is returning null because we
have
the string wrong here so we have to
write here hello because we have removed
the in case sensitive modifier save it
now and you can see
we have both the hello words with
indexes as 0 and 46 respectively so this
global modifier tells the system that
the word is now global and if you find
the word once and the user tries the
exact function again then the second
time you should return the index value
of the second word
so this is how it actually works now the
following function we are going to
discuss is a pretty simple one the test
function
now this function returns either true or
false nothing else
this function checks for a particular
word that if the word exists in a string
then it will return true otherwise false
it will not return the index value or
some sort of other things
it deals with the boolean value only
that is true or false so that's it for
the function let's see how this function
work
actually so what we'll do is we'll
mention here this test function
and will
comment this piece of code
so that there will be no
confusion
we'll comment it out
now we'll go through the syntax of this
test function the syntax is pretty easy
we'll use the output variable again
and we'll write here
variable name dot function name and the
string name will be passed as a
parameter
now the next thing we'll do is we'll
write here console.log
and we'll print this on a
console
fine so this is the syntax for test
function save it
and here you can see in the console that
for the word hello it returns true if we
change this word here to something else
like if we write here hi instead of
hello
save it and you can see the output is
changed to false because high is not
there inside a string right because high
does not exist according to this history
so this is how the test function
actually work now one more thing i want
to mention here about the test function
is if we write here some part of a word
not the whole word but some part so
let's say if we write here
e l
now this is the part of hello world now
what if we save this you can see the
output here is true that's because the
test function checks for every letter
and if it finds these three letters in
any word it will return true in that
case as well fine next up we have
another function to use with the regular
expressions in javascript now the next
function's name is match function
i'll write it here
first i'll commend these two statements
and then i'll write here the name of
this function so the name is match
now this match function returns an array
of results otherwise null the syntax for
this function is exactly opposite from
the previous functions
because we'll pass the regular
expression as a parameter to this
function now and the function will be
used along with the string
so
it is completely opposite to
the syntax we used for the previous two
functions so we'll write here for this
we'll use the output variable again
we'll write here where output
and
instead of rejects we'll use it with
this string so we'll write here
str1.match
and
the variable name will be passed as a
parameter fine
so this is how the syntax for match
function looks like it's exactly
opposite to the syntax we used for
previous two functions the next line
will remain the same we'll write here
console.log and we'll print
output on a screen fine now we have to
do one more thing here what's that is we
have to remove this modifier from here
and we have to write here
hello
so save it and you can see we have an
array over here now what if we want to
find both the words in a string if we
have if we want to check if there's more
than one word with the similar name so
what we have to do is we have to write
here g and if you save it now you can
see the output is completely changed and
now we have an array with two similar
words what if we add another hello here
so let's say we have another hello here
save it and you can see here the array
size is increased to 3 now now we are
left with one more method and the method
we are going to discuss now is pretty
important because we'll use this method
in future as well so the last method is
the replace method which is used to
replace something from a string we can
either replace the first matching word
or all the matching words from a string
if we are using the global modifier then
all the words will be replaced otherwise
the first matching word will be replaced
so the syntax for this method goes like
this
what we have to do is so let's comment
it out first
and we'll go through the syntax of final
method so the final method is
replace method
fine
so the syntax goes like this we'll use
the output variable again
and we'll write here
str1
dot replace because we want to replace
something in that particular string the
first parameter will be the
variable name we'll write here regex
comma and then we'll pass
the word we want to change so hello will
be changed with let's say in this case
hi
fine
now check over here that if we are using
any modifier so we are using global
modifier here
now if we print this on our console if
we write a console.log and
we are writing here output
if we save it now we'll get to know that
all the hello words in the string are
replaced with the word hi
save it and you can see over here that
hi and welcome to a youtube channel say
hi if you are new here and then we have
a hi you can see that all the hello
words are replaced with the word hi
now if we remove this global modifier
from here and if we save it now you can
see only the first hello world is
replaced the other hello worlds are here
and there will be no change in them
because we are not using the global
modifier now in the previous video where
we came across regular expressions in
javascript we saw different predefined
functions that we use for finding a
particular expression present inside a
string right
like the predefined functions we also
have some javascript characters that
make the searching part easy
so these characters are used within the
expressions and help us in different
ways for example let's consider a
scenario where we have a regular
expression and we want to find a
particular word within the string
but we don't remember the whole word
let's say we forgot the word with time
and now we remember only a part of that
word so let's do the same side by side
and what we'll do is we'll go to our
javascript file
and we'll take three variables
we'll write here let regex is equals to
then we'll write here let str1 is equals
to
and then finally we'll write
where output is equals to
fine
now here we have three variables the
variable regex will store a regular
expression within it we haven't returned
the word yet next up we have a variable
str1 to store the string and a variable
output to store the output returned by a
function the function will use will be
any one of the ones we used in the
previous video so let's do it here the
word let's say
the word will be
welcome fine
you can take any word you want now
moving on to the string let's write the
string as well we'll write here welcome
to our youtube
channel and then we'll write another
welcome here
fine
we'll discuss the reason why we wrote
welcome twice now if you guys remember
from the previous video where we have
used the test function to check the
availability of a word present in a
string or not we'll use the same
function again so we'll write here
variable name
dot
function name so the function name is
test and then we'll pass the string name
as the parameter so we'll write here
str1
that's fine
and finally what we'll do is we'll
print this on our console so we'll write
a console.log
output fine now we already know the
output for this piece of code right the
output will be true that's obvious
because we have the word welcome present
in our string not once but twice the
output will remain true if we remove the
first welcome from the string let's do
it here let's save the program first and
then we'll move to the console
and you can see here the output says
true for the word welcome present in the
string str1 that's true right
and now if we remove this welcome word
from here and if we save it you can see
the output still remains true because we
have another welcome word present in the
string right
so this is how the test function
actually works we will put the welcome
word here again we already know the
functioning of this test function the
main point of discussion here is the
meta characters so metacharacters are
characters with special meanings
like the dot character if we write this
regular expression like we can remove
any one character from this word and put
a dot in its place let's do it
we'll remove a random character and
write dot m so let's say
we are removing
l
fine and instead of l we are putting a
dot here
now the dot character here will replace
this character and the system will not
throw any error
it will still find the word we can also
use exact function here to check the
index number of the word so what we'll
do is we'll take another variable
and we'll do the same we'll write here
rejects dot
exec
and then we'll pass the string name as
parameters
fine
we'll copy this console.log from here
and we'll paste it here
the variable name is op
save it
and here you can see
we have the output as true for the test
function and for the exact function it
returns the index number 0 of the word
in the string now the system
automatically puts a l in place of the
dot character similarly if you want to
do the same thing for more than one
character we have another meta character
for that it's not that we can't use this
dot operator but we can use it for a
limited time like we can use it for a
single character but if we want to put
more than one character and we don't
know the number of the characters so
then we have another meta character for
that the meta character is asterisk
now this asterisk allows us to put
multiple characters within a particular
expression for example if we write here
let's remove all this
and we'll put star or asterisk in place
of all the characters in between so save
it and you can see the output returns
true
for
test function and for the exact function
the index is
0
now if we write here something like that
and we don't know what it is but let's
assume it so if we save it now you can
still see the output returns true for
this as well
because
now we can put any number of characters
in between w and e the only thing that
matters is the first and the last
character of the word welcome
now the next character will be looking
at does not work the same way as these
characters the carrot character works
upon a whole string let's go through the
syntax and what we'll do is
we'll remove this unwanted piece of code
and then we'll come here we'll write
here
welcome again
and now we'll put this carrot character
now the carrot character is this
character so
what this character returns is this
character returns true only if the whole
string starts with the word welcome the
second welcome word does not even exist
for this meta character if we save this
program now it will return true because
welcome is present at the start of this
string right so save it
and you can see the output is
true now if we remove this welcome from
here
and if we save this program now we know
that we have another welcome present in
the string but this character does not
work
that way
and it will return false because the
string starts with 2 now right
save it and here you can see the output
is false for test function and for exact
function the output is null it will not
return any index number of the second
welcome or some sort of thing so this is
how the caret character works in
javascript
the next meta character does the same
thing but for the end of the string the
symbol is dollar and it checks for the
end part of the string this meta
character is placed at the end of a
regular expression and it checks if the
string ends with characters present in
the expression the syntax goes like this
what we'll do is we'll remove this
carrot character and we'll put a dollar
sign you
now this statement now will check if the
string ends with the word welcome or not
in this case the last word of the string
is
back right not welcome so the output
will be false save it
save it and you can see here the output
is false and null
suppose we write here back in place of
welcome now what we'll do is we'll write
here
back in place of welcome and if we save
this program now the output will change
to true because back is the last word
present in a string right so this
character checks for the end of the
string
save it and you can see the output is
changed to true and the index number is
32
when the exact function will return the
index number of the word back the last
meta character we will discuss in this
video is the optional meta character
the question mark symbol represents this
meta character and the functioning be
like
any character before the symbol is
treated as optional
this means that it doesn't matter if the
character is present in the string or
not for example
if we write here let's say
we'll
write here welcome again because welcome
has more characters than back and will
write here
welcome as well
fine
now let's make some changes in this
particular rejects expression so what
we'll do is we'll put a question mark
here
and let's say we'll put another question
mark here fine now if we remove c and e
from the string or any one of them then
also the function will work fine and the
output will be true let's do it and what
we'll do is we'll make some changes in
this particular string and we are going
to remove some characters from this
string so we have two welcome words
there and what we'll do is we'll remove
c from this one
and we have two optional characters
right both c and e are optional but for
now we are removing c only so the string
looks like this we have the word vellum
it doesn't mean anything but for
understanding purposes we have done it
so save it and you can see the output
remains true for vellum
now
what if we put any other word in place
of this character
let's say we are writing here b
fine
the output will change we have to put an
os
because o is not an optional character
now the output
will change
as we were discussing if we save this
program you can see it says true for now
but it is saying true because of this
welcome now if we remove this welcome
from here and if we save it now you can
see the output is changed to null
yes these characters are optional but we
can't put any character in place of them
we have two options only either we can
put c in its place or we can leave it
so there's no other option with the
optional characters so these are the few
meta characters present in regular
expressions which helps in validation a
lot we came across meta characters in
regex in the previous video where we saw
how to check the availability of a
particular word or expression within a
string we know about functions as well
so today we will combine all these
things to some extent and we'll see how
basic validation actually works in
javascript
we'll see an example wherein we'll go
through the character sets and ranges
and check for some specific type of
validation in this video
now the topic character sets and ranges
itself is a pretty explanatory topic and
we can get an idea of what's coming just
by going through the words characters in
layman term refers to alphabets and
numbers right we see a character on a
daily basis and we know a lot about them
now if i write here a
we can say that this is a character in
javascript now we can use one single
character or a group of characters at a
time with regular expressions in
javascript we have a particular syntax
for it we'll go through the syntax first
and the syntax is like we have to use
square brackets and we have to write
characters in between these brackets or
inside these brackets
here we have three characters a b and c
what we can do is we can give
instructions to the system to use any
one of them in a regular expression
so let's take a small example of how
this actually works with regular
expressions and what we'll do is we'll
do the same thing we have been doing
till now we'll search a word within a
string we'll check that if a word exist
within a string or not so we'll do it
like we'll take a variable regex
that will contain the regular expression
so this is
the syntax for regular expression and
this is a regular expression which says
d e f so in actual this is not a word
but assume it as a word for now and what
we have to do is we have to include
character sets with this regular
expression right so we'll write here
inside square brackets abc
now the next thing is we'll define the
string let's say the string name is tr1
and the string says
this string contains adef
so def
or we can say adf is what matters the
most for now so anything else you can
write on the string the next thing we
are going to do is we are going to
use the test function to check if this
particular regular expression
is available in the string or not so
we'll write here regex dot
test and inside this will pass the
string as a parameter
now the last thing we'll do is we'll
write here console.log and
we'll print this on our console fine
we are done with it so what we are doing
here is we want to search the string for
a word which contains the letter d e f
compulsory but before def we can have a
character that character can either be a
b or c no other character will be taken
in front of def because we have defined
a character set as well right and that
character set contains only three
characters a b and c
so
here you can see we have adef present in
the string and we have a along with def
so
what we are expecting is this test
function should return true right so
save it and check for the output in the
console so we will go to a console
and here you can see the output says
true because we have adef only
now if we write here anything else like
if we replace this a with the character
r
save it and you can see the output is
false because r is not present inside
this character set now
what if we write here something like
let's say we are writing here
caution def now
this will check for this letter only for
this l only other letters don't actually
matters in this case in the case of
character sets the only character that
matters is the character right before
the regular expression so if we save it
you can see the output is changed to
false and if we write here let's say
caution adef save it and you can see the
output is true because it checks for
this character only fine
talking about ranges let's say we want
to add any character in the string
between a to z now we have two options
to do so first one is we can write abc
till z here like we'll write here d e f
g h i and so on and so forth tills it
but this task is a little bit lengthy
right and we have to spend a lot of time
in that process so the alternate to this
process is to define a range of
characters to define a range of
characters it's quite an easy task all
you have to do is write a
hyphen z so this is how you can define a
range of characters now this range will
consist every character from a till z a
and z will also be included keep this
thing in mind if we write here caution
df again so we have seen in in the
previous example that it returned false
for this right save it now and you can
see the output is still true that's
because now we have a range from a till
z
if we write here 5 now now it will
return false because 5 does not lies in
between this range in between a to z so
it will return true for any character
between a till z fine
now let's say we want to exclude some
particular characters from this range
like we don't want the user to include
def again no character from d e or f so
the syntax for that is also pretty easy
we have to use the carrot operator and
we have to write here but we don't want
to include so let's say in this case we
don't want to include def fine so if we
write here d d e now and save it you can
see
it will return false because we have
included ddef and if we write here adef
save it and you can see the output is
true
now we can't include characters
d e and f in front of this regular
expression because we have defined this
character set to not include these
characters in the regular expression
so these are characters and ranges in
regular expressions so the next thing
we'll be doing is we'll be going through
a basic validation example and we'll see
how actually basic validation works in
javascript what we'll do is we'll create
a small html form that will take the
employee id from the user and it will
check if the employee belongs to the
organization or not
so let's say the employee id of the
organization has some unique characters
present in it and the character remains
there in each employee id
the idea is simple we'll take the id
from the user and we'll use if else
control statement to check if it belongs
to the organization or not so let's move
on to the html file and we'll create a
placeholder and a button so
let's do it
we'll write here
form
and inside this form tag
let input
id is equals to
eid
and
placeholder is equals to
employee id
and type is equals to
text fine
the next thing we are going to do is we
are going to include a button as well
button and we are going to call a
function on clicking so we will use the
on click event so we will write your own
click and lets say the function name is
employee
and the button name is let's say submit
save it and you can see over the browser
that we have a placeholder along with
the button so let me give a space here
save it now and you can see we have a
placeholder and a button so that's all
what we have to do in html part now the
rest of the thing we'll be doing in the
javascript file so let's move to a
javascript file
and comment
this piece of code first
now what we want is we want to call a
function employee on clicking the submit
button fine so what we'll do is we'll
define a function employee
and inside the body of this function the
first thing we will be doing is we'll be
taking
the user's id right so we need a
variable for that so let's say the
variable is
mpid and we'll write here
document
dot
get element by id the id is
eid
dot
value
fine now this empid variable will hold
the value entered by the user right so
like if we write here something like
d2386 so let's say this is the id this
will be stored the value for this id
will be stored inside this empid
variable fine now we'll use the regular
expression to check for some special
characters so we'll write here
inside the function we'll write here
where
check is equals to
inside the regular expression we'll
write something so let's say we want to
start the employee id for the
development team with the alphabets dnd
and each id will have a similar numeric
code like 253 which represents the code
for a particular team fine
so we'll write here inside the character
sets
we want de to be there before a similar
numeric code right so
253 is the numeric code and we want to
include either d or e
before that right
and
after 253 let's say we have a range of
numbers that each employee id has a
unique two digit number the id should
look like
either
d
2 5 3
1 1 or either
e
2 5 3
6 1
something like that right
now so for that what we have to do is we
have to include here another range and
this range will be from 11
oh sorry this range will be from 10 till
99
fine
this looks a bit complex now but if you
try to do it by yourself believe me guys
you will find it out that this is an
easy task but a little lengthy we can
say now the next part is we have to
validate the id entered for that we have
to use the if else control statement
along with the test function
so we have to write here
if
check
dot test and inside this will write
amp id because empid is the variable
which is holding the value entered by
the user right so if it's true then it
will return
an alert box with the message that says
valid
id
fine
else
it will
return a message in the pop-up
which will say
invalid
id fine
so this if else statement will check the
value returned by the test function if
the value returned is true it will
return a message valid employee id
otherwise the else statement will run
and the user will get a pop-up with the
message invalid email id fine
let's check the output and in the
browser here we'll write the employee id
in the
given placeholder so let's say the
employee id is d
253 one nine
submit it and you can see it says valid
employee id we can do it for some mode
like if we write here e
two five three
nine eight
submit it and you can see it still says
valid employee id now what if we want to
include any character between this range
and the unique number right so let's try
to do it we'll write it d
253
k
89 fine so let's say this is the id we
want to enter submit it and you can see
it says invalid employee id
now one more thing we want to do here is
like if we write here
d253
okay eight nine
in this case it will return false or
invalid employee id why because we
haven't included any modifier here and
it will differentiate between uppercase
and lowercase character so to overcome
this problem what we can do is we can
include the in case sensitive modifier
and we are clearly good too now if we
write here d25398
and save it if we write here now d
2 5 3
9 8
submit it
and you can see here the output says
valid employee id
so this is how we can use validation
along with regular expressions
in the last video we came across
character sets and ranges we saw how we
could use them with regular expressions
and we also saw how to validate a user's
input with the help of character sets
and ranges along with regular
expressions now in this video we'll look
at the shorthand character classes
present within regular expressions and
we'll see how they are helpful in
javascript
if you guys remember the regular
expression we used became a bit
confusing and lengthy because we have
used so many ranges and character sets
all in one right a character class can
be used to overcome this particular
problem and we have several character
classes present in javascript so today
we will go through them in this
particular video now the syntax is not
too much complicated all we have to do
is to write a single character with the
backslash and we are good too
for example
if we go to a javascript file and if we
write here
backslash d
now if we write this character before
any regular expression in javascript it
means that we have added a character
class to a regular expression this
backslash d is a character class used
for finding a digit within a string
let's go through an example for this
character class
and we'll do the same thing we'll take a
string and try to find a regular
expression within that string so what
we'll do is
we'll write here
where
regex is equals to
and here we'll write a regular
expression
first we'll take up a string and use
some functions to check the output so
let's do it here what we'll do is we'll
take another variable let's say the
variable name is str1 and
the string says
users
phone number
is
nine eight seven six five four three two
one zero now let's say this is the
string we are using for today's program
the next thing we'll do is we'll use the
exact function to find the regular
expression within the string so we have
already gone through this exact function
in javascript today we'll use that
function only
now we'll write here where
output is equals to
regex dot exec
and inside this will pass a string as a
parameter
the next thing we'll do is we'll write
here console.log
and we'll print this output on a console
now we are good to go so we are done
with it and the next thing we want to do
is to find a particular pattern along
with the number present before that
pattern in the string so let's suppose
if we write here inside these slashes we
write here let's say 3 to 1
now
this statement here asks the computer to
find a pattern 3 to 1 in the string
save it and go to the console so we'll
move to our browser and we'll press
control plus shift plus i and here you
can see we have a console here and here
we have an array as well so here you can
see it says
let me zoom it out a bit here you can
see it says
3 to 1 is present at index 28.
now
the system finds out that this
particular string or this particular
regular expression is present here in
the string at index number 28 obviously
the indexes will start from 0 and the
moment it will find this
3 to 1 regular expression it will show
the index number in an array
in a console
now if we add
backslash d here let's say we are adding
here backslash d
in front of this expression and check
the output here save it you will notice
that we have a number present here right
before that expression
right we have 4 3 2 1 here instead of
just 3 2 1. the output here gives us the
number 4. this means that this backslash
d represents this number
4 in this string now what if we put an
alphabet before this expression now
let's do it what we'll do is we'll write
here a
and let's say we are adding only a
single alphabet here let's say we are
adding a before 321 now the expected
output is a321 but the moment we'll save
it you can see it says null that's
because this particular character class
works for digits only if it finds
anything other than a numeric digit it
will return an error or it will return
null in that case now if we want to find
all the numbers before this pattern then
we have to add a plus operator in the
regular expression all we have to do is
we have to write here plus and we are
good to now it will return everything
until it finds a space or any character
other than a digit now let's suppose if
you are writing here a after 987
now this particular statement will
return all the numbers till 6 the moment
it will encounter a here it will return
all the numbers after a it will stop at
a and it will not go further now save it
and you can see it says 654321
that's because
this backslash d works for digits only
now if we write here nothing like we
have a number nine eight seven six five
four three two one zero save it and it
will return the whole number nine eight
seven six five four three two one not 0
because we haven't included any number
here
now if we write here again
backslash d after this as well save it
and here you can see we have the output
as
0 as well we have the whole number here
fine
so this is how this backslash d actually
works in javascript so this is a
character class
now
the next thing is what if we want to
find a non-digit character before a
particular pattern
if we write here
before 321 let's say we are writing here
a
and we want the system to return the
non-digit character before 3 to 1 in
that case we use capital d instead of
small d always remember guys every
shorthand character class and rejects
have an inverse that does
precisely the opposite of that
particular class like if we have small d
here that works for digits only we also
have an inverse which is denoted by
backslash capital d and it does exactly
opposite of this small d here
now if we write here
capital d in place of small d
what will happen is it will return the
character here it will return true for
everything other than a digit
now if we remove this small d from here
and save it
here you can see it says null because we
haven't included the backslash sign here
save it
and here you can see it says
a321 it will return true for anything
except for a digit even if we put a
symbol over here then also it will
return the output as true for example if
we write here
let's say we are including dollar sign
here let's say we are including two
dollar sign here save it and it will
return two dollar signs that's because
we are using the plus operator here
obviously let's include as many signs as
we can
save it and here you can see we have all
the symbols present over here on our
output so this is how capital d
character class works or we can say
inverse character class of small d this
is how it works
now the next class will be going through
is the wordly character denoted by the
letter w small w and is used in place of
any character that can be an alphabet a
number or an underscore sign
we can use this character over d if we
are unsure about the character present
before the pattern for example if we
write here
let's say backslash w
ber
now here we have used the ber pattern
which is present at the end of
number right here ber is present at the
end of number now this statement will
return m only because we are not using
any plus operator here if we use any
plus operator then it will return the
whole number because it will return
everything until it encounters a space
or something like that
so for now we are not using any plus
operator so we'll be writing here this
only now here it will return m because
it can take up a number an alphabet or
an underscore sign it will return false
if it finds any space or something other
than these three these three means a
number an alphabet or an underscore sign
fine
now save it and you can see on the
console that the output says mber let me
zoom it a bit so here you can see the
output says mber right present at index
14
it will return null if we put a space
before the pattern like if we write here
num space b er save it you can see it
says null for this now we can use the
plus operator as well here for this
particular character class now what will
happen is it will return every character
present before the pattern until it
encounters a space or something like
a symbol or any sort of thing so let's
try it what we'll do is we'll write here
w
plus b er and we'll remove this space
from here
save it and here you can see it says
number what if we remove this space from
here remove it save it and here you can
see it says phone number it will return
every character before the pattern until
it finds any space or any other let's
say
symbol so let's say we are including
here dollar percentage
and carrot sign
save it and here you can see it says an
e number so it's returning it from here
because it will not return true for any
of the symbols here
save it and here you can see we have the
output as phone number again so that's
working totally fine
like the inverse character class for
digits we have the inverse character
class for this also and it returns true
for everything other than an alphabet
number or any underscore sign now if we
write here
instead of small w let's say we are
writing here capital w
and let's do something with the string
as well so let's put a space here again
and we are good to go we are not doing
anything more than that so it will
return null because before ber we have m
here right if we remove this m with us
sign let's say if you are removing this
with a dollar sign or with an empty one
like we are writing here space nothing
then it will return the index number and
the pattern
so let's do it save it
and here you can see it says dollar then
it says ber and index number is 14. you
can count the index number so 0 for u
and then similarly 1 for s 2 for e 3 4 r
4 for s up to 14 for dollar so dollar is
present at index 14 it will return the
index number here now the plus operator
also works for this inverse character
class as well right here plus ber and we
can insert as many characters or as many
symbols as we want so like here we have
inserted so many symbols this doesn't
mean anything but we are inserting them
for
example purposes or for practical
purpose so save it and here you can see
we have all the symbols present over
here in a array and the index number is
still 14. if we remove
these n and u from here now save it the
index number will change to 11
that's quite easy
now
the next class we have is the simplest
of all this class works for white spaces
only it means that it will return true
or give us the index number of the
expression
from the string only if a white space
exists before the pattern
it is denoted by small s and works for
spaces only now if we write here
let's say
backslash s
okay we have made a mistake we'll write
a backslashes
and we'll write your phone so
this is the pattern and this is the
character class backslash s is the
character class now what we'll do is
we'll
remove it from here and we'll
write the string
as this again we'll write a user's phone
number is this and this
now for this regular expression it will
return the index number of this space
the space is present at index 5
0 for u
1 for s 2 for e 3 for r 4 for s and this
space is present at index number five so
it will return index as 5 for this
particular space now don't get confused
guys for this index number s5 the index
number is for the space present in the
screen before the pattern phone
right
now if we try to do the same for users
as well
let's suppose if we write here
users it will return null in this case
because there's no space present before
users in the string right save it and
here you can see the output says null in
this case
fine
now we can also use the plus operator
here for more than one spaces present in
the string it will return all the spaces
until it finds a character or something
other than the spaces like if it finds
any symbol or any character then only it
will return false otherwise for spaces
it will return true so if we write here
too many spaces if we put too many
spaces before the word
phone or let's say we are changing this
word to
phone
save it and here you can see we have all
the spaces here it's denoted by a single
space but the index numbers is changed
to 19. now we have so many spaces
present here before the
pattern phone or before the word phone
so this is how we can use
space character class in javascript
now we have also the inverse class for
this character class as well it returns
true for everything other than empty
spaces if we write here
let's say we are removing this and let's
say we are right okay and let's say we
are
writing here users
and we are
giving so many spaces here before the
word users now it will return null in
this case because there are spaces
present in front of the word users
if we include a character or something
in front of this word then only the
output will change and return the index
number along with the string so save it
first and here you can see
okay we have used the smallest in place
of smallest we'll write here capital s
save it and you can see here the output
says null for capital s because this
capital s will return true for
everything other than spaces only now if
we put here any symbol let's say we have
these symbols here
save it and here you can see now we have
a hash symbol present before the word
users that's because we have used
capital s only now if we use a plus
operator save it and here you can see we
have all the symbols present in a array
we have the index number as 11 we have
dollar percentage carrot and hash
present over here right so this is how
the inverse of character spaces in
javascript actually work so these are
the character classes we have in
javascript if you guys see we have two
text boxes over here one is for the
username and other one is for the
password creating such text boxes in
html is quite an easy task we have to
use the input tag which we discussed a
few sessions back
and we are using some more properties
here so you can see we have type as text
for username and for password the type
is password
so before we move on to validation with
javascript let me tell you guys that we
can do certain things with html as well
like if we want that none of the two
text boxes over here remains blank
we can write here inside these input
tags so if we write here
required
save it and now if you try to click on
this submit button you can see it says
please fill out this field it will not
allow the user to submit the form until
there is any value present for the name
so if we write here any random name and
submit it now you can see the form is
getting refreshed that's because we have
used the form tag over here now if we
try to submit without writing anything
we'll get the pop-up as please fill out
this field and we can do the same for
password as well like if we write here
required and save it
now if you write any name over here for
the username and if we leave this
password field blank submit it you can
see it says please fill out this field
for password as well
so html can let you do all this stuff
but when it comes to actual validation
like if you want the user to enter only
if the name or password matches the one
present in the back end or maybe we can
say in the server
we have to use something more than html
now the case with javascript is a bit
different
if we talk about validation in
javascript we can use javascript for
client-side verification
the scenario here will be the one we'll
discuss in today's video what we'll do
today is we'll create a basic signup
form with three text boxes one is for
the username the other one is for the
password and we'll add one more box for
each
half of the work is already done and we
have to add one more box now for the age
so edge is just a number right so we can
add a text box over here what we have to
do is we have to write here
before the submit button will write here
input
type is equals to number
and will provided the id as well so
let's say the id is h we'll use the id
attribute later
and inside this placeholder will write
here h
save it and here you can see we have
three text boxes over here
inside the h we can't write any
character or alphabet because we have
defined the type as number for this so
we can write numbers here only now the
next part is to link this page to
another web page such that if the
credentials are correct the user will
enter the home page of our website for
that we have to use the action attribute
in html now the question here is when do
we want the user to enter the home page
only if the credentials are correct
right
we have to use the action attribute with
the form tag so you can see over here we
have already mentioned the form type now
what we'll do is we'll write here action
and what we want is we wanted to
redirect the user to another page or
another web page the home page of our
website after checking the credentials
and if the credentials are correct the
user will move on to the home page so we
have already a file named homepage.html
so we'll write your homepage.html
and save it now on clicking the submit
button okay we have to fill something
for
name and for password as well so we'll
write random values over here submit it
and you can see we have been redirected
to another page and this is the home
page of our website however it doesn't
look like a home page still we can
assume it right so now we know what
should be done if the user has correct
credentials to enter the home page we
are almost done with the html part we
will make some more changes to this file
later the next thing we have to do is to
validate the credentials entered by the
user right for validation purposes we'll
use the if else control statements in a
javascript file we'll create a function
in a javascript file and call that
function when the user clicks the submit
button but there is a difference will
not call the function on clicking the
submit button instead will call the
function on
submission of the form so instead of
writing here on click and then calling
that function what we'll do is
we'll write here inside the form tag
we'll write on submit so this is an
event and on submit what will happen is
it will call a function named validate
we'll create this validate function in
our javascript file now
so you can see here we have already used
the id attribute with all the input tags
in order to get the values entered by
the user so let's move on to the
javascript file and what we'll do here
is we'll first declare a function named
validate so we'll write here function
and the function name is
validate
and then we have the body of this
function
now we'll take three variables to get
all the values entered by the user
because we need to check for all the
values right so we need to check if the
user's name and password match the one
we want and the user should be aged
above 13 to enter our website
for all these we need the values entered
by the user so we'll use the get element
by id method to get all the values now
for that we'll take three variables so
let's say the first variable is unnamed
it will hold the value entered in the
username text box
let me go to the form again
and here you can see we have three text
boxes username password h so we'll take
three variables
for name we'll write here document dot
get element by id and the id is you name
let me confirm it once so you can see
here
the id for username is
uni
for password it is pass and for h it's h
so we'll write here dot
value
the next thing we'll do is we'll create
another variable for password we'll
write here again document dot
get element by id and the id is pass
will again write here dot value
and the third variable will be where age
it will hold the age of the user
so we'll again write here
document.getelementbyid
and id for ages h
we'll again use the dot value property
now we are done with the values
we have three variables holding all the
values entered by the user next up we'll
use these values to validate the data
entered by the user
now the first condition we can have here
is that we don't want the user to leave
any of the text boxes empty right
if we click on this submit button you
can see it says please fill out this
field now we can do it with the help of
html as well but for now we are using
javascript so we will remove these
required keywords
so that we can do it with javascript
only
save it
and submit it now you can see it is
redirecting us to the home page of our
website so it's working totally fine now
what we'll do is we'll write a condition
if the user leaves any of these fields
empty so we'll write here if
u name
is equals to is equals to blank
or
pass is equals to is equals to blank
okay
pass is equals to is equals to blank
or
age
is equals to is equals to
blank now what will happen is it will
give the user a pop-up with the message
let's say
the message is
missing
credentials fine
save it
and if we leave any of these fields
empty now a pop-up will appear with the
message missing credentials so the first
condition is done but there's a loophole
in this condition so let's check it out
first we'll
leave username and password empty submit
it you can see it says missing
credentials right now the next thing is
if we write here let's say a random name
and password as well but we are leaving
this age text box empty submit it it
still says missing credentials because
we haven't entered the h and it's
working totally fine
now there's a loophole in this condition
the exciting part is it will work fine
if the user enters more than one space
in all the fields like
if you are giving here spaces for more
than once and similarly for password as
well submit it
and you can see it says missing
credentials because we haven't filled
the h
so let's
do one thing we'll
write some spaces for username and
password and for h we'll say the age is
4. submit it and you can see we have no
error over here now to overcome this
problem we have a predefined javascript
method that treats all the spaces the
same
no matter the number of spaces whether
it be one or more than one it will treat
all the same we have to include the trim
method
within the if else statement so what
we'll do is we'll write here dot trim
for username and similarly for password
as well we'll write here trim
and for age as well let's say
dot trim
and save it now
move back to a sign up form and if we
try to give more than one spaces here
and let's say the age is 4 submit it you
can see it says missing credentials for
more than one species as well so this is
working totally fine now the following
condition will be for validating the
name let's say the required name is
caution or anything else
the required password is let's say one
two three four five and the age should
be more than thirteen
then only the user can enter the website
so for that we have to use the else if
statement and what we'll do is we'll
write here
elsif and inside this will give our
conditions so let's say the conditions
are u name
is equals to is equals to
caution
and
pass
is equals to is equals to
one two three four five
and
h
should be
greater than or is equals to
13
then
it will give the user a pop-up and
which states that we'll write here alert
we'll write here
sign up
successful
fine
save it
now the user can enter the website with
these credentials only otherwise a
pop-up will appear
so let's give the else condition as well
what we'll do is we'll write here else
and we'll use another alert
inside this we'll write
wrong id and
password
fine
now we have all the conditions here save
it and now we'll check for different
inputs
so let's move back to a form
and what we'll do is we'll write the
username is let's say ravi
and the password is let's say any random
numbers and age is let's say 6 submit it
and you can see it says wrong id and
password now what we'll do is we'll give
it the correct credentials we'll write
here
caution and the password will be one two
three four five
and age is let's say 21 fine the age
should be greater than or equals to 13
so submit it and you can see it says
sign up successful
now we have different conditions over
here
like if we write here any random name
and
if we write here any random password now
it will return wrong id and password but
if we write here correct id and password
and
correct username as well let's say we
are writing here caution and let's say
the age will change to
11 submit it and you can see it still
says wrong id and password we can add
one more condition over here like we'll
write here elsif age is less than 12 it
will give an alert that
you are under aged or some sort of that
so we'll write here else if
h
is less than 13.
an
alert which states underage fine
save it
and what we'll do is we'll move back to
our form and we'll write a caution
password is one two three four five and
age is let's say
11 submit it and you can see it says
under aged now so it is working totally
fine now one thing that seems a bit
irritating as well is it redirects us to
the home page every time right it
doesn't matter if the credentials are
correct or not it redirects to overcome
this issue we have
to make some minor changes in the html
file and include the return keyword in a
if else conditional statements so let's
go back to our html file and what we'll
do is
we'll write here inside the form tag now
we have on submit over here so what
we'll do is we'll write return
before validate
so save it and we'll move back to
javascript file
now this return keyword will let the
form perform any action only if the
value returned by the function validate
is true otherwise it will not allow the
form tag to perform any action the
action here is redirecting the user to
the home page right so
let's do it here we know that the
function should return true only if all
the credentials are valid so we'll write
here for all other
conditions we'll write
return
false
fine
for this one we'll write
return true because this is the
condition when all the credentials are
correct and for all other conditions
we'll write return
false
similarly for else as well we'll write
here
return false
now save it and we'll move back to
sign up form
save the html file as well once
and what we'll do is we'll write a
caution password is 1 2 3
and age is let's say 4 submit it you can
see it says underaged click on ok and
now it is not redirecting us to the home
page right
now if the credentials are correct what
we'll do is we'll write here the
password is 1 2 3 4 5
and the age is let's say
21
submit it
now you can see it says sign up
successful click on ok and you can see
we are in the home page it is working
totally fine
so if all the credentials are valid then
it is redirecting us to the home page
exactly what we wanted so these are the
basics of validation in javascript
obviously we can't validate a form with
javascript in the real world because we
don't have to deal with one user only we
need the back end to do all the
validation and all but simple validation
can be done with the help of javascript
we did it just now
we have many things to do with
validation in javascript like adding
some more conditions or using regular
expressions to validate forms in
javascript using regular expressions for
validation in javascript is what we
already saw in the previous videos we
have come across almost every important
topic in javascript whether it is an
important one like regular expressions
in javascript or the one mainly asked in
interviews like promises in javascript
each topic has its own value in
javascript and every topic is important
so in today's video we'll come across
two different types of games the first
one will be the one wherein we'll
recreate flappy words using javascript
now many of you guys must have heard
about this game already if not
we have to take a bird through a space
between two walls in this particular
game so let me just take you through the
game once
and
here we are so this is our game you can
see we have a bird over here and we have
to take this bird through this yellow
hole present in between the blue color
right the yellow holes are random and if
the bird strikes the blue wall or maybe
at the bottom of the screen
then the game will over fine so i hope
you guys understood what we have to do
in this particular game now we have to
press a key from the keyboard to make
the bird jump repeatedly and we have to
make the bird jump so that the bird will
go through the hole between the walls
without touching the boundaries of the
whole
so i hope you guys must have understood
the task here
now
let's try to recreate this game again
from scratch and we'll do everything by
ourselves will go through the html part
will go through the javascript and will
go through the css as well both html and
css will play a vital role in making
this game along with the javascript part
obviously
so let's start with the code now we'll
go back to vs code and here you can see
we have a html file named
flappybird.html so we'll change the
title of this as well we'll write here
instead of document we'll write here
flappy bird fine save it
now first of all we'll take a container
for the game to run so
as you can see here we have a container
over here fine so this is our container
now we have to create this whole
container
now what we'll do for that is we'll go
to the body tag and we'll write here
div
id is let's say
game
and we'll close this day now inside this
particular div we'll create three more
div tags so we'll write here div
id is equals to
block or we can write here pipe as well
for the wall or for the pipe we can say
the next we'll write here div
id is equals to hole that is for the
whole
and the last one is for the bird fine so
we'll write it div
id is equals to
bird
we'll close this div and a fundamental
task is done here
now we have a container for the game
we'll put the game inside one single
container
the next thing we need in a game is a
block which we'll use to create the
walls in the game followed by the hole
in the block for the bird to go through
it right and the last thing is the bird
itself so we'll add an image here for
the bird so let's do some styling for
all this that we have written over here
so what we'll do is we'll move to a css
file so this is a css file
and we'll write here
for the whole document the margin will
be
zero by default
okay so we'll write here zero
and
the padding will be zero as well fine
we are good to go that's a common thing
the margin and the padding will remain
zero for the whole html document
the next thing is to create the
background of whole document
so we'll do something creative here
something different from what we did
till now
so what we'll do is we'll create the
background with two different colors
now you might be thinking of what these
two different colors are so what we'll
do is we'll write here body
and then we'll write here
background color we'll take any
background color
let's say we are taking cadet blue
fine
now save it
save this part as well and open this on
live server
so here you can see we have a background
we have the background of html document
as cadet blue color
now the next thing we'll do is we'll use
two different colors over this
background right so we'll write here
background
image
and we'll write here
webkit
linear gradient and we'll write here rgb
175
comma 75 comma 75
then we'll write here
rgb so these are three particular colors
we'll write here
31 comma 31 comma 31
and the last one will be
rgb
59 comma
153 comma
1 4 8
fine
so here we are and the next thing we'll
do is we'll write here
min height
will be
800 pixels
now save it
and you can see here we have three
different colors over here we'll go to
our css file
and you can see this webkit linear
gradient over here is unknown to us
right so css gradients let us display
smooth transitions between two or more
specified colors
so we can do it radially or linearly
now let's see the difference
and you can spot the difference here in
the output
we have three different colors over here
we have red black and a little bit of
gray in between
right so let's move on to the first
container and we'll create the game area
now
now what we have to do is we have to
create the game area
so what we'll do is we'll access the div
tag with ids game
and let's start working on this div tag
and we'll understand it much better
so we'll write here
game
and we'll write here next up
height of this container will be let's
say 500 pixels
width
is let's say 400 pixels so guys remember
this height and width we'll need them
later
now the next thing we'll do is we'll
write here
border
and the border will be one pixel
solid
black in color fine
and we'll add a background image as well
we'll write a background image
or we'll write a background only
we'll write a url and inside this will
write
fine
save it now and
you can see here we have a container
over here
now it's not working it
says there's no such image present in a
folder so what we'll do is we'll check
it from here
here we are
we have bg2 over here not bg1 so we'll
write here bg2.jpg save it now
and move back to the browser and here
you can see we have an image over here
so it's not quite visible till now so
what we'll do is
we'll write here
background size as
cover fine save it now
and here you can see we have an image
over here now the image looks fine
the next thing we'll do is we'll write
margin
and we'll write here
margin
and the margin will be
one ram and
auto fine save it now
you can see we have the block in between
now the next thing we'll do is we'll use
the overflow property here and it will
not show the bird going out of the box
so we'll see it in a moment but this
overflow property will do so what we'll
do is we'll write here overflow
is equals
to hidden
save it now
you can see it's not making any
difference as of now but we'll
understand it later
now we have a box over here on the
browser and the game will be played
inside this particular box now we have
to work on the div for the block
so we have to create a block and that
block will move again and again through
the screen with holes present at a
random place every time
fine i hope you guys got it so let's
style the block now what we'll do is
we'll go to a css file and we'll write
here
hash
block fine so this is the id for the
block
now inside this will use
width
as
50 pixels
then we have
height
so the height will be
500 pixels equal to the height of the
whole container
the next thing we'll write here is
background
color and the background color will be
let's say
blue
fine
we will write here
position as
relative
and
then we'll write here
left
400 pixels
fine now we know that after saving this
piece of code the block will not be
visible anymore so why is it not visible
it's a question right
it arises in every person's mind save it
and here you can see the block is yet
not visible now what we have to do is we
have to set the left property as 200
let's try to do it 200 once so what
we'll do is we'll write here
200 pixels save it now
and here you can see we have a block or
a screen now the value of left property
is 200 means the block is present
to 200 pixels from the right most corner
of the container
if we write here 400
and save it
you can see we don't have any block here
it means that the block is present
right after this entire container the
block starts here and goes still here
it's a 50 pixels wide block and it's not
visible because we have set the left
property as 400
so
now the next thing we have to do is we
need some animation over this box right
or we can say we need some animation
over this block right so what we'll do
is
we'll write here
animation
and we'll
write here block we have
to perform it on a block
and the animation time will be two
seconds we'll write here
linear and
it will go to infinite fine
now this animation property will help us
in moving the box again and again after
every two seconds
and the moving points we have to define
here
so for that what we have to do is we
have to write here
at the rate
keyframes
after this we'll write here block
and inside this will write zero percent
left will be
400
pixels
and at 100 animation
what we'll do is we'll set the left
property is
minus 50 pixels
fine
now you guys might be wondering what we
are doing here but this keyframe here is
a rule that specifies the animation code
and it will help the block move again
and again from 400 pixel in the right to
minus 50 pixels in the left
fine save it
and we'll go to the browser
you can see the box is moving again and
again after every two seconds or two
milliseconds now the next thing we have
to do is with the hole in the block so
we have to put a hole here in the block
and for that we have to access another
div with ids whole
fine so we'll move to a css file and
we'll access that particular
element with ids hole so we'll write
here hash
hole
and inside this will write
height of the hole will be
150 pixels less than that of the block
width will be
50 pixels same as the block
and then we'll write here
background
color fine so let's say the background
color is
yellow
this is for
practical purpose you can change it by
yourself
the next thing we'll write here is
position position will be
relative
left will be
400 pixels
and
top will be
minus 5 double zero pixels fine
then we'll write a animation
again we'll write a block
we'll write here two seconds we'll write
a linear
and we'll write here infinite fine
now this hole will also go with the same
animations as the block
save it
and open the
browser and here you can see the hole is
not properly over the block and they are
both at different locations so we can
try to refresh this code and here you
can see
the hole is now present at the top of
the block so here is the hole this
yellow part represents the whole for
this particular game
now it is working totally fine
and this is an empty space to make this
hole randomly come anywhere in the block
we have to do some magic with javascript
for that so we'll do it later in this
video
now if the hole is not placed over the
block in your code don't worry just
refresh the code or we can say just
refresh the home page it will be fine or
if not it will get fine once we go
through the javascript part that's not a
major deal
so let's move on to the bird now what
we'll do is we'll add an image to our
html file for the bird
so we'll write here
inside the html file we'll write here
where the id's bird will write here
img
okay we
have we'll write here src is equals to
bird
one dot
png
so let me check if this file exists in a
system or not
so here we are we have bird dot png not
bird one dot png
save it and what we'll do is we'll write
here
alt is
but we'll close this img tag save it
open the browser and you can see the
bird is not visible as of now to make
this image visible we have to work on
the styling so we'll access this image
with the id board
what we'll do is we'll go to the css
file again
and we'll write here
hash
board
the next thing we'll write here is
position
so position will be
fixed
and
top of bird will be
100 pixels
then we have
height
as
50 pixels and
width will also be
50 pixels fine
we'll do the same for image tag as well
so we'll write here
bird
img
and inside this will write
height
as 50 pixels and we'll write a width
fine
is
50 pixels
right
now save it
and if we open the browser now
you can see we have a bird in our game
now we are halfway done in making our
game and we haven't used any javascript
until now right that's quite funny so
we'll use javascript now
let's move on to the javascript part
we'll go to the javascript file first
now first of all we'll access every
element of a javascript file that we can
access
so we'll use the getelementbyid method
to access every element of our html file
what we'll do is we'll write here where
whole so
whole
is the id of whole present in the block
so we can access that div tag you will
write you
document dot
get element by id and we'll write here
whole fine
the next thing is we'll write here where
game
is equal to document dot
get element by id the id will be
the id will be game fine
so for now we need to access these two
elements only we'll add some more
elements later and then we'll access
them so for now let's focus on these two
only
next up we need the hole to be placed in
random places in the block every time
for that we need an event listener so
we'll create a function that will change
the location of this hole every time
it will change the location on every
iteration of the block fine
so
we'll write here whole dot
add event listener
and we'll write here
animation iteration so this is a event
listener and we'll write here a function
name so let's say we are writing here
ran whole fine so this is a function
it's random hole so we'll write here
rain hole now we'll declare this
function as well we'll write here
function renhold and
inside of this function we'll take a
variable
random let's say so this is a variable
we'll write here
minus
math dot
random
so this is a function and we'll
multiply this value by
350
so this means that it will take any
random value between 0 and 350 fine and
then what we'll do is we'll add 150 to
that particular value and the whole
value will be changed to minus
we'll see it in a moment why we are
doing so so the next thing we'll write
here is
whole dot style dot
left
now whole dot style dot
top
is equals
to random
plus
pixels fine i hope you guys got it till
now
so this math dot random function will
pick any random value between 0 to 350
and 150 will be added to that particular
value because we don't want the value to
go down as low as 10 and the whole will
go out of the containers borders so the
initial value of the hole was let's
check it out
so here we are in a css file so you can
see the initial value of whole
was
minus 500 pixels for top fine
so the new value will be random plus
pixels
the value was 500 because we wanted the
hole at the top of the block and now it
will take any random value and the whole
will be placed according to that
particular random value
so let's save it
open the browser and here you can see
the hole is moving randomly now you can
see it was initially present at the top
now it is at the bottom here so it will
change the location randomly according
to the random number picked up by the
math dot random function so let's get
back to the javascript part now before
we move on to the fall and game over
function let's discuss the game over
scenario first and will finish out all
the necessary html and css tasks for the
game over
so the game will be over when the bird
strikes the pole or either the bird
falls down to the ground
on game over the score will be shown on
the screen with a restart button right
so the score will be counted on the
basis of blocks passed by the birds now
the number of blocks passed will be the
final score
so we'll take a variable score and
increase the value of this score
variable with each random block coming
through
so we'll take a variable score and we'll
write here
where
score
is equals to 0 the initial value will be
0. so let's do the html part wherein
we'll use a div tag to print the result
on the screen
what we'll do is we'll go to the html
file and here what we'll do is we'll
write here after this particular div tag
we'll write
diff
id is equals
to result
and here we have another div tag present
over here now inside this div tag
we'll use
h1 tag and we'll write here
game over
fine next thing we'll do here is we'll
use
p tag with ids
let's say text fine
we'll close the p tag here or the
paragraph tag we can say now we need a
button so we'll write a button
id is equals to btn
we'll write here on click
is equals to location
and dot
reload
and will write here
restart
fine
now the html part is done the paragraph
tag with ids text will be used to print
the score on the scoreboard
now this
location.reload method is used to reload
the whole webpage on clicking the start
button the entire page will be reloaded
and the game will start again
fine we'll use css to style all of this
game over part
so we'll go to the css file and here's
the css file
now we'll write here
hash
result we are accessing the div tag with
id as a result
so the height will be
let's say 200 pixels for result and the
width
is let's say
500 pixels right
so
if i show you once again so here is the
block for game over scenario so the
height is 200 pixels and the width is
500 pixels basically we need to create a
card right or we can say a rectangle
so we'll move back to the css file and
we'll write here
background color is
let's say
down
margin will be
5 frame auto
so
margin top will be five rip and then it
will do it automatically
then we'll write here
border
so border will be two pixels
solid
and the color will be white fine
we'll write here
border radius
so the border radius will be let's say
20 pixels we want rounded borders
and the display will be
none
fine
the last thing we'll do is we'll write
here text
align
as center it will align the text in the
center
and the next thing we are left with is
the
button fine so we'll write here hash btn
because the id of button element is btn
so we'll write here
padding
0.5
ram
and one ram
fine
the border
will be
none
because we don't need any border for
this button
we of course want the button to be round
from the corners so we'll write your
border radius as 11 pixels
background color is
green
color is
white
font size is
1.5 ram
we'll write it text
transform
uppercase
we'll write here margin top
one rim
so guys you can see we are using this
ram again and again so i might wonder
that if any one of you knows the exact
definition of this word ram if yes then
do let us know in the comments below and
let's see how many of you guys know the
actual definition of this term
so the last thing we'll do is we'll
write here cursor is equals to pointer
and we are good to fine the next thing
is we'll write here
hash text
margin
top will be
one ram
and
font size will be
2 ram fine
we'll do one more thing
we'll write here
color is
c shell so this will be the color of our
text so we are now totally done with the
html and css part
the only thing remaining now is the
javascript part and we have to work on
that only
so just a few more files statements and
all and we are done with the game
now moving back to the javascript part
but before we go there let me just
show you how this works
save it and go to the browser so this is
our game
and you can't see any
game over scenario here right so for
that what we have to do is we have
to go here in result and we have to
comment this
particular statement fine
display has none we have to comment out
this statement save it now
and it's not working
now as well okay here's a mistake in
this div tag
what we did wrong here is
so this was a mistake save it now
and now here you can see we have a card
for game over over here and if you click
on this restart button you can see the
page is reloading again and again
so it's working totally fine we'll move
back to the css file
and will
remove this fine
save it now
and let's go back to the javascript part
now we'll access two more html elements
that we just created so what we'll do is
we'll
write here where
result is equals
document dot get element by id and id is
a result fine
and then finally we'll write here where
text is equals to
document.getelementbyid
and id is
text fine
so the next thing we'll do is we'll
write here where
jumping
is equals to 0 we'll take another
variable for the bird to jump now we'll
need all these elements further in the
video now we have to create functions
for falling and we have to mention the
conditions for game over as well so what
we'll do is we'll write here after this
renault function
we'll write here where fall
is equals to
set interval will set an interval so
we'll write here
function
and
then we have the body of this function
so
the next thing we'll do is we'll write
here where
bird top
is equals to percent
we'll write your window
dot
get computed style
and will pass bird here
then we'll write here dot
get
property value and the property value
will be
top
fine
now the next thing we'll do is
we'll write here if
jumping
is equals 2 is equals to zero
the body of if statement will write here
mer dot style
dot top
is equals to bird top
plus 2
after this will
make them in pixels fine
now
we have to mention the time in
milliseconds here so we'll write here
10.
and we are good to go so here in this
function we are using the top value
provided to the bird so we have used
these two functions window dot get
computed style and get property value
to get the elements style property with
ids bird and the top value we need will
be passed to the following function the
value of jumping is 0 so the style dot
top will be set to bert top plus 2
pixels
now the initial value was 100 pixels
from the top
and 2 pixels will be added to the value
after every 10 milliseconds now
save it
and here you can see a bird will fall
eventually
fine so what's happening here is
two pixels will be added to this value
of top after every 10 milliseconds now
fine
now we have to define those conditions
here wherein we'll check if the bird
touches the ground then game over for
that we have to write inside the same
function only so we'll move back to a
function
and we'll write inside this particular
function only
we'll write here where block
left
will take the left value of block
and we'll write here percent window dot
get computed style so we need the
computed style
for block now
and we'll write here dot get
property value
fine
so we'll write here
left because we need the left value
and the value will be stored inside
block left and then we have where
whole top
fine
we'll write here percent window dot
get computed style we'll write here
whole and then we'll write here get
property value and we'll write here
top
fine
now what we'll do is we'll write here
where
h stop
so this is another variable
so the value of h top will be
500
plus
whole top
so any value returned to the whole top
variable will be added to 500 and that
value will be assigned to h top variable
fine
now we have to write your conditions so
the conditions will be
if bur top is greater than 450 or block
left
so we've made a mistake here
we have to put one more bracket over
here and then we'll write your block
left
is
less than 50
and then
we'll write here block left
greater than minus 50
then we have
bird top
is less than h top
or
but top
is
greater than h top
plus 100
fine
i'll explain it to you in a moment
now what we have to do is we have to
write here
result dot style
dot display we have to change this style
to
block now which was none till now so
then we'll write here text
dot
inner text
is equals to
your final
score is
colin will use rare dollar and then
we'll print the
scoria fine now the next thing we'll do
is we'll write here
game
dot style dot
display is equals to
none which was block until now
now the last thing we have to do is we
have to change the value of score to
zero again so that the game will restart
from zero
now let me explain this to you guys
so we have to write here but top first
not birdy up
so now if bird top is greater than 450
means that the bird is touching the
ground or we can say the bottom part of
the container
now you can get all these values correct
by going through the inspect elements
and i hope you guys already know how to
use it in javascript to get the exact
values in pixels so i want you guys to
check it to cross check it once if it's
fine or not
now if the block left is less than 50
and greater than minus 50 means if the
bird is colloiding with the block or not
and the bird top is less than h stop
means the bird is hitting with the top
of the block
or the bottom of the hole we can say
the last one is for the bird to collide
from the upper part of the block
now in all these cases the result box
will appear and style of the result box
will be blocked
the paragraph tag with ids text will
show the score here and the game dot
style will change to none
now the game will disappear and the
game over scenario will come forward now
score will be again 0 as if the user
wants to restart the game then he can
restart it from zero again
so save it once and let's see if it's
working or not
save it
and go to the browser
close
it
okay
you can see it's working totally fine
but it says your final score is dollar
score so we have made a mistake over
here
now what we'll do is we'll go back here
and we'll check
what's wrong here fine okay the mistake
here is of single inverted comma instead
of single inverted comma we have to put
this sign over here
now save it go back to the browser
restart the game and you can see it's
working totally fine it says your final
score is zero
restart it again and here you can see
it's working totally fine now we are
left with only one thing
and that thing is
quite easy so what we have to do now is
we have to make the bird jump on button
press so we have to create one last
function for this event so what we'll do
is we'll write here after this
window
dot add event listener
will add an event key down
and then we'll write here
hop so hop will be a function
op is basically a synonym for jump as
well so we'll define this hop function
now
we'll write here
function hop and then we have the body
of this function so jumping
will set to 1
on calling this function and we'll write
here where
bird top
is equals
to percent
will again write here
window dot
get computed style
and the style will get from
bird and the property we want is
top
fine
now we'll write here if
top
is greater than six
then we'll write here
bird
dot style
dot
top
minus
60
fine
okay so we'll write here
is equals to
word
top
minus 60
so we'll put all this inside a bracket
and we'll convert it to
pixels so for that we have to write here
pixels inside double inverted comma
fine
now what we have to do next is
we have to write here
set
timeout
and we have to create
an anonymous function over here
so we'll write here function and we'll
again set the value of jumping to
0 after every
100 milliseconds fine
so every time a key is pressed the hop
function will be called and the value of
jumping will change to 1. it will again
take the birth top value and check if
the value of bird top is greater than 6
and if yes then subtract 60 from it and
save it inside the top of
the bird then again the bird will try to
go down after every 100 milliseconds but
the word will also go up by 60 pixels
on each button press right now save it
and our game is ready so we are done
with creating the game now what we'll do
is we'll go to the browser and will
restart the game
so here you can see our bird is jumping
and
we can take the bird
from the holes so
here you can see
we have a bird and it's working
fine
so we have to take the word through
these holes so here you can see it says
your final score is zero every time
fine so let's check out for this ones
okay so we have forgot to mention here
score plus plus
now save it
go back to the browser
now
we'll play this game again once
so we have to take this bird through
these gaps in between the blocks
see how long it
goes so here you can see it says your
final score is 5 and then again the
value of score is set to zero after some
time
that's because if the person want to
restart the game then the value of score
will be zero for that restart
now here you guys just saw me playing
this exciting game and i want you guys
to try it it's fun and you'll enjoy the
game more after creating it by yourself
today we'll create a car game in which
we have to save a car from obstacles
coming towards our vehicle
i don't know the exact name for this
game but let me give you an overview of
this game real quick so here is the game
you can see over the screen wherein we
have a red car on the road and we have
to protect this car by moving to the
left or right
all we have to do is to protect this red
car from collision with the blue one
now i know the graphics for these games
are not too much appealing but if you
want to make a high-end graphics game
then javascript is not the only language
you can use
we have to use many different js
libraries and maybe several other
programming languages along with
javascript to achieve this task
so let's focus on these small games for
now and we'll go ahead step by step
now in this particular game if you see
here we have three images one is of red
car the other one is of blue car and a
road behind them right so let's move on
to the programming part directly
and most of the parts will remain the
same like that of flappy birds let's
move on to vs code
so here is our game this is the html
file and then we have a css file and a
javascript file for this game
now what we'll do first is we'll create
a div tag we have to protect a block
right we have to move the container
either to the left or to the right so
for that we have to create div tags so
first of all we'll write here
div we'll take this particular div tag
for the game and we'll write here
another div with
ids
game fine
now we have two div tags over here now
what we'll do first is we'll add images
for
red car and for blue car right so what
we'll do is we'll take two div tags and
we'll write here id
as
blue car
for the blue car
and then we'll write here
img
src the source will be
blue dot png so we have a file named
blue dot png which is actually an image
and what we'll do is we'll write here
alt
so the alternate will be
blue car fine
we'll
copy this piece of code and we'll do the
same for red vehicle as well so instead
of blue car we'll name the id as red car
the image source we have in our computer
is red dot png
and alternate will be
red car fine
now we have added the two cars toward
div tag or we can say to a html file
save it go to the browser so this is our
document you can see here we have a blue
car and we have a red car you can see we
have both images over here but the size
is different the blue car looks big and
the red one is pretty small right not to
worry we'll figure it out in the css
part
so let's do the rest of the html part
here what we'll do is we'll move to our
html file again and
now one thing you might have noticed in
the game here is
on collision we are getting a card for
game over so we have to create this div
tag as well so let's finish the html
part first what we'll do is
we'll write here div
again and this time the id will be
resolved so we are
preparing for the game over part right
now what we'll do is we'll write here h1
heading
so inside h1 we'll write
game over so let me show you why we are
doing this so if you can see here on
collision we have game over right so
game over we have to write here now what
we'll do is we'll write here
game over like this the next thing we
need is the score so what we'll do is
we'll write here p
so we'll use the paragraph tag the id
will be score
and the score will do in javascript part
now what we have to do is we have to add
the restart button as well so for that
we'll write here button
id is equals to
let's say btn
and we'll use the on click event so on
click we'll write here
location dot
reload
we'll call this function so this is a
built-in function in javascript what
this function will do is it will refresh
the whole page fine the game will start
again
so
we have added another div tag for the
score here we have a heading game over
and a paragraph with ideas score and
then we have a button to reload the web
page
now let's style these elements and make
them look like a game so what we'll do
is
we'll move to the css file now here's a
css file we'll
first write here some code for the whole
html document so for inside this we'll
define margin
and the default margin will be zero
similarly we'll define padding as well
so the default padding will also be zero
now
the next thing we have to do is we have
to write here
some code for the body
fine here what we'll do is we'll use two
colors at a specific angle of 45 degrees
we have already been through the webcam
linear gradient property in the previous
game which is flappy bird so what we'll
do is we'll write here let's take a
background color let's say the
background color is this kind of sky
blue now the next thing we'll do is
we'll take a background image and inside
this will write
webkit linear gradient we have already
been through this in the previous game
so we'll write here 45 degree
this is the angle
and then we'll define two colors here
so our two colors will be
gray
and the next one will also be gray but a
little bit different from this one so
we'll write here 45 percent it will take
45 percent of the screen
and then we'll write here hash so this
is the code for dark grey color and it
will take the rest 55 percent of the
screen fine save it for now go to the
web browser so you can see here we have
two different colors present over here
in a web browser the colors are divided
at an angle of 45 degree what we can do
here is we can write here
50 50 instead for both the colors
save it now move to the browser and here
you can see
you can clearly spot the difference here
so here you can see these two colors are
different now
we'll leave it here you can do this
thing as you wish so
moving ahead we'll write here min
height will be
800 pixels
fine save it now move to the browser and
here you can see we have a
background color set for this particular
web page
now
so after the body tag we'll do some
styling for the game container so here
you can see we have the ids game for the
first div tag so what we'll do is we'll
write here
game we'll
we'll write some properties here we'll
write here height so the height will be
500 pixels
then we'll write here
width the width of the box is let's say
300 pixels
and the border will also define so the
border will be black
and
border will be one pixel thick
solid and black in color fine save it
you can see over here
so we can't see anything for now so
let's
style this first completely
what we'll do is we'll write here margin
so the margin will be
one ram
auto
now
right here we'll write background image
so the background image is the one we
already have in a folder the name for
that image is road1.png
now i will write here background
size so we'll write here
contain to fit this image inside the
container and we'll write here overflow
as
hidden
fine
save it
move to the browser and here you can see
now we have a div tag present over here
we have a container over here and we
have the blue image only for now now
what we'll do next is
we'll style these images as well so
first we'll do the same for blue car
we'll write here
blue car and inside this will write
height as 100 pixels
width
will be 130 pixels so there's a specific
reason behind writing this 130 pixel
will understand it later
now the background color for this car
will be let's say blue for the blue one
and we'll write here
position
so the position will be
relative
next up we'll write here
top
top will be
zero pixels so remember the value for
these properties we'll need them later
in the javascript part
now what we'll do next is we'll write
here left as
0 pixels
now next up
we'll write here text align as
center
and
animation so this animation we have
already been through it
now what we'll do is we'll write here
move
after one second the animation should be
linear
and
it should be infinite fine now this
animation we have to define but before
that we'll write here blue car img so
here what we'll do is we'll define the
height of image
we'll write a height as 100 pixels
fine
now save this
go to the browser and here you can see
we have a blue car present at the top
left corner of our container now what
we'll do is we'll define the animation
for this particular div tag right so
here is our car present at the top left
corner so what we'll do is we'll move
this box to the middle of the screen so
we have already done it i guess
but there is some mistake
so here you can see we have given space
between one ramp save it now
and here you can see we have a box
present at the center of our screen
now we are good to go next up we'll
define the animation so we'll write here
at the rate
keyframe
and
instead of identifier the identifier we
have
here is
move
fine so inside this will write here
zero percent at zero percent
the top will be
zero fine zero pixels
and at hundred percent the top will be
501 pixels
fine
now one thing to notice here is
the total height of the container is 500
pixels and the animation will go till
501 pixels save it now
move to the browser and here you can see
the car is still not moving
so we have made a mistake here so here's
a mistake we have to write here move
only save it now
and here you can see the animation is
going swiftly now so the car starts from
0 pixel and goes to 501 pixel so it will
happen infinitely because we have
used a infinite inside the animation
property
what we'll do next is we'll do the same
for
red car as well fine so here you can see
we have a red car the id is red car for
this so what we'll do is we'll write
here
hash red car
and we'll start styling this
red car as well the height will remain
the same the height will be 100 pixels
and then we have the width
the width will be 130 pixels for this
car as well
the background color will be
red because the color color is also red
position will be relative for this as
well
the top will be 250 pixels let's say
and the left will be
130 pixels fine
now what we are doing here is we are
taking the left as 130 pixels why so
because what we want is we want the car
to be present at 130 pixels away from
the left corner of the box
so that's why we have written 130 pixels
over here inside the left property
now the next thing we'll write here is
text align and text line will be sent
fine
we'll do the same thing for red car as
well here we'll write here red car
img
we have to write here hash as well
now inside this we'll define the height
of this image
we'll write here height as 100 pixels
fine
save it now
go to the browser and here you can see
we have a red and blue car over here now
the box seems to be a little bit less
wide for these two cars so what we'll do
is we'll
write the width here as 390 pixels
so that it will be divided equally in
three parts save it now
and here you can see now this box looks
totally fine we have a red car present
in the center we can move it to the left
and to the right
so we are done with styling these three
images next up we have to style the
result part as well right so here you
can see in this particular game we have
a card over here with
a different background the game over
color is white
and this color is gray i guess the
button color is black and the restart
color is
sky blue fine so we have to keep all
these things in mind we have to style
this box as well so what we'll do is
we'll write here
result
and inside this will write
height height will be
200 pixels for this box
then we'll write here
width
and width will be 400 pixels so we want
a rectangle for this
next up we'll write here background
color
so let's define the rgb value
the rgb value for this particular color
is 231
comma 1 0 5 comma
1 0 5
that's because we want to make the exact
same game so that's why we are using the
rgb values here
save it now
move to the browser
and here you can see we have the game
over card over here
and the game over color is black and the
card color is pinkish we can say
now we'll move to a css file we'll write
here
margin and the margin will be
one ram
or two
next up we'll write here
border radius so we want the box to be a
little bit round from the edges
so for that we'll write here border
radius as 20 pixels
and then we have
font size is
30 pixels for game over
then we'll write here
text align we want to align the text at
the center of this box
game over color will be white fine so
we'll write here white and we are done
with it
save it
and here you can see we have a box over
here we have a game over card over here
now what we want is we want to hide this
thing right so for that we have to write
here
display as
none save it now and you can see we
don't have this game over box over here
anymore
now moving back to our css file what
we'll do is
we'll remove this particular statement
for now save it and here's our box again
we'll add this property later so for now
what we'll do is we'll write here
score
now what we have to do is we have to
write here
font
size
as
2.2 ram
i hope you guys must have searched for
the ram keyword
now we'll discuss this keyword again in
the next video
so for now we'll write here
color and the color will be
let's say
take any color of your choice
so we'll write here gray
or we can say let's take golden rod i
don't know which color is it but let's
take it once
save it
and you are not getting anything over
here because we haven't defined it yet
so we'll see it later now the last thing
we have to do here is with the button
right so we'll use the button id for
that we'll write here btn
and inside this will write padding
so padding will be 0.5 ram
and
1 ram for
left
now we'll write here
border radius for this button is 20
pixels because the button is a little
bit round at the corners
next up we'll write here
border is
none we don't need any border for this
particular button
then we'll write here background color
is let's say
black
will write here
the color is
which color we should take let's take
this one
now we'll write here margin
top so let's say the margin top will be
10 pixels
next up we'll write here
cursor
so cursor will be
point fine cursor will change to pointer
on taking it over the restart button
we'll write here
text
transform we want to transform this text
to uppercase
fine save it now move back to the
browser and here you can see we have a
game over here but this tag is not
working for now
so let's see what's wrong here
okay so we have to write here restart
save it now
and here you can see we have a button
over here we have a restart button over
here the button looks a little bit small
so what we have to do is we have to do
some styling change here
we'll take
let's say the font size
so we'll write here
font size is let's say 25 pixels
save it now
and here you can see the button is quite
right now
so we are done with it what we'll do is
we'll add the display property here
we'll write here display
none save it
and the box is gone fine
now we are done with the css part as
well now we have to make this game
responsive only that will do with the
help of javascript
so let's move on to the javascript file
first
here's a javascript file now we'll
access all the html elements here in the
javascript file
because we need them so what we'll do is
we'll write here where blue car is
equals to document
dot get element by id so the id for blue
car is
blue car
we'll write here where
red
car document dot
get element by id
so the id is red car for the red one
next up
we'll write here where
our result will
get result as well we'll write your
document dot
get element by id and inside this will
write
a result fine we are accessing all the
elements with the help of get element by
id method
now what we'll do is we'll write here
where score
so the score will write your
document.getelementbyid and again we'll
write here score
then we'll write here where
game document dot
get element by id the id4 game is
game
fine
we'll take another variable here let's
say the variable name is variable
counter
to count the number of cars passing
through the red one to get the final
score basically so we'll initialize the
value as 0 for this counter variable
now the next thing we have to do is to
make the blue car move randomly in three
positions right
for that we'll use math dot random
function again we have used this
function previously in the flappy birds
game
so we'll write here
blue car dot add event listener will add
an event
so we'll write here
animation iteration so this is a
predefined event listener in javascript
so for this we'll create a function here
we'll write here
function and will define the function as
well fine
so we'll take a variable let's say
random
and we'll write here math dot
floor
math dot random
so this is a predefined function in
javascript we'll write here into 3
and right here we'll write 130 fine
why 130 because 130 is the default width
which we have taken in a css file
so
we'll write here
blue car dot
style
dot
left
is equals
to the value of random in
pixels fine
then we'll increase the value of counter
after every car passes through after
every blue car passes through the red
one save it and move to the browser
you can see
the blue car has three positions over
here can either come from the left
right or from the center any random
number from these three numbers will get
multiplied to 130 so we have three
positions only any random position let's
say the position is one it means that
the car is present at the left
so that particular number will be
multiplied with 130 and the left value
of the blue car will change to that
particular number
the logic is simple if the number
randomly taken is 2 then the random
value will become 260 in that case and
the blue car will have a distance of 260
pixels from the left side of the
container
so this was the reason behind taking the
width of container as 390. i hope you
guys can relate to it now so let's move
ahead and write the code for moving the
red car as well so you can see the red
car is not moving as of now will make it
move so let's write the code for that as
well
we'll move to a javascript file
and we'll write here
window dot add event listener will add
an event here
we'll write here
key down
and we'll define a function here fine
so we'll take a parameter inside this
function now what we'll do is we'll
write here if
e dot
key code
is equals to is equals to
39
and then what will happen is
we'll take a variable where
red car left
is equals to
we'll write here percent
window
dot
get
computed style
will get the computed style of
red car
and we'll write here get
property value fine we'll take the
property value here we'll take the left
value so we'll write here left
and we'll write here if
red car left
is less than
260 pixels
then
red car
dot style
dot left
will change to red car left
plus
130
and the value will change to
pixels as well fine
now
we'll write the code for another key as
well so we have to add two keys over
here
what we'll do is
we'll write here if
e dot
key code
is equals to is equals to
37
this key code over here represents the
left and the right arrow key of a
keyboard so that's why we are using here
key code as 37 and 39
39 is the default key code for the right
arrow key and 37 is for the left arrow
key
so what we'll do here is we'll write
here where red car left
is equals to percent so what we'll do is
we'll copy this from here
and we'll paste it here fine
this will remain the same
now what we'll do is we'll write here if
red car left is greater than 0
then
it will change the
style so we'll write here
this
and here what we'll do is we'll change
the value of red car to red car left
minus 130 pixels so we are moving the
car to the left or to the right fine
now we are done with it
now save it
and move to the browser and now here you
can see we are able to move the red car
to the left or to the right as well fine
now we are good to go so the next thing
we have to do is to write the code for
collision of these two cars or we can
say the function for game over as well
fine
so let's head back to our javascript
file and we'll create another function
over here
so what we'll do is we'll take certain
values and pass them through some
conditions
if any of the requirements fail then the
game is over the logic is simple let's
implement this logic
so what we'll do is we'll write here set
interval so we'll use the set interval
method
and we'll write here
function so let's say the function name
is
game over will
now define the body of this function
now let's discuss some things what we
need is we need the top property of blue
car we need the left property of blue
car and then we need the left property
of a red car fine so we'll take three
variables we'll write here
where
blue car top
then we'll take where
blue car left
and then we'll take where red car left
fine
so we have these three variables over
here now what we'll do is we'll write
will get these values first so we'll
again use the get computed style
property and the get property value
we'll write here percent and inside this
we'll write
window dot
get computed style so the computed style
is of the blue car
then we'll write here
get property value we'll write here
top because we need the top value we'll
do the same thing for
blue car left and for
red car left fine so we'll change the
values here
we'll write here left for the blue car
left
and we'll write here
left for the
red car
fine
we are good to go we have these three
variables
and we have the properties right we have
the value of these particular properties
now we'll write here certain conditions
we'll use the if statement again
we'll write here if
blue car left
is equals to
red car left
let's replace this left with a capital l
and we'll write here and then blue card
top
is
greater than
250
and blue car top is also less than 450
so we need the blue car in between 250
and 450 for collision right what we'll
do is
we'll write here result
dot
style
dot display so will change the display
property of a result element will write
here
is equals to
block
now we need a game over card over the
game and we'll also change the display
property of game as well we'll write
here game dot
style dot display
as
none fine we don't want the game for
this now the next thing we'll do is
we'll write here score so for that we'll
write it score
dot inner html
is equals to
let's say it says your score is
and we'll write here
dollar we have a variable counter right
we'll print the value of
counter here fine
now there is an error over here you can
see so what we have to do is
we have to put them
inside this
will not use
the double inverted commas we'll use
this instead
and you can see the error over here is
gone now
so we are good to go
now after that we'll change the value of
counter to 0 again in case the user
wants to restart the game
the value of counter will start from 0
again now we want to call this function
after a certain interval of time so
we'll write here 10
and we are good to
so the set interval method will be
called after 10 milliseconds
now the same thing we did for flappy
birds as well so some conditions here
are almost same and the output is also
the same as we had for flappy birds
now
save it and you can see on the browser
that our game is completely fine now
it's working totally fine so we can play
this game
now let's play it once so here you can
see we can move our red car and the blue
car is coming randomly from any of the
three directions it means that it can
either come from the left or from the
center or from the right fine on
collision you can see it shows that the
game is over and the score is 13. now
one clicking the restart button we can
restart the game the page reloads again
and it's working totally fine now
we have to create this particular game
and we can see that the game is
completely done we can play this game
anytime
and it's fun as well of course
so we can do certain things with the
graphics as well i want you guys to do
that thing and let us know in the
comments below what else can we do to
make this game more appealing to the
user and with that we come to the end of
this full course tutorial if you enjoyed
watching the video do give it a thumbs
up comment your doubts below and the
experts will answer them for you thank
you so much for being here watch out for
more videos from us until then keep
learning and stay tuned to simply
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you